a room that was specifically designed
for cocaine
um his his colleagues told him about how
a lot of times
um on Charters there's the main boat and
then a boat that follows it that's for
prostitutes uh he found a weed Buffet on
another boat I mean this is like serious
partying stuff and these people do not
mess around serious partying and also
serious money Chris what are the legal
implications for the other people on the
boat like could the deckhand get in
trouble for being escorted into the coke
room yeah so um so that was a privately
owned boat by by like uh by a person it
wasn't a charter boat
um but you know a lot of the sort of
culture of the 70s and 80s when there
were like a lot of drugs on these yachts
in the Mediterranean and the Caribbean
has stopped because you can actually get
um you can get busted for trafficking if
they find any kind of Narcotics on your
ships weed is a little bit different but
a lot of the the cocaine culture is
actually on land these days for among
the Brokers and the partying Okay so the
dicans can can stay pristine and all
that if if we do manage to get a job you
know one day as a deckhand how much
money could we bring in in tips so the
salary for deckhand is about 3 000 a
month but on a good summer you can earn
up to fifty thousand dollars in tips and
if you work on a private boat for a year
you could get a Breitling watch for a
Year's worth of work or a Rolex for five
years wow sounds like a lot of perks and
kind of befriending the other folks who
are on the ship uh Chris one anecdote
from the article that I was fascinated
with is this idea that the deck hands
see the lavish lifestyle and they want
to act that way as well can you tell me
about that yeah I think people you know
they watch the show below deck on Bravo
they see this sort of fabulous life and
then when they're up close and personal
with it they feel like when they go on
land and Mika knows they should be going
to the clubs too so they find themselves
buying the same Gucci sunglasses that
the passengers buy hopefully luck if
they're lucky someone will have left a
nurse scar for something on board and
you can tie that on but uh yeah they
find that their they end up paying for
the same kind of bottle service and high
life when they're off the ship that
their clients do yeah that's where that
fifty thousand dollar tip goes to
um how much of these boats cost I
mentioned Jeff Bezos has a giga yacht
that he's working on or someone's
working on for him yeah so that one is
going to cost 500 million dollars
estimated and that most of them aren't
that expensive but they cost about a
million dollars for every three feet and
we Define a super yacht as up to 120 is
120 feet or more so that's starting at
40 million dollars and that's before you
get you know necessary add-ons like a
Jacuzzi like a helicopter pad you know
right thing that you can't really do
without on your super yacht you know
what we forgot to ask what is it that
these deckhands do obviously they have
to earn their keep like what what are
their jobs what are they up to they do
everything I mean they said they're like
you know they do a lot of like waiter
type service but they also do a
tremendous amount of cleaning the Salt
Air is incredibly destructive as are the
passengers anytime they spray on
sunblock they ruin all the surfaces our
um our reporter found himself removing
Fried Chicken skin Flakes with a tweezer
from teak floors
they're they're constantly Vigilant
doing sort of everything that you could
possibly need in a private house which
is basically what those boats are is
there anything really quickly here that
passengers on the ships don't know about
that you think that they should they
don't know that they're always being
watched you know it may seem obvious but
you know there's cameras everywhere and
there's always someone watching to make
sure you don't need anything so anything
from like if you pick mushrooms out of
your food the chef then knows later to
not serve those mushrooms to if you're
naked sunbathing someone's gonna see it
if you pass out drunk with no clothes on
the deck hands are going to see it so or
you'll never forget Ben Affleck has his
hand on your butt I guess the duck hands
are going to see that
I wanted people to see that yeah along
with the rest of the world I'm going to
watch succession with new respect now
you know they have that a couple of
episodes on the yacht and like now
rethinking everything that's happening
on that show
oh my gosh I know oh Chris thank you so
much Chris Rouser of Bloomberg Pursuits
and Chris is going to join US Weekly for
uh different takes on on what's going on
in the luxury world this is fantastic he
had a really good piece too on personal
shoppers at Barney's that I was
fascinated with he said that uh one of
them became best friends with Rihanna
and actually ended up going to her
wedding so it seems like the perks
abound in these kind of you can marry
friends with the talent with the Stars
yeah you don't have to deal with the
fame you just get to reap the benefits
ah okay maybe maybe there's reason again
to to look into these undercover
reporting talks yes that does it for a
quick take this hour follow us on
Twitter at quick take for the latest
headlines and of course add our own
individual Twitter handles I'm at
Scarlet Foo I'm at Madison mills22 have
a great night everyone
foreign
[Music]
coming up on quick take the lead with
lash on covid prevention tactics
establishments grapple with renewed Mass
guidance amid the vaccine rollout and
what seemed to be a return to normal
we'll have everything you need to now
know about masks and more
and Deep South Coal Miners take to the
streets of the Big Apple demanding help
in an ongoing Union dispute we were
there live and we'll tell you everything
you need to know
and a new wave of Mobility meet the
so-called Tesla of the sea electric
boats are making a splash on the
eco-friendly scene we'll talk to the CEO
of a Swedish company leading the pack
it's Wednesday July 28th I'm Madison
Mills and I'm Scarlett so we've got
those stories and more coming up on
quick kick the lead
foreign
[Music]
we begin with the latest on the pandemic
today States and businesses in the U.S
scrambling to change course after the
federal government issued new guidance
calling for vaccinated people in some
parts of the U.S to mask up indoors
Tuesday's announcement from the centers
of Disease Control and prevention is
limited to locations with high
transmission rates so what does that
mean it's when more than 50 cases per
100 000 people are in any given area so
joining us by phone to discuss what this
all means for the coming months is
Bloomberg News senior health editor Drew
Armstrong Drew Armstrong Drew always
great to chat with you really quickly I
want to hit on this new guidance where
in the U.S do people definitely need to
mask up again
well it's actually a surprisingly large
number of places where we're seeing
um case rates increase all over the
place right now
um frankly though a lot of that is
concentrated in hot spots
um you know along the uh along the South
and Central regions of the country in
particular there's this band of cases
happening right now in uh Louisiana
Arkansas and Missouri we also seeing
huge amounts of cases in Florida
um right now and then also a significant
cluster kind of in the Northeast here
along the Northeast Corridor where we
are seeing a rise in cases in you know
the New York City area some in Boston
and you know in places like La as well
this really is a a bit of a national
phenomenon right now another national
phenomenon that's some good news to
celebrate here is that vaccination rates
are starting to increase and I know you
just did some great reporting on this
Drew tell me a little bit about what you
think is causing the increase in
vaccinations over the last seven days
well if you talk to people who are on
the ground
um in uh in these in these places where
these vaccination rates are climbing um
you know again a lot of this is really
concentrated in those three states that
I mentioned you know Missouri Arkansas
and Louisiana there are people who you
know it's been a while since there's
been a surge in those in those places
but all of a sudden there's a lot of
people who are you know vaccine
reluctant or vaccine hesitant or even
vaccine refusers who now know somebody
who is getting sick I talked to
Louisiana State Health officer a guy
named Joseph Kennard he said you know
they're seeing their hospitalizations go
through the roof right now but along
with that you know he said everybody
knows someone who's sick right now there
are those people who are not real
anti-vaxxers but they were just not
maybe confident in the vaccine and he
says they're saying things like I'm not
waiting a day longer and they're going
out and getting shots because they see
what's happening around them is
Louisiana the state in the U.S though
that has the lowest vaccination rate so
far is that correct they're they're the
fourth lowest in in the US they've been
a laggard for a long time and I and I
have to say I mean listen vaccination
return up in these places but it would
take months for them to catch up to some
of the leading places in the U.S right
that you see you know in in Vermont and
you know in the Northeast and places
like that so how long do you anticipate
this increased vaccination rate to go on
you know um I I think that remains to be
seen you know if this is a if this is a
long-term Trend
um you know but it does tell you that
there is room to move people here um
that stayed out you know State Health
and state local Health officials have
been trying to do you know they've been
trying everything they can begging
people to go get vaccinated putting
incentive programs out you know working
with people's doctors local community
leaders they are really really pushing
hard on this but you know um
unfortunately fear attempts to it
appears to be it's one of the Prime
motivating factors that's pushing people
into going getting these shots well
speaking of fear drew a lot of the
people who did their part and went out
and got the vaccine are among the more
health conscious and that's causing them
to continue to have coveted anxieties
particularly as the highly contagious
Delta variant continues to spread I know
that the CDC has been investigating
clusters where vaccinated people might
have infected others and finding that in
those cases the vaccinated people had
higher levels of viral load what does
that mean
well you know it's this it's this
interesting situation with the Delta
variant that you know we all we know is
more contagious but one of the reasons
why it is is because it the virus tends
to replicate much much faster
um which means that you know even if
you're vaccinated it still takes a
little while for your immune system to
catch up so basically you've got a whole
lot of virus that you know if you are
talking or coughing or you know
breathing may be coming out because
there's just more of it there early on
which means that if you're vaccinated
but you're still kind of in that window
where your immune system hasn't really
geared up and gone to war and smashed
these things down you can still be
spreading it to other people that's a
real change from some of the other
variants and the original strains of
this virus where you know vaccinations
were basically shown against those
strains to quash the thing before it
ever really got going because it didn't
replicate quite as fast and you
basically didn't have as much virus
kicking around in your body really great
explanation there Drew really quickly as
we wrap up I remember couple months ago
talking to you on the show and you were
joining us in the office your mask was
off you mentioned going to dinner the
night before
um do you think that we're going to be
able to keep that optimistic view as the
Delta variant does continue to spread I
mean are we going to be going out to
dinners with our masks off
you know it's a great question and I
think these are things that everybody
has to decide for themselves you know
the good news is that you know even
though we do have this issue of
contagion you know the risk to
individuals who've been vaccinated
you're still not seeing you know you're
seeing the kind of same protection
against severe disease that said I have
a bunch of friends who are vaccinated
and have gotten sick with covet and like
being sick sucks and in addition to that
you have people who worry about taking
back an illness to somebody else in
their household who might not be
vaccinated right um being a little more
cautious than I than I was previously
yeah yeah I mean I I can I think I hear
your child in the background they're
making their needs known yeah yeah it's
a it's definitely something to consider
and something I feel like a lot of
working parents are worried about as we
still look for more information about
vaccinations among kids uh Bloomberg
senior Healthcare editor Drew Armstrong
always appreciate you joining us to talk
all things covid Scarlett well starting
next week fully vaccinated American and
European Union Travelers will no longer
need to spend 10 days in quarantine when
when arriving in England
meanwhile you've got International
cruises that'll also resume after being
put on hold for more than a year it's
now unlikely that the Biden
Administration will reciprocate anytime
soon U.S health officials advising
Americans to avoid traveling to the UK
due to a surge in infections and in
other coveted news a U.S Senate
committee postponed a hearing today
after some of its members were
potentially exposed to the coronavirus
Michigan senator Gary Peters says his
panel delayed the hearing but declined
to name which lawmakers were possibly
exposed the news comes after the top
position of Congress reimposed a mass
mandate for lawmakers when they're on
the house floor in hallways and in their
offices
and New York City offering an incentive
for vaccine hesitators get the first
dose of a coveted shot at a city run
site show proof that you live or work in
the city and after that you get a
hundred dollars through prepaid debit
cards incentives can be redeemed as
starting Friday and of course this week
the city said all Municipal workers are
required to get the shot or submit to
weekly testing so it looks like they can
get paid for that now
for the latest coveted news at bookmark
bloomberg.com forward slash coronavirus
Maddie well coming up after the break
we'll look at the challenges social
media platforms like Facebook have to
contend with when it comes to
misinformation this is quick Take the
Lead
foreign
[Music]
access the financial World On Demand
foreign hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
just talked about the spread of the
Delta variant the problem globally is a
lack of access to vaccines here in the
U.S there's a surplus of the shots a lot
of the vaccine hesitancy can really be
chalked up to misinformation and
conspiracy theories proliferating on
social media President Biden has called
on big Tech and its leaders to address
this but so far little action has been
taken so let's bring in Jim Anderson CEO
of social flow now to discuss what else
could be done Jim it's always good to
have you on quick take I feel like no
matter what steps Facebook or any other
social media platform takes to address
misinformation they will always be five
to ten steps behind it's like
whack-a-mole here would spending more
money to hire more monitors or tweaking
algorithms change anything
well it would certainly help I mean
you're right it is a game of
whack-a-mole and the analogy I used
before is it's a little bit like trying
to get the weeds out of your garden
except you're a single Gardener and
you're trying to Garden all the corn
fields in Iowa right it's just a massive
problem and no matter what you try you
hire a 100 moderators a thousand I
believe Facebook is tens of thousands of
moderators and it's still not enough uh
that doesn't mean you shouldn't try that
doesn't mean you shouldn't hire the
moderators but let's be realistic here
when you're talking about billions and
ultimately trillions uh in reach uh and
and billions of pieces of content
there's only so much you're going to be
able to do right and I also think about
the fact that it's certainly not limited
to Facebook or Twitter um how do you
think about the scale of misinformation
that that's out there right now because
anything that acts as a social network I
imagine that there's problems on
LinkedIn as well and it happens in
places like China which has a closed
system Facebook and Twitter aren't even
allowed to operate but I'm sure things
on weibo there's probably stuff on weibo
that's not accurate either
yeah if you have an audience you have
the potential for misinformation
especially with user generated content
and the other point that I think is
really important to realize is you need
to follow the money if you want to
understand what's really going on here
people have lots of motivations but in
General Financial is one of the
strongest and so a lot of the
misinformation that's putting out being
put out there is actually being done for
profit and you might say well how in the
world are people profiting from
misinformation but they're selling books
they're selling merchandises quack
medical cures building audiences that
they then sell to sponsors and have
advertising against this whole variety
of profit mediums out there for somebody
who has built an audience and whether
the content is true or false sadly is
almost irrelevant so how do you make
that content less profitable how do you
make that message less profitable
well you do the things that we were just
talking about enforcement having clear
standards and one of the things Facebook
in particular has gotten in trouble uh
with in the past with its oversight
board is not having clear standards of
an adhering to them so misinformation we
know is a really tough thing to diagnose
you know there are things about the
vaccine how long did it take to develop
it was developed very quickly how much
testing was done probably less than
previous vaccines what's the vaccine
mechanism those are all true statements
that you can then add up to sort of
infer that the vaccine is somehow
dangerous which I think most reasonable
people would conclude is not the case at
least not for them but how do you make
the distinction between what's a true
statement and then ultimately what's
misleading and and that's really hard to
do from a platform standards perspective
because there's so much variance between
say what's going on with covid now and
some other type of misinformation say
around the election yeah setting
standards is exactly what none of these
platforms want to do because then it
turns them into teams of editors and
that that's pointedly what they're
trying to avoid being I want to go back
to that idea about how there are truths
underneath the vaccine skepticism the
questions that people are raising are
legitimate it's just the conclusions
that people draw as a result of those
questions being asked that's the problem
yeah without a doubt I mean vaccine
hesitancy is understandable right I mean
some people are hesitant about any form
of medicine or going to the doctor or
getting a shot and if you say well I'm
scared to get a shot or I'm just
hesitant to get a shot does that make
you a vaccine skeptic I think not right
it's a perfectly reasonable uh you know
a thing for people to ask you know is it
worth it to me and your health reporter
previously was talking about you know
these are very personal decisions things
like where do I wear a mask in certain
circumstances do I not vaccines are a
little bit different because it has an
impact Beyond just you but you know
ultimately people's personal health
decisions are their personal decision
and so we have to be careful not to
label any kind of hesitancy as flat out
misinformation the problem is is of
course people will then flip that for
their own profit right they'll say oh
you should definitely not get a vaccine
because it's dangerous and it hasn't
been tested and those are those are
demonstrably not true statements and so
drawing that line is what everybody has
to do and and that's what the platforms
are on the hook to do and and candidly
not doing a great job of it right now
would more rules on privacy and data a
collection make this less profitable
this misinformation and I bring this up
because Facebook just reported results
where it was fairly cautious when it
gave a outlook for the next quarter and
that's because Apple's new rules on data
collection is going to hurt its bottom
line
yeah I don't think data privacy is going
to affect the misinformation problem at
all it may affect Facebook and apple
although probably not as much as you
might think I mean Facebook is still you
know in record territory I think even
after with a sell-off after after the
markets they're still up probably 30
percent uh you know on the year so
Facebook just keeps having record
quarter after record quarter after
record quarter there are quite
legitimate privacy issues but I don't
think those are going to affect the
misinformation issue at all gotcha
distinct issues then Jim Anderson CEO of
social flow always great to speak with
you really appreciate your joining us
today
now we're staying staying with this
earnings idea Spotify could just be the
biggest name in music streaming but the
latest results showed it remains
vulnerable to the pandemic the Swedish
company added fewer new users than
expected in the second quarter
especially in global markets like India
the disappointing growth shares of
Spotify down as much as 10 today still
spotify's advertising business is
booming thanks in part to podcasts I
recently had a chance to sit down with a
top executive in charge of spotify's
engineering chief of research and
development officer Gustav soderstrom
Gustav was once quoted as saying he
wants to make Spotify the r d of the
music industry so I asked him to explain
what he meant by that
most other Industries they have a lot of
r d they have a lot of smart people
working on building products for them
and the thing that struck me about the
music industry was I mean it's it's all
the labels and the labels had at least
back then they had very few Engineers
there just wasn't any or in the in the
music industry at all they were just
they were just monetizing the IP they
had and they relied on someone else CD
makers or iTunes or something to do the
r d
and so I just wanted to set the ambition
and say like well music seems to have no
r d Department there's no one doing
there's no one innovating in on the
consumer side so let's make the goal uh
be that we are that r d department now
we have competing r d departments and
other companies that also try to
innovate that's a great outcome for the
music industry and for artists now
there's competition for for the consumer
experience
so it's thinking about breaking the mold
and how you can break the mold and how
you can reinvent what's been around
um exactly journalists and a lot of
people in PR who frankly let's face it
are former journalists tend to get lazy
and we like to use a lot of shorthand
for describing things and identifying
new themes so after Warby Parker came
out and disrupted the eyewear industry
there are a lot of you know new Warby
Parkers of blank so there's Warby Parker
for belts or something
um and then of course there was Uber
which became the in-demand economy right
there was uh Uber for private jets Uber
for blank
what do you think the shorthand is for
Spotify what do you want Spotify to be
shorthand for this what would it mean to
be the Spotify of blank so it's a great
question now I actually do see a lot of
pitches and Pitch Decks that does
include where the Spotify for for blank
and uh
so so that's not necessarily what I
would want it to mean
but what what that usually means is that
they take something where you paid per
item like music you paid per download
right or you paid per CD and you turn it
into an access model where you pay a
fixed fee or or you use advertising but
you you go from per item access or
download access to Flat access so I
think that's what most entrepreneurs
mean when they say with a Spotify for
something we take an industry we pay the
marginal cost per item and instead you
pay a flat access and what's interesting
about that is for music it turned out to
as as often is the case with what is
called bundling basically you can think
of the entire catalog now as a big
bundle all these tracks bundled together
for a single consumer price and that
turned out to maximize it took a long
time for the music industry to get back
after the pirate era but it's growing
very very quickly now so that turned out
to optimize the global industry for it
was a great consumer deal some more
consumers paid so that actually generate
more money to the music industry than
happen in the marginal cost model uh and
that's what I think people mean with the
Spotify 4 we turn this from a from a
sort of per item to a flat axis model
what do you want that that comparison to
mean in the future yeah I think you know
that we will be representative of
putting an access model business model
on top of a proactive model is is quite
a cool thing I guess it would also I
would love it for it to imply taking on
a complicated industry that most people
recommend against going into yeah
entrenched Industries which have no
interest at all in changing how they do
anything and breaking it apart and
putting it back together essentially the
important thing is there there's a lot
of talk about disrupting Industries but
that's not what Spotify did we actually
worked with the industry and the same
industry is bigger right and that's
important it's easy to say we're going
to go in and disrupt and kill this
industry Spotify is the opposite we
started negotiating with them from day
one it took us long and painful route
which is often recommended against the
the recommendation is to try to go in
and disrupt and Destroy but so the
record labels see Spotify as their
friend as rather than their enemy
for sure I mean with the where the
majority of their of the revenue now
streaming is what about musicians though
a lot of musicians
um say they can't make a livable wage
off of their their streaming proceeds
it's a very complicated question I mean
we try to look at are we are we growing
the pie or not is there more and more
money going to rights holders every year
and that's super clear it's growing very
very fast and you know beyond the the
what was called the Golden Days of the
of the city industry and we're also
looking at you know
it's our our deals with the what the
labels are while not transparent quite
well known we pay out the vast majority
of any dollar we make to the rights
industry now there are many complicated
um
there are many complicated Parts in
between there and when what revenues
Creator sees and you also have many many
more people participating now and
creating music which
obviously it's a great thing I mean we
want more creators I think most creators
thinks it's great that more creators get
a chance but that also means that while
the pie is growing there are also more
craters at the same time so it's a very
complicated
question to to solve we're trying to be
transparent with what we're doing and
we're trying to be fair and how we pay
out
from Chief r d officer of spotify and by
the way host of the podcast Spotify a
product story that offers an inside
account of product development at the
company Maddie let's get you some other
Tech headlines Google and Facebook
employees will have to get a vaccine to
get back into the office now apple is
requiring masks in half its U.S stores
starting this Thursday Google CEO Sundar
pichai made the announcement about
vaccines on Wednesday the company also
says it'll be postponing its return to
office date by about a month now
staffers returning to Google are going
to have to show proof of vaccination
starting October 18th
Facebook's WhatsApp unit will face its
first find under the European Union's
data Protection Law the European data
protection board cleared the way for
Irish Regulators to find Facebook
WhatsApp set aside more than 91 million
dollars to pay potential fines for two
investigations from Ireland's privacy
agency that's according to an Irish
regulatory filing for November
and bad news for those of us already
struggling to swipe the credit card a
little less because there's another
social media platform getting in on the
e-commerce Game Twitter will allow
businesses and retailers to sell to
users directly through their profiles
now it's only being piloted right now
but some businesses are already testing
out ways to enable sales on the Twitter
app
for the latest tech news bookmark
bloomberg.com forward slash technology
and coming up after the great the break
a huge group of coal miners and their
supporters landed in the heart of New
York and one of the biggest Asset
Management firms in the world we'll tell
you why when we're back in two minutes
[Music]
foreign
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
fight down south takes its mission to
financial firm BlackRock and went out to
speak with some of these workers and
find out what they're looking to get out
of their long time strike
amen brothers and sisters
union workers are gathering right behind
me right outside of the Black Rock
building they're organizing here today
in hopes that BlackRock which is a big
investor in the company that owns these
mines will actually take a stand in
their investments in that company
see what rock input pressure on the
negotiating team to come to a decent
contract to actually come and bargain
with us in good faith they have enough
stock that they could put that pressure
there they themselves could step in and
speak out for us speak out for the
workers while they're living the way
they're living is because of us
that's the reason why they're able to
live the way they live it's because we
do what we do uh we go underground we
put our lives on the line for our
families and it's time for them to give
us what we deserve in 2016 is where your
met was trying to emerge from bankruptcy
the miners took pay and benefit Cuts
just to keep their jobs wear your met
cold their investors are at BlackRock
and basically our miners got them out of
bankruptcy but they refused to give us a
fair contract officials at BlackRock
declined to comment on Warrior met the
Striking miners choice to involve
BlackRock is just the latest example in
a movement of different groups asking
their asset managers to take a stand on
investments the miners are now looking
for pay and benefit increases beyond
what more your met is offering we'll
have to wait and see how all this shakes
out for these workers who again are on
month five of their strike for now I'm
Madison Mills in front of Blackrock in
New York
and this is not the first time that
BlackRock has drawn protests last
February before the start of covid
climate activists occupied the BlackRock
headquarters in Paris to protest its
investments in companies that damaged
the environment but what can and what
should BlackRock do about its
Investments Bloomberg's animasa has
covered BlackRock for years as a
reporter on the asset management team
and she joins us now great to speak with
you and welcome to the show uh coal
miner that I spoke with today told me
that she protested to kind of convince
BlackRock to pressure the company to use
their board votes to get where you're
met to really make a change what do you
envision Larry Fink's response to that
might be
well the response that BlackRock has
typically had to protest like this and
as you mentioned there have been many
over the course of the years that I've
been covering BlackRock the typical
response is we're a fiduciary on behalf
of our clients we oversee client money
and it's not our decision necessarily to
invest in XYZ company but that that
argument is increasingly wearing thin
for people and it hasn't managed to stem
the tide of protests that we're seeing
on the social side on the environmental
side against BlackRock specifically
okay Annie BlackRock is clearly the
world's biggest asset manager I mean the
numbers are astronomical nine and a half
trillion dollars in assets under
management it's definitely the biggest
shareholder in Warrior met with a 15
stake but if you look at companies in
the S P 500 it's also one of the biggest
shareholders in apple in GM in Citigroup
it's hard to find a publicly traded
company in which BlackRock is not one of
the biggest shareholders explain to us
why that is why BlackRock is everywhere
that's exactly right in fact if you go
down the list BlackRock it for 99 of s p
500 companies you're going to find
Blackrock in the top five holders so as
you said it is everywhere the reason
that BlackRock is such a major holder of
so many of those recognizable companies
has to do with how its business is
structured and it's one of the biggest
index fund managers in the world so of
that 9.5 trillion dollars in assets that
you mentioned two-thirds of that is
coming from index funds those aren't
funds where there's really oversight oh
there's really uh active oversight over
the companies that are going into the
fund those are Tethered to indexes so
that's why BlackRock has traditionally
made the argument that okay it oversees
trillions and trillions of dollars in
assets but such a large such a vast
proportion of that is in these indexed
tethered funds
so given what you just mentioned that
BlackRock doesn't really decide what
goes into these ETFs that passively
track an index someone else does like
the guys who make the S P 500 would the
folks I spoke with today be better off
protesting against them instead
it's a great question I think some of
the frustration is coming because people
see that BlackRock is is out front with
statements about how we need to be
thinking about the environment and even
Finance needs to be reorienting itself
and companies need to be reorienting
themselves towards uh global warming and
addressing it more so when you're out
there on the record uh positioning
yourself that way and making changes to
your business to confront those problems
it it does make you an easier Target
maybe uh for activists like the ones
that you saw today
so Larry flank as you know has been out
front in talking about the need to look
at climate change as an investment
priority and I know in the past he has
said something about how BlackRock can't
just divest from companies that people
find objectionable but what they can do
is offer more funds that are focused on
sustainability Maddie that's something
that may not fly with the people that
you spoke with a hundred percent yeah
and I wonder if they would feel like
it's a little bit of the company kind of
having its cake and eating it too what
what do you make of that Annie
that's a really good point I mean
there's clear frustration uh at this end
of at this end of things and it's being
vented towards BlackRock I mean
BlackRock has made changes as a result
of I think things like climate change
but that's really not that's not enough
uh for people like the protesters that
you saw today and I think that for them
BlackRock can seem like this big opaque
kind of business uh that's a major owner
of the company that's aggravating them
and as a result they're they're seeing
it as a perfect Target yeah well said
okay so BlackRock one of the top five
owners shareholders of 99 of the S P 500
the other names you'll always see up
there are State Street and Vanguard yet
neither of those two firms seem to get
as much attention as BlackRock any why
do you think that is
I think that there is something to being
the biggest I the BlackRock is the
biggest asset manager in the world with
that more than nine trillion dollars in
assets so they're the largest and it's
easy to Target the largest one there's
also maybe a little bit of a sense that
Vanguard State Street they're not even
they're not based in New York or Wall
Street is so there may be an element
that uh BlackRock is here in New York
City kind of the center of finance and
uh it's a Target that way as well Annie
really really great perspective
Bloomberg investing and asset management
reporter Annie Massa thank you so much
now coming up new guidelines on home
appraisal language hopes to close the
race Gap will it be enough this is quick
Take the Lead
access the financial World On Demand
thank you hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
homework.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
access the financial World On Demand
foreign hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
number.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
this week's City lab we're taking a look
at the race Gap in home valuations
practices in the industry have been
criticized for continuing to widen that
Gap making it harder for certain
communities to build generational wealth
Fannie Mae is looking to change all of
that but will it be enough quick takes
Matthew albaney spoke with City Labs
Brenton mock about what to expect
to kick things off what exactly is
Fannie Mae looking to change when it
comes to how they describe home
appraisals and why are they doing this
foreign
basically they've issued a guidance
um where they're asking appraisers to
kind of change the language that they
use when they create their appraisal
evaluation reports when pricing homes
and I just I want to emphasize that it's
just a guidance it's not like a hard
rule on anything but basically Fannie
Mae is trying to help root out what's
called appraisal bias or racial
appraisal bias where this nagging
problem of historically homes and black
neighborhoods uh being appraised at much
lower values than similar or same homes
in white neighborhoods which are often
appraised at much much higher values and
so Fannie Mae is saying you know guys
when you fill out your reports try to
avoid language such as you know
crime-ridden neighborhoods you know
don't say that the house isn't an
affordable neighborhood don't say that
the house is in a desirable neighborhood
and you know basic quickly they're
acknowledging that all of these
signifiers these all in some ways kind
of signify class or race and if you say
it's an affordable neighborhood you know
that's often a you know coded language
for this is where poor people live or
this is where you know people of color
live since race and low income is often
tracks together
right and speaking to kind of the
historic issues the systemic issues that
go on with appraisals it seems like the
race Gap has not necessarily slowed down
what are some of the practices on the
side of the appraisers and the effects
that it does have on these homes
well you know the history of course is
is racial segregation and how um early
redlining practices
um basically basically signaled to to
Banks and lenders that properties in
black neighborhoods were too risky for
investment
um and also how Federal housing policies
um historically basically encouraged a
white homogeneity basically uniformly
white neighborhoods which signaled to
Banks and lenders that these are the
best neighborhoods for investment this
would in this would have the effect of
kind of of maximizing and optimizing
property values and and quote-unquote
white neighborhoods you know those kinds
of like race-based practices have been
outlawed by the fair housing act in 1965
the community reinvestment Act of 1977.
um however there was nothing put in
place to actually kind of cure the
um the undervaluing of black
neighborhoods and the and the
overvaluing of homes and white
neighborhoods that that was basically
already entered into the industry
current appraisal practices
um you know they and they kind of still
take into account uh the home values
that were set in the 20th century um
again like black homes on average I
think are valued somewhere
um well depending on the city but I
think Across the Nation 75 000 lower
than again same size same Design Homes
and white neighborhoods
right and when it comes to trying to
figure out kind of the cure to this
issue I I'm curious how people are
reacting to these changes that Fannie
Mae said that they want to implement or
the guidances that they want to
implement rather uh you point in your
article that racial composition is one
of the strong determinants of housing
values are these changes of words really
going to change anything or is it just
more or less a nice gesture
all right I think we'll see
um you know Fannie May just issued this
guidance
um in uh in June I reached out to a few
industry leaders
um about this and I didn't get a I
didn't get a direct comment at all
um about the language
um they may not have even known about it
honestly however you know I spoke with a
researcher Elizabeth uh Corbett Glenn
she's been researching a racial
appraisal bias and also uh racial bias
in the in the housing market in general
you know she basically wasn't buying it
she didn't think it was going to bring
any change at all because it doesn't she
for her she said it doesn't at all
substantively changed the way that
appraisers conduct their business today
um and so to use the an interesting
analogy of like a book publisher who
publishes cookbooks right you know
looking at how uh chocolate chip cookie
recipes have been printed and published
in that publishers books for years for
decades and then you know say some
health agency comes out and says you
know chocolate is unhealthy and she says
the publisher now tells her writers that
they should no longer use the word
chocolate in their chocolate chip cookie
recipes you know just call them I don't
know chip cookies
you know use any any other language but
don't use the word chocolate but you
haven't changed the actual ingredients
in the recipe you haven't changed the
way that it's baked and so the cookies
are made the same you just told the you
know you've just told the people that
they can't use these words anymore and
she says that's basically the same thing
that's happening now Fannie Mae hasn't
actually changed the way that appraisers
conduct their business they haven't
changed the practice
um all they've done is to say like don't
use these words
that was our Matt albani speaking with
City lab reporter Brenton mock now
coming up after the break would you ride
in a boat made of flaxseed that cost
tens of thousands of dollars you might
it's the next wave in clean Mobility
e-boats we'll explain when we're back
into
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring just to see what's
moving the markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
for today's movers and shakers the
people impacting the world of business
politics and sports Julian Assange is no
longer a citizen of Ecuador the country
stripped his citizenship after finding
irregularities in his naturalization
process Assange became Ecuadorian in
2018 as part of an attempt by then
president Lenin Moreno to get him out of
the country's London Embassy we lived
for seven years to avoid arrest the
Wikileaks co-founder was taken into
custody in 2019 after Ecuador withdrew
his Asylum status Assange is currently
in prison in the UK his lawyer says he's
going to appeal the ruling
Jared Kushner is planning to open an
investment company later this year the
firm will operate in Miami and Israel
for new person with knowledge of the
matter Reuters report says the Israel
office will pursue Regional Investments
to connect Israel's economy to India
North Africa and the gulf during
kushner's last year as a political
advisor to his father-in-law former
president Donald Trump he brokered a
deal between Israel and several other
Middle Eastern countries
actor Bob Odenkirk was rushed to a
hospital after collapsing on the set of
AMC's Better Call Saul on Tuesday it's
not clear what caused the collapse
Odenkirk was in Albuquerque New Mexico
filming the sixth and final season of
the Breaking Bad spin-off the 58 year
old is a four-time Emmy nominee for his
role as lawyer Saul Goodman
those are your movers and shakers from
today Scarlett well for the Rich and
Famous there's a new cool way to get
around this hot summer that may be
better for Earth an electric boat that's
being called the Tesla of the sea
Swedish company extra is cleaning up
emissions and in the process drawing
comparisons to Elon musk's vehicles for
its software and sleek and smart
features extra CEO Jenny casu joins us
now from Stockholm to discuss Jenny
welcome to Quick take for those of us
who aren't Sailors or boaters I'm not
sure if that's a word give us a brief
overview of electric boats and their
impact on the environment
of course so basically an average usage
of a typical combustion engine boat over
a summer compares to three and a half
years usage of a combustion engine cars
so the um the um amount of CO2 that
Leisure bulking industry is emitting is
huge and then you have noise pollution
as well and hence you need to change
that quickly and that is why we're
seeing electrification also in the
Boating industry now we are providing
smart Tech combined with a superior
Driving Experience and a sustainable
product and it's available now for order
so part of your sustainable product is
the material that it's made out of flax
fiber materials there's also cork
instead of traditional teak
um what about the safety of these new
materials how much testing has there
been done and is it is it testing that
really tests the limits of of these
vehicles given that it's it's pretty
quick to Market
also basically the founder of Connor
Bergstrom has been doing this in 2016 so
we have been in an r d phase for quite a
few years now and these are uh materials
that is not new for other Industries
just news for uh voting Industries so we
are certified in Europe and we are
certified in the US as well and we have
delivered products under certification
to three continents already
you mentioned that these boats are
available tell me what demand looks like
right now and which markets are growing
the fastest both Geographic and
demographic
so we are growing quickest now with the
Nordic region in the U.S and in Middle
East and we are seeing High demands so
we are scaling up production quickly we
recently uh opened our second Factory
which we will have fully up and running
in Sweden later this year and so next
year we will be able to provide our
customers with 450 additional boats we
have sold more than we can produce
talk about government regulations too
because especially in Europe where
you're based um the the push to go
fossil free is really gaining Steam and
it's pushing ahead the timeline as well
for the adoption of electric vehicles
including electric boats
oh of course so what we're seeing here
in the Privacy agreement is that we need
to uh stop uh emissions quickly and a
lot of emissions actually comes from
Leisure building and hence why we have
several countries now Banning uh
combustion engine in Leisure boats on
both lakes and near shore areas such as
Amsterdam Norway
Germany Switzerland Austria Etc
got it got it and I was looking at some
of the features they include a mobile
and Smartwatch app which unlocks and
turns on the boat when in range I I
gotta wonder is there going to be an
autopilot mode kind of like Tesla
well uh hopefully not too far out
hopefully not too far it's hard not to
make comparisons to Tesla Jenny I mean
looking at how the company Tesla has
managed the launch of different new
models and some of them were problematic
and meeting the demand which you know
sometimes it wasn't able to do while
managing shareholders expectations
what's the number one lesson that you've
learned from what not to do
well so we have of course studied Tesla
very hard as you can see and it's very
flattered just to be compared with them
and I think that Elon Musk is a huge
inspiration for most Business Leaders
and we have uh carefully looked at I
mean there is they had in production and
this is why we're scaling up as fast as
we can if you can sell an electric boat
today you will be able to sell it and
hence we are scaling a production as
fast as we can got it Jenny caser CEO of
extra really appreciate it and Maddie I
wonder uh JLo and Ben Affleck were in
that we're in an E-boat well they were
probably actually in a super yacht which
is exactly what we're gonna talk about
next because we have some really good
Intel on what it's like to work on ships
for the ultra Rich we're going to bring
you more hot gossip on super Yachts when
we're back in two minutes wait for tea
foreign
[Music]
World On Demand
foreign
hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
at bloomberg.com webinars
foreign
[Music]
the market for super Yachts is on fire
Jeff Bezos is waiting for his
custom-built Giga yacht now for
non-billionaires Charters are so in
demand right now there are now
membership services available since
Maddie and I will never own a yacht and
can't afford a membership the best we
can do is hope to get a job working on
board Bloomberg sent a reporter to do
just that his editor Chris Rouser of
Bloomberg Pursuits is here now to share
what Bloomberg has learned Chris good to
speak with you what is the craziest
thing your undercover reporter heard
about first of all you guys I don't even
know if you can get a job on a boat it's
very very competitive oh my gosh on
these boats now people are dying for
these jobs so the craziest thing that
our reporter who went undercover and
worked as a deckhand on a super yacht
140 Foot super yacht uh saw was um he
stumbled into one room and he saw a room
that was specifically designed for
cocaine
um his his colleagues told him about how
a lot of times on Charters there's the
main boat and then a boat that follows
it that's for prostitutes uh he found a
weed Buffet on another boat I mean this
is like serious partying stuff and these
people do not mess around serious
partying and also serious money Chris
what are the legal implications for the
other people on the boat like could the
deckhand get in trouble for being
escorted into the coke room yeah so um
so that was a privately owned boat by by
like uh by a person it wasn't a charter
boat
um but you know a lot of the sort of
culture of the 70s and 80s when there
were like a lot of drugs on these yachts
in the Mediterranean and the Caribbean
has stopped because you can actually get
um you can get busted for trafficking if
they find any kind of Narcotics on your
ships weed is a little bit different but
a lot of the the cocaine culture is
actually on land these days among the
Brokers and the partying okay so the
deck hands can can stay pristine and all
that if if we do manage to get a job you
know one day as a deckhand how much
money could we bring in in tips so uh
the salary for daikan is about three
thousand a month but on a good summer
you can earn up to fifty thousand
dollars in tips and if you work on a
private boat for a year you could get a
Breitling watch for a Year's worth of
work or a Rolex for five years wow
sounds like a lot of perks and kind of
befriending the other folks who are on
the ship uh Chris one anecdote from the
article that I was fascinated with is
this idea that the deck hands see the
lavish lifestyle and they want to act
that way as well can you tell me about
that yeah I think people you know they
watch the show below deck on Bravo they
see this sort of fabulous life and then
when they're up close and personal with
it they feel like when they go on land
and Mika knows they should be going to
the clubs too so they find themselves
buying the same Gucci sunglasses that
the passengers buy hopefully luck if
they're lucky someone will have left a
nurse scar for something on board and
you can tie that on but yeah they find
that their they end up paying for the
same kind of bottle service and high
life when they're off the ship that
their clients do yeah that's where that
fifty thousand dollar tip goes to
um how much of these boats cost I
mentioned Jeff Bezos has a giga yacht
that he's working on or someone's
working on for him yeah so that one is
going to cost 500 million dollars
estimated and that most of them aren't
that expensive but they cost about a
million dollars for every three feet and
we Define a super yacht as up to 120 is
120 feet or more so that's starting at
40 million dollars and that's before you
get you know necessary add-ons like a
Jacuzzi like a helicopter pad you know
right thing that you can't really do
without on your super yacht you know
what we forgot to ask what is it that
these deckhands do obviously they have
to earn their keep like what what are
their jobs what are they up to they do
everything I mean they they're like you
know they do a lot of like waiter type
service but they also do a tremendous
amount of cleaning the Salt Air is
incredibly destructive as are the
passengers anytime they spray on
sunblock they ruin all the surfaces our
our um our reporter found himself
removing Fried Chicken Flakes with a
tweezer from teak floors uh they're
they're constantly Vigilant doing sort
of everything that you could possibly
need in a private house which is
basically what those boats are is there
anything really quickly here that
passengers on the ships don't know about
that you think that they should they
don't know that they're always being
watched you know it may seem obvious but
you know there's cameras everywhere and
there's always someone watching to make
sure you don't need anything so anything
from like if you pick mushrooms out of
your food the chef then knows later to
not serve those mushrooms to if you're
naked sunbathing someone's gonna see it
if you pass out drunk with no clothes on
the deckhands are going to see it so or
you'll never forget Ben Affleck has his
hand on your butt I guess the duck hands
are gonna see that there's a lot of
people to see that yeah along with the
rest of the world I'm going to watch
succession with new respect now you know
they have that a couple of episodes on
the yacht and like now I'm rethinking
everything that's happening on that show
oh my gosh I know oh Chris thank you so
much Chris Rouser of Bloomberg Pursuits
and Chris is going to join US Weekly for
uh different takes on on what's going on
in the luxury world this is fantastic he
had a really good piece too on personal
shoppers at Barney's that I was
fascinated with he said that uh one of
them became best friends with Rihanna
and actually ended up going to her
wedding so it seems like the perks
abound in these kind of you can marry
friends with the talent with the Stars
yeah you don't have to deal with the
fame you just get to reap the benefits
ah okay maybe maybe there's reason again
to look into these undercover reporting
talks yes that does it for quick take
this hour follow us on Twitter at quick
take for the latest headlines and of
course add our own individual Twitter
handles I'm at Scarlet Foo I'm at
Madison mills22 have a great night
everyone
foreign
[Music]
World On Demand
foreign
hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring just to see what's
moving the markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
foreign
[Music]
coming up on quick Take the Lead
Whiplash on coveted prevention tactics
establishments grapple with renewed Mass
guidance amid the vaccine Royal and what
seemed to be a return to normal we'll
have everything you need to now know
about masks and more
and Deep South Coal Miners take to the
streets of the Big Apple demanding help
in an ongoing Union dispute we were
there live and we'll tell you everything
you need to know
and a new wave of Mobility meet the
so-called Tesla of the sea electric
boats are making a splash on the
eco-friendly scene we'll talk to the CEO
of a Swedish company leading the pack
it's Wednesday July 28th I'm Madison
Mills and I'm Scarlett so we've got
those stories and more coming up on
quick pick the lead
foreign
we begin with the latest on the pandemic
today States and businesses in the U.S
scrambling to change course after the
federal government issued new guidance
calling for vaccinated people in some
parts of the U.S to mask up indoors
Tuesday's announcement from the centers
of Disease Control and prevention is
limited to locations with high
transmission rates so what does that
mean it's when more than 50 cases per
100 000 people are in any given area so
joining us by phone to discuss what this
all means for the coming months is
Bloomberg News senior health editor Drew
Armstrong Drew Armstrong Drew always
great to chat with you really quickly I
want to hit on this new guidance where
in the U.S do people definitely need to
mask up again
well it's actually a surprisingly large
number of places where we're seeing
um case rates increase all over the
place right now
um frankly though a lot of that is
concentrated in hot spots
um you know along the uh along the South
and Central regions of the country in
particular there's this band of cases
happening right now in uh Louisiana
Arkansas and Missouri we're also see a
huge amounts of cases in Florida
um right now and then also a significant
cluster kind of in the Northeast here
along the Northeast Corridor where we
are seeing a rise in cases in you know
the New York City area some in Boston
and you know in places like La as well
this really is a a bit of a national
phenomenon right now another national
phenomenon that's some good news to
celebrate here is that vaccination rates
are starting to increase and I know you
just did some great reporting on this
Drew tell me a little bit about what you
think is causing the increase in
vaccinations over the last seven days
well if you talk to people who are on
the ground
um in uh in these in these places where
these vaccination rates are climbing um
you know again a lot of this is really
concentrated in those three states that
I mentioned you know Missouri Arkansas
and Louisiana there are people who you
know it's been a while since there's
been a surge in those in those places
but all of a sudden there's a lot of
people who are you know vaccine
reluctant or vaccine hesitant or even
vaccine abusers who now know somebody
who is getting sick I talked to
Louisiana State Health officer a guy
named Joseph Kennard he said you know
they're seeing their hospitalizations go
through the roof right now but along
with that you know he said everybody
knows someone who's sick right now there
are those people who are not real
anti-vaxxers but they were just not
maybe confident in the vaccine and he
says they're saying things like I'm not
waiting a day longer and they're going
out and getting shots because they see
what's happening around them is
Louisiana the state in the U.S though
that has the lowest vaccination rate so
far is that correct they're they're the
fourth lowest in in the US they've been
a laggard for a long time and I and I
have to say I mean listen vaccination
return up in these places but it would
take months for them to catch up to some
of the leading places in the U.S right
that you see you know in in Vermont and
you know in the Northeast and places
like that so how long do you anticipate
this increased vaccination rate to go on
you know um I I think that remains to be
seen you know if this is a if this is a
long-term Trend
um you know but it does tell you that
there is room to move people here um
that stayed out you know State Health
and state local Health officials have
been trying to do you know they've been
trying everything they can begging
people to go get vaccinated putting
incentive programs out you know working
with people's doctors local community
leaders they are really really pushing
hard on this but you know um
unfortunately fear attempts to it
appears to be it's one of the Prime
motivating factors that's pushing people
into going getting these shots well
speaking of fear drew a lot of the
people who did their part and went out
and got the vaccine are among the more
health conscious and that's causing them
to continue to have coveted anxieties
particularly as the highly contagious
Delta variant continues to spread I know
that the CDC has been investigating
clusters where vaccinated people might
have infected others and finding that in
those cases the vaccinated people had
higher levels of viral load what does
that mean
well you know it's this it's this
interesting situation with the Delta
variant that you know we all we know is
more contagious but one of the reasons
why it is is because it the virus tends
to replicate much much faster
um which means that you know even if
you're vaccinated it still takes a
little while for your immune system to
catch up so basically you've got a whole
lot of virus that you know if you are
talking or coughing or you know
breathing may be coming out because
there's just more of it there early on
which means that if you're vaccinated
but you're still kind of in that window
where your immune system hasn't really
geared up and gone to war and smashed
these things down you can still be
spreading it to other people that's a
real change from some of the other
variants in the original strains of this
virus where you know vaccinations were
basically shown against those strains to
quash the thing before it ever really
got going because it didn't replicate
quite as fast and you basically didn't
have as much virus kicking around in
your body really great explanation there
Drew really quickly as we wrap up I
remember couple months ago talking to
you on the show and you were joining us
in the office your mask was off you
mentioned going to dinner the night
before
um do you think that we're going to be
able to keep that optimistic view as the
Delta variant does continue to spread I
mean are we going to be going out to
dinners with our masks off
you know it's a great question and I
think these are things that everybody
has to decide for themselves you know
the good news is that you know even
though we do have this issue of
contagion you know the risk to
individuals who've been vaccinated
you're still not seeing you know you're
seeing the kind of same protection
against severe disease that said I have
a bunch of friends who are vaccinated
and have gotten sick with covet and like
being sick sucks and in addition to that
you have people who worry about taking
back an illness to somebody else in
their household who might not be
vaccinated right um we're being a little
more cautious than I than I was
previously yeah yeah I mean I I can I
think I hear your child in the
background they're making their needs
you know yeah yeah it's uh it's
definitely something to consider and
something I feel like a lot of working
parents are worried about as we still
look for more information about
vaccinations among kids Bloomberg senior
Healthcare editor Drew Armstrong always
appreciate you joining us to talk all
things covid Scarlett well starting next
week fully vaccinated American and
European Union Travelers will no longer
need to spend 10 days in quarantine when
when arriving in England
meanwhile you've got International
cruises that'll also resume after being
put on hold for more than a year it's
now unlikely that the Biden
Administration will reciprocate anytime
soon U.S health officials advising
Americans to avoid traveling to the UK
due to a surge in infections and in
other coveted news a U.S Senate
committee postponed a hearing today
after some of its members were
potentially exposed to the coronavirus
Michigan senator Gary Peters says his
panel delayed the hearing but declined
to name which lawmakers were possibly
exposed the news comes after the top
position of Congress reimposed a mask
mandate for lawmakers when they're on
the house floor in hallways and in their
offices
and New York City offering an incentive
for vaccine hesitators get the first
dose of a coveted shot at a city run
site show proof that you live or work in
the city and after that you get a
hundred dollars through prepaid debit
cards incentives can be redeemed as
starting Friday and of course this week
the city said all Municipal workers are
required to get the shot or submit to
weekly testing so it looks like they can
get paid for that now
for the latest coveted news at Baltimore
bloomberg.com forward slash coronavirus
Maddie well coming up after the break
we'll look at the challenges social
media platforms like Facebook have to
contend with when it comes to
misinformation this is quick Take the
Lead
foreign
[Music]
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring
see what's
visit bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
foreign
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
just talked about the spread of the
Delta variant the problem globally is a
lack of access to vaccines here in the
U.S there's a surplus of the shots a lot
of the vaccine hesitancy can really be
chalked up to misinformation and
conspiracy theories proliferating on
social media President Biden has called
on big Tech and its leaders to address
this but so far A little action has been
taken so let's bring in Jim Anderson CEO
of social flow now to discuss what else
could be done Jim it's always good to
have you on quick take I feel like no
matter what steps Facebook or any other
social media platform takes to address
misinformation they will always be five
to ten steps behind it's like
whack-a-mole here would spending more
money to hire more monitors or tweaking
algorithms change anything
well it would certainly help I mean
you're right it is a game of
whack-a-mole and the analogy I used
before is it's a little bit like trying
to get the weeds out of your garden
except you're a single Gardener and
you're trying to Garden all the corn
fields in Iowa right it's just a massive
problem and no matter what you try you
hire a 100 moderators a thousand I
believe Facebook is tens of thousands of
moderators and it's still not enough uh
that doesn't mean you shouldn't try that
doesn't mean you shouldn't hire the
moderators but let's be realistic here
when you're talking about billions and
ultimately trillions uh in reach uh and
and billions of pieces of content
there's only so much you're going to be
able to do right and I also think about
the fact that it's certainly not limited
to Facebook or Twitter um how do you
think about the scale of misinformation
that that's out there right now because
anything that acts as a social network I
imagine that there's promise on LinkedIn
as well and it happens in places like
China which has a closed system Facebook
and Twitter aren't even allowed to
operate but I'm sure things on weibo
there's probably stuff on weibo that's
not accurate either
yeah if you have an audience you have
the potential for misinformation
especially with user generated content
and the other point that I think is
really important to realize is you need
to follow the money if you want to
understand what's really going on here
people have lots of motivations but in
General Financial is one of the
strongest and so a lot of the
misinformation that's putting out being
put out there is actually being done for
profit and you might say well how in the
world are people profiting from
misinformation but they're selling books
they're selling merchandises quack
medical cures building audiences that
they then sell to sponsors and have
advertising against this whole variety
of profit mediums out there for somebody
who has built an audience and whether
the content is true or false sadly is
almost irrelevant so how do you make
that content less profitable how do you
make that message less profitable
well you do the things that we were just
talking about enforcement having clear
standards and one of the things Facebook
in particular has gotten in trouble uh
with in the past with its oversight
board is not having clear standards of
it and adhering to them so
misinformation we know is a really tough
thing to diagnose you know there are
things about the vaccine how long did it
take to develop it was developed very
quickly how much testing was done
probably less than previous vaccines
what's the vaccine mechanism those are
all true statements that you can then
add up to sort of infer that the vaccine
is somehow dangerous which I think most
reasonable people would conclude is not
the case at least not for them but how
do you make the distinction between
what's a true statement and then
ultimately what's misleading and and
that's really hard to do from a platform
standards perspective because there's so
much variance between say what's going
on with covid now and some other type of
misinformation say around the election
yeah setting standards is exactly what
none of these platforms want to do
because then it turns them into teams of
editors and that that's pointedly what
they're trying to avoid being I want to
go back to that idea about how there are
truths underneath the vaccine skepticism
the questions that people are raising
are legitimate it's just the conclusions
that people draw as a result of those
questions being asked that's the problem
yeah without a doubt I mean vaccine
hesitancy is understandable right I mean
some people are hesitant about any form
of medicine or going to the doctor or
getting a shot and if you say well I'm
scared to get a shot or I'm just
hesitant to get a shot does that make
you a vaccine skeptic I think not right
it's a perfectly reasonable uh you know
a thing for people to ask you know is it
worth it to me and your health reporter
previously was talking about you know
these are very personal decisions things
like where do I wear a mask in certain
circumstances do I not vaccines are a
little bit different because it has an
impact Beyond just you but you know
ultimately people's personal health
decisions are their personal decision
and so we have to be careful not to
label any kind of hesitancy as flat out
misinformation the problem is is of
course people will then flip that for
their own profit right they'll say oh
you should definitely not get a vaccine
because it's dangerous and it hasn't
been tested and those are those are
demonstrably not true statements and so
drawing that line is what everybody has
to do and and that's what the platforms
are on the hook to do and and candidly
not doing a great job of it right now
would more rules on privacy and data
data collection make this less
profitable this misinformation and I
bring this up because Facebook just
reported results where it was fairly
cautious when it gave a outlook for the
next quarter and that's because Apple's
new rules on data collection is going to
hurt its bottom line
yeah I don't think data privacy is going
to affect the misinformation problem at
all it may affect Facebook and apple
although probably not as much as you
might think I mean Facebook is still you
know in record territory I think even
after with a sell-off after after the
markets they're still up probably 30
percent uh you know on the year so
Facebook just keeps having record
quarter after record quarter after
record quarter there are quite
legitimate privacy issues but I I don't
think those are going to affect the
misinformation issue at all gotcha
distinct issues then Jim Anderson CEO of
social flow always great to speak with
you really appreciate your joining us
today
now we're staying staying with this
earnings idea Spotify could just be the
biggest name in music streaming but the
latest results showed it remains
vulnerable to the pandemic the Swedish
company added fewer new users than
expected in the second quarter
especially in global markets like India
the disappointing growth scent shares of
Spotify down as much as 10 today still
spotify's advertising business is
booming thanks in part to podcasts I
recently had a chance to sit down with a
top executive in charge of spotify's
engineering chief of research and
development officer Gustav soderstrom
Gustav was once quoted as saying he
wants to make Spotify the r d of the
music industry so I asked him to explain
what he meant by that
most other Industries they have a lot of
r d they have a lot of smart people
working on building products for them
and the thing that struck me about the
music industry was I mean it's it's all
the labels and the labels had at least
back then they had very few Engineers
there just wasn't any or in the in the
music industry at all they were just
they were just monetizing the IP they
had and they relied on someone else CD
makers or iTunes or something to do the
r d
and so I just wanted to set the ambition
and say like well music seems to have no
r d Department there's no one doing
there's no one innovating in on the
consumer side so let's make the goal uh
be that we are that r d department now
we have competing r d departments and
other companies that also try to
innovate that's a great outcome for the
music industry and for artists now
there's competition for for the consumer
experience
so it's thinking about breaking the mold
and how you can break the mold and how
you can reinvent what's been around
um exactly journalists and a lot of
people in PR who frankly let's face it
are former journalists tend to get lazy
and we like to use a lot of shorthand
for describing things and identifying
new themes so after Warby Parker came
out and disrupted the eyewear industry
there are a lot of you know new Warby
Parkers of blank so there's Warby Parker
for belts or something
um and then of course there was Uber
which became the in-demand economy right
there was uh Uber for private jets Uber
for blank
what do you think the shorthand is for
Spotify what do you want Spotify to be
shorthand for that's what would it mean
to be the Spotify of blank
it's a great question now I actually do
see a lot of pitches and Pitch Decks
that does include where the Spotify for
for blank
and uh
so so that's not necessarily what I
would want it to mean
but what what that usually means is that
they take something where you paid per
item like music you paid per download
right or you paid per CD and you turn it
into an access model where you pay a
fixed fee or or you use advertising but
you you go from per item access or
download access to Flat access so I
think that's what most entrepreneurs
mean when they say with a Spotify for
something we take an industry we pay the
marginal cost per item and instead you
pay a flat access and what's interesting
about that is for music it turned out to
as as often is the case with what is
called bundling basically you can think
of the entire catalog now as a big
bundle all these tracks bundled together
for a single consumer price and that
turned out to maximize it took a long
time for the music industry to get back
after the pirate era but it's growing
very very quickly now so that turned out
to optimize the global industry for it
was a great consumer deal some more
consumers paid so that actually generate
more money to the music industry than
happen in the marginal cost model
and that's what I think people mean with
the Spotify 4 we turn this from a from a
sort of per item to a flat axis model
what do you want that that comparison to
mean in the future yeah I think you know
that we will be representative of
putting an access model business model
on top of a proactive model is is quite
a cool thing I guess it would also I
would love it for it to imply taking on
a complicated industry that most people
recommend against going into yeah
entrenched Industries which have no
interest at all in changing how they do
anything and breaking it apart and
putting it back together essentially the
important thing is that there's a lot of
talk about disrupting Industries but
that's not what Spotify did we actually
worked with the industry and the same
industry is bigger right and that's
important it's easy to say we're going
to go in and disrupt and kill this
industry spotifys did the opposite
we started negotiating with them from
day one it took a long and painful route
which is often recommended against the
the recommendation is to try to go in
and disrupt and Destroy but so the
record labels see Spotify as their
friend as rather than their enemy
for sure I mean with the where the
majority of their of the revenue now
streaming is what about musicians though
a lot of musicians
um say they can't make a livable wage
off of their their streaming proceeds
it's a very complicated question I mean
we try to look at are we are we growing
the pie or not is there more and more
money going to rights holders every year
and that's super clear it's growing very
very fast and you know beyond the the
what was called the Golden Days of the
of the city industry and we're also
looking at you know
or deals with the what the labels are
while not transparent quite well known
we pay out the vast majority of any
dollar we make to the rights industry
now there are many complicated
um
there are many complicated Parts in
between there and what revenues Creator
sees and you also have many many more
people participating now and creating
music which
obviously it's a great thing I mean we
want more creators I think most creative
things it's great that more creators get
a chance but that also means that while
the pie is growing there are also more
creators at the same time so it's a very
complicated
question to uh to solve we're trying to
be transparent with what we're doing and
we're trying to be fair and how we pay
out
from Chief r d officer of spotify and by
the way host of the podcast Spotify a
product story that offers an inside
account of product development at the
company Maddie let's get you some other
Tech headlines Google and Facebook
employees will have to get a vaccine to
get back into the office now apple is
requiring masks in half its U.S stores
starting this Thursday Google CEO Sundar
putai made the announcement about
vaccines on Wednesday the company also
says it'll be postponing its return to
office date by about a month now
staffers returning to Google are going
to have to show proof of vaccination
starting October 18th
Facebook's WhatsApp unit will face its
first find under the European Union's
data Protection Law the European data
protection board cleared the way for
Irish Regulators to find Facebook
WhatsApp set aside more than 91 million
dollars to pay potential fines for two
investigations from Ireland's privacy
agency that's according to an Irish
regulatory filing for November
and bad news for those of us already
struggling to swipe the credit card a
little less because there's another
social media platform getting in on the
e-commerce Game Twitter will allow
businesses and retailers to sell to
users directly through their profiles
now it's only being piloted right now
but some businesses are already testing
out ways to enable sales on the Twitter
app
for the latest tech news bookmark
bloomberg.com forward slash technology
and coming up after the great the break
a huge group of coal miners and their
supporters landed in the heart of New
York and one of the biggest Asset
Management firms in the world we'll tell
you why when we're back in two minutes
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
fight down south takes its mission to
financial firm BlackRock I went out to
speak with some of these workers and
find out what they're looking to get out
of their long time strike
hey man Brothers assist
union workers are gathering right behind
me right outside of the Black Rock
building they're organizing here today
in hopes that BlackRock which is a big
investor in the company that owns these
mines will actually take a stand in
their investments in that company
what rock can put pressure on the
negotiating team to come to a decent
contract to actually come and bargain
with us in good faith they have enough
stock that they could put that pressure
there they themselves could step in and
speak out for us speak out for the
workers while they're living the way
they're living is because of us
that's the reason why they're able to
live the way they live it's because we
do what we do uh we go underground we
put our lives on the line for our
families and it's time for them to give
us what we deserve in 2016 is where your
met was trying to emerge from bankruptcy
the miners took pay and benefit Cuts
just to keep their jobs where you're met
cold their investors are at BlackRock
and basically our miners got them out of
bankruptcy but they refused to give us a
fair contract officials at BlackRock
declined to comment on Warrior met the
Striking miners choice to involve
BlackRock is just the latest example in
a movement of different groups asking
their asset managers to take a stand on
investments the miners are now looking
for pay and benefit increases beyond
what more your met is offering we'll
have to wait and see how all this shakes
out for these workers who again are on
month five of their strike for now I'm
Madison Mills in front of Blackrock in
New York
and this is not the first time that
BlackRock has drawn protests last
February before the start of covid
climate activists occupied the BlackRock
headquarters in Paris to protest its
investments in companies that damage the
environment but what can and what should
BlackRock do about its Investments
Bloomberg's animasa has covered
BlackRock for years as a reporter on the
asset management team and she joins us
now great to speak with you and welcome
to the show uh coal miner that I spoke
with today told me that she protested to
kind of convince BlackRock to pressure
the company to to use their board votes
to get where you're met to really make a
change what do you envision Larry Fink's
response to that might be
well the response that BlackRock has
typically had to protest like this and
as you mentioned there have been many
over the course of the years that I've
been covering BlackRock the typical
response is we're a fiduciary on behalf
of our clients we oversee client money
and it's not our decision necessarily to
invest in XYZ company but that that
argument is increasingly wearing thin
for people and it hasn't managed to stem
the tide of protests that we're seeing
on the social side on the environmental
side against BlackRock specifically
okay Annie BlackRock is clearly the
world's biggest asset manager I mean the
numbers are astronomical nine and a half
trillion dollars in assets under
management it's definitely the biggest
shareholder in Warrior met with a 15
stake but if you look at companies in
the S P 500 it's also one of the biggest
shareholders in apple in GM in Citigroup
it's hard to find a publicly traded
company in which BlackRock is not one of
the biggest shareholders explain to us
why that is why BlackRock is everywhere
that's exactly right in fact if you go
down the list BlackRock it for 99 of s p
500 companies you're going to find
Blackrock in the top five holders so as
you said it is everywhere the reason
that BlackRock is such a major holder of
so many of those recognizable companies
has to do with how its business is
structured and it's one of the biggest
index fund managers in the world so of
that 9.5 trillion dollars in assets that
you mentioned two-thirds of that is
coming from index funds those aren't
funds where there's really oversight oh
there's really uh active oversight over
the companies that are going into the
fund those are Tethered to indexes so
that's why BlackRock has traditionally
made the argument that okay it oversees
trillions and trillions of dollars in
assets but such a large such a vast
proportion of that is in these indexed
tethered funds
so given what you just mentioned that
BlackRock doesn't really decide what
goes into these ETFs that passively
track an index someone else does like
the guys who make the S P 500 would the
folks I spoke with today be better off
protesting against them instead
it's a great question I think some of
the frustration is coming because people
see that BlackRock is is out front with
statements about how we need to be
thinking about the environment and even
Finance needs to be reorienting itself
and companies need to be reorienting
themselves towards uh global warming and
addressing it more so when you're out
there on the record uh positioning
yourself that way and making changes to
your business to confront those problems
it it does make you an easier Target
maybe uh for activists like the ones
that you saw today
so Larry flank as you know has been out
front in talking about the need to look
at climate change as an investment
priority and I know in the past he has
said something about how BlackRock can't
just divest from companies that people
find objectionable but what they can do
is offer more funds that are focused on
sustainability Maddie that's something
that may not fly with the people that
you spoke with a hundred percent yeah
and I wonder if they would feel like
it's a little bit of the company kind of
having its cake and eating it too what
what do you make of that Annie
that's a really good point I mean
there's clear frustration uh at at this
end of at this end of things and it's
being vented towards BlackRock I mean
BlackRock has made changes as a result
of I think things like climate change
but that's really not that's not enough
uh for people like the protesters that
you saw today and I think that for them
BlackRock can seem like this big opaque
kind of business uh that's a major owner
of the company that's aggravating them
and as a result they're they're seeing
it as a perfect Target yeah well said
okay so BlackRock one of the top five
owners shareholders of 99 of the S P 500
the other names you'll always see up
there are State Street and Vanguard yet
neither of those two firms seem to get
as much attention as BlackRock any why
do you think that is
I think that there is something to being
the biggest I the BlackRock is the
biggest asset manager in the world with
that more than nine trillion dollars in
assets so they're the largest and it's
easy to Target the largest one there's
also maybe a little bit of a sense that
Vanguard State Street they're not even
they're not based in New York or Wall
Street is so there may be an element
that uh BlackRock is here in New York
City kind of the center of finance and
uh it's a Target that way as well Annie
really really great perspective
Bloomberg investing and asset management
reporter Annie Massa thank you so much
now coming up new guidelines on home
appraisal language hopes to close the
race Gap will it be enough this is quick
Take the Lead
access the financial World On Demand
thank you hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
access the financial World On Demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
so this is the difference between
[Music]
this week's City lab we're taking a look
at the race Gap in home valuations
practices in the industry have been
criticized for continuing to widen that
Gap making it harder for certain
communities to build generational wealth
Fannie Mae is looking to change all of
that but will it be enough quick takes
Matthew albaney spoke with City lab's
Brenton mock about what to expect
the kick things off what exactly is
Fannie Mae looking to change when it
comes to how they describe home
appraisals and why are they doing this
so Fannie Mae is um basically they've
issued a guidance
um where they're asking appraisers to
kind of change the language that they
use when they create their appraisal
evaluation reports when pricing homes
and I just I want to emphasize that it's
just a guidance it's not like a hard
rule on anything but basically Fannie
Mae is trying to help root out what's
called appraisal bias or racial
appraisal bias where this nagging
problem of historically homes and black
neighborhoods uh being appraised at much
lower values than similar or same homes
in white neighborhoods which are often
appraised at much much higher values and
so Fannie Mae is saying you know guys
when you fill out your reports try to
avoid language such as you know
crime-ridden neighborhoods you know
don't say that the house isn't an
affordable neighborhood don't say that
the house is in a desirable neighborhood
and you know basically they're
acknowledging that all of these
signifiers these all in some ways kind
of signify class or race and if you say
it's an affordable neighborhood you know
that's often a you know coded language
for this is where poor people live or
this is where you know people of color
live since race and low income is often
tracks together
right and speaking to kind of the
historic issues the systemic issues that
go on with appraisals
it seems like the race Gap has not
necessarily slowed down what are some of
the practices on the side of the
appraisers and the effects that it does
have on these homes
well you know the history of course is
is racial segregation and how um early
redlining practices
um basically basically signaled to to
Banks and lenders that properties in
black neighborhoods were too risky for
investment
um and also how Federal housing policies
um historically basically encouraged a
white homogeneity basically uniformly
white neighborhoods which signaled to
Banks and lenders that these are the
best neighborhoods for investment this
would in this would have the effect of
kind of of maximizing and optimizing
property values and and quote-unquote
white neighborhoods you know those kinds
of like race-based practices have been
outlawed by the fair housing act in 1965
the community reinvestment act in 1977.
um however there was nothing put in
place to actually kind of cure the
um the undervaluing of black
neighborhoods and the and the
overvaluing of homes and white
neighborhoods that that was basically
already entered into the industry
current appraisal practices
um you know they and they kind of still
take into account uh the home values
that were set in the 20th century um
again like black homes on average I
think are valued somewhere
um well depending on the city but I
think Across the Nation 75 000 lower
than again same size same Design Homes
and white neighborhoods
right and when it comes to trying to
figure out kind of the cure to this
issue I I'm curious how people are
reacting to these changes that Fannie
Mae said that they want to implement or
the guidances that they want to
implement rather uh you point in your
article that racial composition is one
of the strong determinants of housing
values are these changes of words really
going to change anything or is it just
more or less a nice gesture
all right I think we'll see
um you know Fannie May just issued this
guidance
um in uh in June I reached out to a few
industry leaders
um about this and I didn't get a I
didn't get a direct comment at all
um about the language
um they may not have even known about it
honestly however you know I spoke with a
researcher Elizabeth uh Korver Glenn
she's been researching a racial
appraisal bias and also uh racial bias
in the in the housing market in general
you know she basically wasn't buying it
she didn't think it was going to bring
any change at all because it doesn't she
for her she said it doesn't at all
substantively changed the way that
appraisers conduct their business today
um and so to use the an interesting
analogy of like a book publisher who
publishes cookbooks right you know
looking at how uh chocolate chip cookie
recipes have been printed and published
in that publishers books for years for
decades and then you know say some
health agency comes out and says you
know chocolate is unhealthy and she says
the publisher now tells her writers that
they should no longer use the word
chocolate in their chocolate chip cookie
recipes you know just call them I don't
know chip cookies
you know use any any other language but
don't use the word chocolate but you
haven't changed the actual ingredients
in the recipe you haven't changed the
way that it's baked and so the cookies
are made the same you just told the you
know you've just told the people that
they can't use these words anymore and
she says that's basically the same thing
that's happening now Fannie Mae hasn't
actually changed the way that appraisers
conduct their business they haven't
changed the practice
um all they've done is to say like don't
use these words
that was our Matt albani speaking with
City lab reporter Brenton mock now
coming up after the break would you ride
in a boat made of flaxseed that cost
tens of thousands of dollars you might
it's the next wave in clean Mobility
e-boats we'll explain when we're back
into
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
for today's movers and shakers the
people impacting the world of business
politics and sports Julian Assange is no
longer a citizen of Ecuador the country
stripped his citizenship after finding
irregularities in his naturalization
process Assange became Ecuadorian in
2018 as part of an attempt by then
president Lenin Moreno to get him out of
the country's London Embassy where he
lived for seven years to avoid arrest
the Wikileaks co-founder was taken into
custody in 2019 after Ecuador withdrew
his Asylum status Assange is currently
in prison in the UK his lawyer says he's
going to appeal the ruling
Jared Kushner is planning to open an
investment company later this year the
firm will operate in Miami and Israel
for new person with knowledge of the
matter Reuters report says the Israel
office will pursue Regional Investments
to connect Israel's economy to India
North Africa and the gulf during
kushner's last year as a political
adviser to his father-in-law former
president Donald Trump he brokered a
deal between Israel and several other
Middle Eastern countries
actor Bob Odenkirk was rushed to a
hospital after collapsing on the set of
AMC's Better Call Saul on Tuesday it's
not clear what caused the collapse
Odenkirk was in Albuquerque New Mexico
filming the sixth and final season of
the Breaking Bad spin-off the 58 year
old is a four-time Emmy nominee for his
role as lawyer Saul Goodman
those are your movers and shakers from
today Scarlett well for the Rich and
Famous there's a new cool way to get
around this hot summer that may be
better for Earth an electric boat that's
being called the Tesla of the sea
Swedish company xjore is cleaning up
emissions and in the process drawing
comparisons to Elon musk's vehicles for
its software and sleek and smart
features extra CEO Jenny casu joins us
now from Stockholm to discuss Jenny
welcome to Quick take for those of us
who aren't Sailors or boaters I'm not
sure if that's a word give us a brief
overview of electric boats and their
impact on the environment
of course so basically an average usage
of a typical combustion engine boat over
a summer compares to three and a half
years usage of a combustion engine cars
so the um the um amount of CO2 that
Leisure bulking industry is emitting is
huge and then you have noise pollution
as well and hence you need to change
that quickly and that is why we're
seeing electrification also in the
Boating industry now we are providing
smart Tech combined with a superior
Driving Experience and a sustainable
product and it's available now for order
so part of your sustainable product is
the material that it's made out of flax
fiber materials there's also cork
instead of traditional teak
um what about the safety of these new
materials how much testing has there
been done and is it is it testing that
really tests the limits of of these
vehicles given that it's it's pretty
quick to Market
also basically the founder of Connor
Bergstrom has been doing this in 2016 so
we've been in an r d phase for quite a
few years now and these are uh materials
that is not new for other Industries
just news for uh voting Industries so we
are certified in Europe and we are
certified in the US as well and we have
delivered products under certification
to three continents already
you mentioned that these boats are
available tell me what demand looks like
right now and which markets are growing
the fastest both Geographic and
demographic
so we are growing quickest now with the
Nordic region in the U.S and in Middle
East and we are seeing High demands so
we are scaling up production quickly we
recently uh opened our second Factory
which we will have fully up and running
in Sweden later this year and so next
year we will be able to provide our
customers with 450 additional boats we
have sold more than we can produce
talk about government regulations too
because especially in Europe where
you're based um the the push to go
fossil free is really gaining Steam and
it's pushing ahead the timeline as well
for the adoption of electric vehicles
including electric boats
oh of course so what we are seeing here
in the Privacy agreement is that we need
to uh stop uh emissions quickly and a
lot of emissions actually comes from
Leisure building and hence why we have
several countries now Banning uh
combustion engine in Leisure boats on
both lakes and near shore areas such as
Amsterdam Norway
Germany Switzerland Austria Etc
got it got it and I was looking at some
of the features they include a mobile
and Smartwatch app which unlocks and
turns on the boat when in range I I
gotta wonder is there going to be an
autopilot mode kind of like Tesla
well uh hopefully not too far out
hopefully not too far it's hard not to
make comparisons to Tesla Jenny I mean
looking at how the company Tesla has
managed the launch of different new
models and some of them were problematic
um and meeting the demand which you know
sometimes it wasn't able to do while
managing shareholders expectations
what's the number one lesson that you've
learned from what not to do
well so we have of course studied Tesla
very hard as you can see and it's very
flattered just to be compared with them
and I think that Elon Musk is a huge
inspiration for most Business Leaders
and we have uh carefully looked at I
mean there is they had in production and
this is why we're scaling up as fast as
we can if you can sell an electric boat
today you will be able to sell it and
hence we are scaling a production as
fast as we can got it Jenny caser CEO of
extra really appreciate it and Maddie I
wonder uh JLo and Ben Affleck were in
that we're in an E-boat well they were
probably actually in a super yacht which
is exactly what we're gonna talk about
next because we have some really good
Intel on what it's like to work on ships
for the ultra Rich we're gonna bring you
more hot gossip on super Yachts when
we're back in two minutes wait for tea
foreign
[Music]
World On Demand
foreign
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
bloomberg.com webinars
foreign
[Music]
the market for super Yachts is on fire
Jeff Bezos is waiting for his
custom-built Giga yacht now for
non-billionaires Charters are so in
demand right now there are now
membership services available since
Maddie and I will never own a yacht and
can't afford a membership the best we
can do is hope to get a job working on
board Bloomberg's sent a reporter to do
just that his editor Chris Rouser of
Bloomberg Pursuits is here now to share
what Bloomberg has learned Chris good to
speak with you what is the craziest
thing your undercover reporter heard
about first of all you guys I don't even
know if you can get a job on a boat it's
very very competitive oh my goodness on
these boats now people are dying for
these jobs so the craziest thing that
our reporter who went undercover and
worked as a deckhand on a super yacht
140 Foot super yacht uh saw was um he
stumbled into one room and he saw a room
that was specifically designed for
cocaine
um his his colleagues told him about how
a lot of times on Charters there's the
main boat and then a boat that follows
it that's for prostitutes uh he found a
weed Buffet on another boat I mean this
is like serious partying stuff and these
people do not mess around serious
partying and also serious money Chris
what are the legal implications for the
other people on the boat like could the
deckhand get in trouble for being
escorted into the coke room yeah so um
so that was a privately owned boat by by
like uh by a person it wasn't a charter
boat
um but you know a lot of the sort of
culture of the 70s and 80s when there
were like a lot of drugs on these yachts
in the Mediterranean and the Caribbean
has stopped because you can actually get
um you can get busted for trafficking if
they find any kind of Narcotics on your
ships weed is a little bit different but
a lot of the the cocaine culture is
actually on land these days among the
Brokers and the partying okay so the
daikans can can stay pristine and all
that if if we do manage to get a job you
know one day as a deckhand how much
money could we bring in in tips so uh
the salary for daikan is about three
thousand a month but on a good summer
you can earn up to fifty thousand
dollars in tips and if you work on a
private boat for a year you could get a
Breitling watch for a Year's worth of
work or a Rolex for five years wow
sounds like a lot of perks and kind of
befriending the other folks who are on
the ship uh Chris one anecdote from the
article that I was fascinated with is
this idea that the deck hands see the
lavish lifestyle and they want to act
that way as well can you tell me about
that yeah I think people you know they
watch the show below deck on Bravo they
see this sort of fabulous life and then
when they're up close and personal with
it they feel like when they go on land
and Mika knows they should be going to
the clubs too so they find themselves
buying the same Gucci sunglasses that
the passengers buy hopefully luck if
they're lucky someone will have left a
nurse scarf or something on board and
you can tie that on but yeah they find
that their they end up paying for the
same kind of bottle service and high
life when they're off the ship that
their clients do yeah that's where that
fifty thousand dollar tip goes to
um how much of these boats cost I
mentioned Jeff Bezos has a giga yacht
that he's working on or someone's
working on for him yeah so that one is
going to cost 500 million dollars
estimated and that most of them aren't
that expensive but they cost about a
million dollars for every three feet and
we Define a super yacht as up to 120 is
120 feet or more so that's starting at
40 million dollars and that's before you
get you know necessary add-ons like a
Jacuzzi like a helicopter pad you know
right thing that you can't really do
without on your super yacht you know
what we forgot to ask what is it that
these deckhands do obviously they have
to earn their keep like what were their
jobs what are they up to they do
everything I mean they they're like you
know they do a lot of like waiter type
service but they also do a tremendous
amount of cleaning the Salt Air is
incredibly destructive as are the
passengers anytime they spray on
sunblock they ruin all the surfaces our
our um our reporter found himself
removing Fried Chicken Flakes with a
tweezer from teak floors uh they're
they're constantly Vigilant doing sort
of everything that you could possibly
need in a private house which is
basically what those boats are is there
anything really quickly here that
passengers on the ships don't know about
that you think that they should they
don't know that they're always being
watched you know it may seem obvious but
you know there's cameras everywhere and
there's always someone watching to make
sure you don't need anything so anything
from like if you pick mushrooms out of
your food the chef then knows later to
not serve those mushrooms to if you're
naked sunbathing someone's gonna see it
if you pass out drunk with no clothes on
the deck hands are going to see it so or
you'll never forget Ted Affleck has his
hand on your butt I guess the duck hands
are going to see that I wanted people to
see that yeah along with the rest of the
world I'm going to watch succession with
new respect now you know they have that
a couple of episodes on the yacht and
like now I'm rethinking everything
that's happening on that show
oh my gosh I know oh Chris thank you so
much Chris Rouser of Bloomberg Pursuits
and Chris is going to join US Weekly for
uh different takes on on what's going on
in the luxury world this is fantastic he
had a really good piece too on personal
shoppers at Barney's that I was
fascinated with he said that uh one of
them became best friends with Rihanna
and actually ended up going to her
wedding so it seems like the perks
abound in these kind of you can be
friends with the talent with the Stars
yeah you don't have to deal with the
fame you just get to reap the benefits
ah okay maybe maybe there's reason again
to to look into these undercover
reporting talks yes that does it for
quick take this hour follow us on
Twitter at quick take for the latest
headlines and of course add our own
individual Twitter handles I'm at
Scarlet Foo I'm at Madison mills22 have
a great night everyone
foreign
[Music]
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
Street experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring see what's moved
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
World On Demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
bloomberg.com webinars
foreign
[Music]
we started a business in the middle of a
pandemic y'all however sold a hell of a
lot of shoes
and we knew it was going to happen
because we understood that there was a
need for this type of thing because we
needed it also
[Music]
the sneaker resale Market is booming
totaling an estimated 2 billion dollars
in North America alone as shoe
manufacturers focus on driving sales
away from brick and mortar stores and
towards mobile apps and websites sneaker
resellers are reaping the benefits
the name of our business is another Lane
we are the premier destination for dope
kicks
so not only do you have a Marketplace
you can sell with no seller fees and
then on top of that you get
communication so you can you know ask
someone hey does the shoe fit small can
I get 50 off those types of things
encouraging Community also you have a
unique URL to your store we want to be
in the background
foreign
when I think about sneakers and my
infatuation with them I don't wear it
like a badge of honor it's kind of
embarrassing and so when I wanted to ask
her out I mentioned it very like ever so
slightly and Adina kind of just
shruggled off like everybody's into
sneakers so you're no different than
anybody else until the first time I
visited his house I was like oh this is
different his entire bedroom it looks
like the back room of Foot Locker
yeah so this is my favorite place in the
world because this is where I house my
Personal Collection this is a Air Jordan
2009 uh prototype sample inspired by
April Holmes she is a gold medalist a
paralympian
[Music]
LeBron 4 All-Star player Edition that he
wore in the All-Star Game and last
Jordan brand just came out with the
Jordan 11 adapt this is Nike's first
Auto lacing Air Jordan 11.
every shoe that Adina likes is either
from the 70s or the 80s me I like the
new stuff anything new and different
that's what I want to try out and I want
to be the first to tell you if it sucks
or if it's awesome
the challenges of being business
partners and being married especially in
a pandemic your home is your office your
office is your home I would say some
days I'm the janitor you know and then
other days I'm the CFO so
[Music]
Chad has seen you know returns of a
hundred to a thousand percent on some
shoes the Stewie Griffin is actually the
highest dollar amount for one pair of
sneakers so the shoe was never released
to the public about two years ago I sold
that shoe for nine thousand dollars
just to see people oh goal at a shoe
that they've only heard of and to see
people's Jaws just drop like isn't that
what we do with art all the time is we
go to a museum we look at it we love it
we talk about it because it makes us
feel things I mean that's what my
Personal Collection is it's my museum in
my house
the sneaker boom has also created
opportunities for new generation of
Speculator the potential to get rich
quickly in an informal setting with
little oversight drew a new breed of
online gen Z Trader exchanges like
stockx they commodify this hobby that we
love the personal communication was
taken out and Community was taken away
I don't think that the audience has
changed I think that it has grown and so
it has expanded to include the white kid
from the suburb that is influenced by
the Black Culture I'm so happy to see
the world enjoy sneakers and see what's
so dope about them but it can sometimes
feel like a gentrification you want it
to still have some of the flavor the
people that made it what it is that's
another reason why we were so happy to
create another Lane is that we didn't
see anybody that looked like us at the
top of these sneaker companies and so we
wanted to assign that face and put us
back into space in places
foreign
years it was completely and totally for
the the passion and the Art of it I had
all these sneakers because I love them I
love to wear them I love to play in them
I love to show them off also it's it's
really about the personal connections
that you make along the way there are
people that Chad waited in line with
with sneakers and now they're really
close friends and he's been in their
wedding that is what a community gives
you
it's expanded my life like I'm from
Brooklyn my network though has taken me
all over the world because of my life
for sneakers I know what it felt like
when I got that pair of shoes from my
Personal Collection so to be able to
share something like that and that same
feeling be transferred that's the best
part of it
foreign
[Music]
World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
as a content creator seeing all the
things that we can do for an artist or a
company and receiving such a little pay
for our artistic Creations it was a slap
in the face really going live right now
you know when it's content I made
and it's just somebody random just took
it and they got so much more credit
racism isn't exclusive to a certain
field and so even when you have new
Fields like the influencer industry it's
gonna make its way in there too
[Music]
I've been an influencer for about a year
now I'm currently known for choreography
I created a viral dance to One of making
the stallion song Captain Hook
call it call it Captain Hook I noticed a
pay Gap in my industry as soon as I
started I noticed pay gaps in the
industry when I was on Vine I didn't get
any brand deals I was one of the top
creators on the app I had 1.6 million
followers other like creators who's not
a person of color who didn't have as
much activity as me or as many followers
as me but still will work with big
Brands I did this ad there were a couple
other influencers on the brand there
with me I come to find out that they had
made like double of what I was making
and one of them had way less followers
in me and then to think about what I was
originally offered like what did they
offer him I created a dance for a record
company they paid me at bottom line 700
compared to Addison Ray she definitely
got a higher pay of what they offered me
to even create the dance
foreign
[Music]
influencer hops on it and all of a
sudden it blows up and they credit this
white girl for something that a black
girl created if a bigger white account
reposts your dance without tagging you
nine times out of ten that artist is
going to automatically see their post
and without your name anywhere on the
video or in the comments nobody knows
that you created it people take
advantage of like black creatives it's
like this trend and it's all fun and
then sewing profits off of it off of
something that a black Creator started
the way that I've had to change my
content actually varies in a lot of
different ways certain things I can't
wear certain things that I can't really
speak on because I know that it will be
Shadow banned and all around just having
to push 10 times harder full hair full
makeup fully dressed and just 100
Glam to be able to get to that point of
viral
creatively I can think of a really great
idea but in the back of my head it's
like can I even post this because I use
the n-word or something and the brand
wouldn't look my way because I made them
feel uncomfortable when I'm speaking to
my audience and my audience
understanding the way I communicate with
them can't use a lot of profanity and
stuff but then I always see like other
influencers white influencers and it's
like oh that's raunchy comedy but but
then when I use it it's looked at In a
Different Light I'll be like this
squeaky clean influencer like fake
optimism all the time I didn't want to
make anybody uncomfortable and
potentially lose out on a brand deal
it's a problem like us just being
ourselves when the companies be out of
touch with the black community the black
lives matter 2020 really showed the true
colors of different companies in in the
industry in general I don't find it
surprising that black Talent managers
are getting more calls for their black
creators I did get more brand deals as
everything was going on because
everybody was stuck in the house and
everybody's on social media I feel like
it was more prominent for them to make
it seem like they did care about black
lives when in general before the
pandemic no one really backed an eye at
it I appreciate the brands working with
the black creators and starting to go in
that direction but was it a trend that
they wanted to work when more black
creators because they felt guilty I just
hope that it continues it definitely
makes it seem as if
people can be used at the power of
someone else's financial gain what I
hope to see change in the industry is
the black creatives get the credit that
we deserve I hope to see genuine
appreciation for black creators not just
when it's convenient
[Music]
foreign
and people usually know me from my
channel Ryan's world
[Music]
[Applause]
this is Ryan's world
a YouTube page that has garnered over 29
million subscribers and over 45 billion
Channel views since launching in 2015.
[Music]
when I did my first YouTube video I was
three years old in my Channel at that
time was called Ryan's toys review
my most popular video is when I was
outside on a bounce house and I was
looking for Easter eggs how many views
did that video get two billions
that first we thought it was somebody
pranking Us on YouTube why are we
getting so many views yeah we generally
questioned who's watching
Ryan's world has been the highest
earning YouTube channel for each of the
last three years earning Ryan and his
parents 30 million in income in 2020
alone thanks to a combination of
sponsorships and ads one great thing
about YouTube is that you can film
whenever and wherever so it's really
flexible so you want to create the
environment it's safe and trusting
environment for kids so they feel
comfortable and have fun when they film
ready it hasn't been entirely smooth for
the family
in 2019 the caduce main channel was the
subject of a complaint by the group
truth in advertising to the Federal
Trade Commission for failure to disclose
promotional content
a shift to off-platform Deals
incorporating toys and branded
merchandise has helped Ryan's World
maintain forward momentum through
YouTube's Ebbs and flows
what our core principle is to entertain
the kids and Ryan's World fans and feel
connected with them through creating
videos merchandise products or our own
video games or TV shows
and at that same time and I really want
to show kids that education can be fun
yeah we call it edutainment it's a
combination of education and
entertainment
one year after we launched our Channel
we decided to start our own company and
we started hiring video editors
producers animators and voice actors
streamlining the workload and minimizing
Alliance participation yeah we always
make sure that Ryan knows that
schoolwork comes first we limit our
filming time with Ryan within three to
four hours a week and that's really
allowing us to maintain his childhood as
a normal kid what do you like to do for
fun when you're not doing videos I like
to rollerblade and play with my iPad and
talk to my friends while we can play
games
[Music]
but Ryan's Persona both on and offline
will continue to be a family focus in
the near term
when do you think you'll keep reviewing
toys and making videos until forever
when I'm 25 I fully develop my brain as
an adult so after that maybe I can do
something else any idea what you'd want
to do sure thing
you know what you want to be when you
grow up like for a job
I'm a developer so I can show off my own
games
we're really fortunate that how many
kids around the world resonate with
Hawaiian and you know maybe Ryan is the
reason they can move forward through
their difficult days so just knowing
that aspects makes us feel happy
creating content
[Music]
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
of our puzzles is a photograph and
they're each intended to be a moment in
time and a world that you can dive into
and immerse yourself in
I'm Rachel hawkhouser co-founder of
Peace work puzzles we started piece work
in the summer of 2019 it has been quite
the roller coaster of a year and a half
as far as launching a business goes a
few years ago I booked a cabin in
Yosemite with the goal of spending the
whole time outdoors and lo and behold I
was rained in and there was a closet
full of Dusty old fuddy-duty jigsaw
puzzles and I spent the whole weekend
working on them and found it was
incredibly restorative and relaxing and
almost meditative
so we loved doing puzzles but we felt
like there were none out there that
spoke to our personal aesthetic you know
everything in our lives have been
reconsidered at this point from electric
toothbrushes to luggage and here the
humble jigsaw puzzle you know an
all-time favorite had never really been
reconsidered and here we are a few years
later you know with a puzzle company
[Music]
what truly sets peace work apart is that
we create all of our art in-house every
single one of our puzzles is a
photograph and they each have their own
title and they grow like a collection on
your shelf so whether it's you know a
wild disco party or Cowboy themed you
know there's these different personas
and themes that you can escape into for
an evening or a few weeks at a time
we start with a concept always we have
an idea of a moment that we want to
create and I partner closely with a
photographer to bring that to life then
we have packaging design creating
something that you would want to leave
out on your coffee table our puzzles are
produced and then we launch it in Market
from you know smaller boutiques to
anthropology CB2 we were in Nordstrom's
holiday shop
onto social media and you know takes on
a life of its own
you really go a bit wild in our own
Communications and marketing that make
an impression and we think it makes a
big difference
[Music]
covet had a really significant impact on
our business because the demand for
puzzles skyrocketed we sold out of all
of our inventory more than once we had
to switch manufacturers and we had
quickly figured out how to scale
everything across the business in a
really short period of time or after you
know all the stress is said and done we
have a higher quality product we're
really proud to say that everything all
of our puzzles are made out of 100
recycled material so it ended up being a
real silver lining for us
foreign
we don't think that the interest in
Puzzles and Games is actually going to
wane once the pandemic ends there was
already a larger trend of Millennials in
particular looking for means to get away
from their screens and find means to
unplug and we're really happy to be
producing something that does enable
people to look inwards or you know relax
a bit or find a meditative moment it's
important to us and we're happy you know
to be a part of them
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring just to see what's
moving the markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers and Industry experts be
alive and on-demand webinars only from
Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
tennis isn't a cheap sport when we
travel around the world every single day
we're spending our own money and we
don't earn too much from playing on the
ITF tour I think a lot of the times
people see the WTA tournaments the grand
slams or the Glamorous kind of stuff and
that's not really what it's truly like
playing on the on the ITF tour after
several years of internal dispute
covid-19 is forcing tennis leaders to
contemplate wide-ranging structural
reforms since most tennis players are
dependent on tournaments in order to
make a living decimated ticket sales and
a potential drop in prize money for 2021
are leading to a greater call for a
tennis players Association the players
that you see are the most often are
probably Serena Djokovic Federer and you
see you know they're earning millions
and millions of dollars every year and
that's kind of not the case with the
majority of tennis players tennis player
Tara Moore who currently ranks 208 has
joined the ITF players panel and has
been working to improve communication
within the organizations
she is also working with bashek
post-basil to persuade female players to
join the Breakaway Association I found
being the ranking that I am now you're
definitely not earning money you're
spending your own money you have to
coach a lot of the times outside of
playing tournaments so not only are we
are we training every single day for
five six seven hours and we're also
coaching on top of that just to be able
to travel to these tournaments earning
money is great but our expenditures are
a lot higher than our earnings tennis
generates about 2 billion dollars in
revenue and about 60 percent of it comes
from the grand slams but for most of the
Year players compete in smaller
tournaments men play with the
association of tennis professionals ATP
women play with the women's tennis
Association wtp and there's a third
governing body called International
tennis Federation ITF some say it is the
sports faction governance that's holding
back its growth
the its and the WKA are completely
separate entities so when WTA
tournaments stopped running the ITF sort
of followed suit and stopped running
their tournaments as well when they were
talking about restarting the tournament
calendars a lot of the top players have
played inside the top 150 had access to
calendars that players outside the top
150 did it just because they were able
to attend WTA meetings even though I'm
an associate member of the WTA I wasn't
privy to these meetings none of my peers
were as well like the players that I
interact with are from the ITF tour
tennis is the fourth most popular sport
in the world and its Superstars are
among the best paid athletes on the
planet but as a business the sport only
accounts for 1.3 percent of total value
of global television rights in 2019 the
100th most successful golfer on the PGA
tour made more than a million dollars in
prize money twice as much as this
counterpart in the men's tennis ranking
the lack of earnings are leading players
to seek out second jobs I think it's
it's
made a greater golf between the top
players and the lower rack players
because as you can see the the calendars
for the WTA and HP are preschool and
pretty well-rounded a lot of players are
unable to play right now we don't have
the same access to resources we don't
have the same access to tournaments we
don't we're not able to travel as much
as the players at the higher level so I
think it's really showing the disparity
between the top players and the lower
ranked players right now
the athletes are hoping that developing
the professional tennis players
Association co-founded by number one
player Novak Djokovic and vashik
postpasil will help protect players
rights unite the various organizations
and bridge the gap between top and lower
ranking players
covid-19 affecting so many tennis
players the leaders are expecting a
greater push for the organization
if I can help the Next Generation earn
more money better at the sport and help
the sport grow then I'm helping the
future of tennis
thank you
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
when you think of a skateboarder people
have this image of you know this white
guy and he's probably got like long hair
or something like that it just kind of
looked over women
my passion for skateboarding started
when I was really young I'd seen all the
neighborhood kids doing it and I wanted
to try it as well
I served proper Nar around 10 years ago
I just felt like the skateboarding
industry had just kind of skipped over a
bunch of people especially black women
in particular weren't really represented
so I wanted to do something to change
that
proper Nara cells clothing hats
skateboards skateboard accessories I
like things with color I like things
that represent me I I just like
different types of art
I do kind of get my inspiration from
everywhere I'm a big anime fan a big
fantasy fan I think what makes my
designs different is the colors that I
use a lot of my work is more feminine
and then I also use a lot of women in my
art particularly black women which I
feel like is something that isn't really
seen in the skateboarding industry
my main mission for this company is to
just get more women in minorities
skateboarding I want people to know that
you know no matter what you look like
and no matter your size color anything
like you should just get out there and
try it
[Music]
so it's really weird but um covet has
had a positive effect on my business
when everything shut down and you
couldn't hang out with each other
skateboarding was one of those things
where you can go outside and do that by
yourself and throughout covid a lot more
people have gotten into skateboarding
and then there was a lot of protest over
the summer I feel like people really
started to support black owned
businesses more so I got a lot of
attention for being a black owned
Skateboarding company Beyonce did this
thing where she had the black parade and
I was one of the companies that she
featured on her website from that and so
my company kind of went viral at the
beginning of July there and it was a lot
to handle so I had to figure out how to
hire people you know how to ship all
these orders I had to get more space
before this happened I was working out
of an extra bedroom in my house
when I first started skateboarding I
never thought that I would have a
Skateboarding company it was just a kind
of a hobby that I had it gets crazy I
sell boards in China now like I never
thought that my art would make it that
far
I think of you know my ancestors and the
dreams that they had and they weren't
able to accomplish those things maybe
because of laws or you know just being
discriminated against so I'm really
happy that I'm alive and an age like
today where I can pretty much accomplish
whatever I put my mind to
[Music]
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers and Industry experts be
alive and on-demand webinars only from
Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
thank you
a company preserving the planet with
carbon credits and an asset management
firm have created the world's first
carbon neutral asset fund I sat down
with moss Earth and one River Asset
Management to see what it's all about
[Music]
you can think of one River as the
solution provider declines so when a
client has a portfolio problem they come
to one River and say here's the problem
we're trying to solve help us solve it
and and that came to us uh through
through digital as well so the question
became okay we would we would like to
get institutional grade exposure to the
digital space how do we do it what are
Best Practices can we build an
infrastructure that resembles the types
of infrastructure we would see in liquid
markets mosque on Earth
it's a global company based in many
countries now originally you know set up
in Brazil
that is one of the leading if not the
largest carbon platform in the world
what we do is we buy government credits
wholesale from the leading uh forestry
conservation projects in the Amazon
forest and we sell retail to individuals
and small medium businesses and large
corporates so a lot of our time has
spent just listening to clients
you know they're they're they're very
engaged in the digital space to
understand more understand how it
integrates their portfolios what
problems they can solve and and the
common thing that kept coming up was
well Bitcoin is an energy harm and then
there's confusion as to what it means to
be an energy hog and what it means to be
an emitter right and we know that over
time you can easily come to a
crystallization that Bitcoin is
ultimately a source of good on the
renewable side but we'll see that that's
it that's a long Horizon View in the
meantime we're we're saddled with this
obvious challenge of having an enormous
amount of energy consumption and
Emissions associated with it the the the
nature of the credits that that Luis and
Moss Earth are are generating how those
are tokenized almost the humanization of
the credit at some level the token the
mco2 token represents uh one carbocratic
which itself represents uh one ton of uh
avoided CO2 emissions
it's not as expensive or as much of his
initial as people think so for every
forty thousand dollar Bitcoin you know
you know uh you can you have to spend 10
bits that's forty dollars to to offset
it and uh it's only function
is you know you can either hold on to it
or you can consume it and by consuming
it the holder transfers the token to the
most website and you know that token
gets burnt and the corresponding carbon
offset you know the global registry uh
gets canceled and in return you know the
person gets a global certificate that
proves that that pollution has been
mitigated you know via the work of of
environmental projects now the catch or
the interesting thing about carbon
credits is that they're a digital
commodity so just like uh wine you know
you can bring the sink you can sit on it
and enough 100 to 100 A Thousand Years
it'll still be the same so you can sort
of open the wine and drink it you can
also just burn the token and consume
that carbon Credit in many many years in
the future because the asset doesn't
expire and another thing that you can do
as well is to buy and you know if the
price goes higher sell it at a higher
price but the main main function is
really for compensation that's where 90
95 of the demand is large corporates
buying these credits and these tokens to
burn them and then get the corresponding
international certificate that proves
that they mitigate it that's the value
for them getting certified that their
emissions were mitigated or or offset
somehow we estimate that
um around 33 million trees are going to
be saved buy one Rivers Acquisitions of
of carbon credit you know big Bitcoin
the numbers range from 50 to 60 million
tons of carbon per year
you know if those are acquired you know
in carbon credits to offset that we're
talking about 500 million dollars being
channeled to environmental projects and
if that goes to forestry projects wow
that's a lot of Chase we're talking
about billions and billions of trees the
remarkable thing and the reason why I
think Bitcoin is being held to a higher
standards that's new
so we don't know what it's going to
become yet so there's all sorts of
speculation as to how it'll be used and
where it'll be used and isn't money is
it Nomine and so on and so forth but
it's new the thing we can all agree upon
is that these These are still nascent
markets the institutions are not deeply
engaged yet so as a result that gives
Bitcoin a massive Advantage I see a lot
of people focusing on the absolute
emission of carbon for crypto you know
saying oh you know Bitcoin emits Mark
garment than Holland and Argentina and I
think it's my greatest is that way of
thinking is you know you shouldn't think
on an absolute basis you should stick on
a relative basis Bitcoin and crypto are
way more efficient than you know the
traditional system the traditional
system of course requires you know a
next number of etms and buildings with
people working you know to make the
transactions work these people use cars
to drive and planes to meet and that
generates a lot of carbon of course it's
looking for you know paper money
generates a lot of carbon because it's
paper right you gotta cut trees and the
math you know is that crypto emits
one-third less per dollar than the
traditional system and as we saw the
offsetting is is quite quite cheap so
it's in a way it's also cheap you know
to take a shot of sort of a cheap shot
at crypto to say that it emits if you're
just looking on an absolute basis you're
not you know really comparing with the
effects of the existing system this is
decrypted I am not Eddie vanderwalt for
more content like this please follow us
on your favorite platforms
access the financial World On Demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
here's what the Skeptics think about
Bitcoin
[Music]
after catastrophic collapse that saw a
drop as much as 83 since the start of
2017 it's come roaring back to trade at
record highs it's nothing more than a
collection of zeros and ones stored on
computer hard drives yet people are now
regularly paying more than fifty
thousand dollars for one of these
artificially scarce digital assets but
not everybody's convinced it's a good
idea and there are still a fair few
people out there who call it a scam a
Ponzi scheme or just plain and simple a
waste of good energy
but let's start with the Believers
created in the wreckage of the 2008
Global financial crisis Bitcoin was a
response to ultra loose monetary policy
and the central banks printing money its
mysterious Creator who went by the name
of Satoshi Nakamoto wanted to create a
digital version of gold the aim was to
create an asset backed by cryptography
that would eventually become a hard
currency that could supplant the dollar
in doing so Satoshi solved an age-old
computer science Paradox one called the
two generals problem the basic idea of
this Paradox was it was almost
impossible for two parties who didn't
trust one another to transact without an
intermediary that both parties have
complete faith in enter the blockchain a
public Ledger that records every
transaction ever made with Bitcoin and
can only be changed if a majority of
Ledger writers agree at the same time it
requires proof of work a concept that
means energy was expended to create new
Bitcoin and the genius of the idea
doesn't end there the real master stroke
was in defining in the original Bitcoin
code and the white paper that acted as
the statement of intent that there would
be a cap on Supply created at a
diminishing rate until created
algorithmic d by a process described as
mining but which involves thousands of
computers solving mathematical problems
the last Bitcoin is minted in about
2140. so who are the people getting in
on bitcoin
in the early days Bitcoin investors were
a Motley Crew of computer nerds gold
bugs and hard money adherents the first
transaction for real-world goods took
place in 2010 when programmer Laszlo
hanyek paid 10 000 Bitcoin for two large
Papa John's Pizzas today though droves
of investors are in on it by the end of
last year they were more than 63 million
wallet addresses that one investor can
have many addresses or none we've seen
retail in this institutional money
flowing into the space even Elon Musk
caught the fever
so who doesn't like it loads of people
and from all walks of life first from
the sphere of computer science there's
Bill Gates he's publicly joked that
unless you're the richest person in the
world it's probably not a good idea for
you to get in then in the investment
sphere JP Morgan CEO Jamie dimon at
various points in last few years said it
was not his cup of tea a terrible store
of value and at one point a fraud though
he later walked back the last comment
and finally there's Regulators some of
whom have kept it at arm's length
waiting to see how it develops While
others have warned that those buying it
could lose all their money so what are
the charges against Bitcoin well Bitcoin
failed in its original goal of
displacing the dollar few people use it
to transact because it's simply too
volatile instead it's become a purely
speculative asset people buy it hoping
that other people will buy it from them
at a higher price that's called the
greater full theory of investing and
like a Ponzi scheme it requires a
constant stream of new money coming in
to make it increase in value when that
stream stops the critics warn the whole
thing might collapse
at the same time all those computers
mining new Bitcoin and scribbling the
blockchain require vast amounts of
electricity the network probably
consumes as much energy as the country
of Argentina and its thirst just keeps
on growing perhaps the hardest criticism
to dismiss is that Bitcoin is hard to
scale up and inefficient
Visa might clear 1 700 transactions per
second Bitcoin five and generally the
dystopian vision of a trustless world is
unfounded it's almost always cheaper to
adopt a central counterparty whose job
and profit comes from the trust placed
in it one such example is a
Clearinghouse at a stock exchange who
stands between parties making sure no
one loses money if the other side of the
trade defaults in short there are better
ways to solve problems Bitcoin is trying
to solve I'm Eddie vanderwalt for more
on the world of cryptocurrencies follow
us on quick take and Bloomberg
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
have cryptocurrencies finally grown up
[Laughter]
cryptocurrencies have got a bad rep over
the years from high volatility that seen
prices drop by 80 or more through claims
that they've been used for money
laundering and Drug deals to investors
losing access to their funds because
exchanges got hacked or became
accessible why is it that they haven't
disappeared from the investment universe
and have they finally outgrown their
uncertain Beginnings to Warrant a place
in the mainstream portfolio what was the
biggest problem for cryptocurrencies
back in 2016 when Bitcoin and other
digital assets burst into popular
Consciousness as they broke to record
highs investing in them took a fair bit
of determination some big leaps of Faith
or even technical Savvy either the buyer
had to send money to a largely
unregulated exchange often with an
offshore bank account in a tax Haven or
they had to set up Wallets on their own
computers and take responsibility for
safeguarding their own Holdings in both
cases this led to Big loss such as when
the 30-year-old founder of quadringa
died taking his exchange wallet password
to his grave and losing his investors
135 million dollars
so what's changed today we're looking at
a whole new landscape custody has
largely been sorted and Retail investors
in the U.S can buy Bitcoin directly via
their PayPal accounts that means they
never have to store the assets on their
local computer and they can leave the
money with a name they know
similar moves have happened elsewhere
with revolut and the UK offering
civilist services and MasterCard
indicating it's willing to get into the
game but what about institutional
investors
institutional investors like Pension
funds hedge funds and Broad money
managers have different needs than
retail customers they want a Futures and
options Market where they can lay off
risk and they want deep liquidity so
they can trade in size and they want a
Clearinghouse to stand as a trusted
counterparty and these things have
started to emerge CME Group which
operates one of the largest derivative
exchanges trading everything from gold
to FX to interest rate products have one
of the more established Bitcoin product
portfolios
others are working on ETFs and together
that's removed some of the wild west
from the cryptocurrencies so does that
mean the end for the old cryptocurrency
exchanges
probably not binance coinbase and Kraken
have gone from strength to strength
adding more staff throughout the
pandemic they're trading billions of
dollars in volume on a daily basis and
looks set to remain the home of the
hardcore crypto Enthusiast they also
still the main point of price Discovery
as a flash crash on Kraken proved
recently so everyone should put Bitcoin
in their Pension funds not so fast even
if the custody has been sorted this
asset class remains extremely volatile
yes it's capable of explosive upside but
history shows it's also capable of
catastrophic collapses and that alone
makes it unsuitable for most investors
Beyond some fractional allocation
but at least now if investors do decide
to take a position they can do so
without the fear of getting scammed I'm
Eddie vanderwalt for more on the world
of cryptocurrencies follow us on quick
take and Bloomberg
[Music]
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
IPOs show crypto is growing up
Bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies have
long existed on the edges of global
Finance occupying a strange parallel
universe
for many in markets they probably
resembled the wild west now with IPOs
and traditional trading venues opening
up it seems that the industry is
becoming a little more refined coinbase
the biggest U.S crypto trading venue has
launched its IPO which is perhaps the
biggest development in the space since
Satoshi Nakamoto wrote his white paper
the listing democratizes a key part of
the infrastructure and gives more
risk-averse and fundamental investors a
way to value and profit from new
technology
think of this IPO as selling shovels in
a gold rush investing in an exchange
doesn't require the belief that crypto
will replace the dollar
as long as there are those who are
willing to buy and trade crypto volume
at this new class of exchange should do
well beyond coinbase is pure size though
what makes it significant for investors
is that it offers a way of applying the
methods of traditional Finance to crypto
discount cash flow models don't work on
quasi-currencies that pay no yield and
rely on the greater full theory of
investing the old Gordon growth model
can easily be applied to the business of
an exchange though as can free cash flow
models residual income models PE and pig
ratios and the whole panoply of tools
Equity analysts have developed over the
years of course those same valuation
metrics may show that coinbase is
significantly more than fairly valued
and yes listings like these run somewhat
contrary to the non-conformist spirit of
crypto
Bitcoin promised a new decentralized
world order where Sovereign individuals
transact directly with one another
without the need for intermediaries like
Banks exchanges and clearinghouses
instead the most lucrative crypto
related companies are those that provide
Financial Services in fact it's perhaps
a little ironic that for an asset class
that promised to do away with
intermediaries financial exchanges have
been among the biggest winners
in the early days these operated in a
regulation vacuum nobody know what these
assets were in any way they were too
small for Regulators to bother with so
predictably they were high-profile
failures
for the most part though the industry
seems to be shaking off those uncertain
beginnings and names like binance Kraken
and bitfenix now trade billions in
digital assets every day
there may soon be more IPOs in this
space
a play on exchanges and other trading
infrastructure might give the investor a
buffer against volatility whether
Bitcoin ethereum and doji coin rallies
or plunges trading activity is likely to
be robust it only tends to fall in
periods of price stability and this
second layer exposure also removes some
of the risk of betting on the wrong
horse who knows if crypto products
cardano polka dot coin or Tron end up
the eventual winner yet it's reasonable
to assume they'll all rely on the same
trading venues as the current crop
of course these Investments don't come
without risks the regulation issue
remains unsettled and the future may
bring consolidation and more
high-profile failures as well as trading
fee price Wars meanwhile existing
non-crypto exchanges are starting to
have a look CME which offers contracts
in FX Commodities and fixed income has
launched its own Suite of cryptocurrency
derivatives
and there's always the chance that
Bitcoin will go back to its roots with
transactions across oceans taking place
directly between Sovereign individuals
I'm Eddie vanderwalt this is decrypted
for more content like this follow us on
your favorite platforms
foreign
[Music]
World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
every Doge has its day
[Music]
it's not doggy coin it's not dodgy coin
it's Dogecoin at least I think it is
Dogecoin was started as a parody of
cryptocurrencies by two software
engineers and it was a great laugh
using an emblem of a Shiba Inu and the
intentional misspelling of the word dog
like when crypto enthusiasts say when
Moon sir it caught the imagination of
crypto junkies everywhere and then it
took off see Elon Musk went and tweeted
a picture of himself in a pose from a
scene in The Lion King holding up the
Dogecoin dog and the internet loved it
so much so that at one point it was up
400 in a week that meant that at that
moment in time it had beaten the Returns
on bitcoin over every time frame since
it was invented on a market cap basis it
was the fifth biggest crypto in the
world Dogecoin is different from Bitcoin
it makes no pretensive fixed Supply
while there were only ever be 21 million
Bitcoin in circulation Dogecoin started
its initial output with a hundred
billion coins in circulation with 5
billion new coins put into circulation
every year from then on for some that's
a better monetary policy it gets rid of
the risk of extreme deflation some worry
about with Bitcoin and in more closely
models modern Central Banking now for a
few in the crypto Community Dogecoin is
an embarrassment
it undermines the claims to
respectability that they crave it's a
misfit among Misfits as my good friend
Joe wasn't I'll put it all the serious
stuff about decentralized Finance stores
of value or people thirsting for an
alternative to the dollar nobody can
talk about that stuff with a straight
face when it comes to Dogecoin he says
you could intellectualize the whole
thing about how money's always been a
shared meme
but really all the crypto talking points
go out the window with Doge except that
isn't a bug it's a feature what Dogecoin
does better than any of its Rivals is
caucus Snoop at The Establishment
whether inside traditional Finance or
inside the digital currency community
and that more than anything else is what
crypto is all about and as they say in
the long run there's no highs no lows
there's only Doge
I'm Eddie vanderwalt this is decrypted
for more content like this follow us on
your favorite platforms
access the financial World On Demand
foreign
hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
crypto mining in the Arctic Circle
[Music]
Bitcoins had its fair share of ups and
downs over the years from rallying 13
000 in 2017 to crashing 70 the year
after but through all this one thing has
stayed the same without miners there'd
be no Bitcoin of course mining crypto
isn't like mining gold there's no
diggers no explosives and no smelters
involved Jose is a fair bit of heat and
they'll come back to that later let's
rewind to 2008 when the mysterious
Satoshi Nakamoto published a white paper
containing the template for the birth of
all cryptocurrencies it explains the
process whereby electricity and CPU time
is spent in a process that attempts to
solve the problem of sending money
across a distributed Network removing
the need for intermediaries effectively
it seeks to solve the problem of trust
in a digital era and to do so it relies
on a concept called proof of work like
old-fashioned gold miners panning for
metal these CPUs have to hunt for a hash
that allows them to write the next block
on the blockchain and then get rewarded
by some freshly minted Bitcoin from a
pool that's designed to never contain
more than 21 million
now in the early days anyone could mine
Bitcoin all you needed was to install
some software on your home PC or laptop
and offered wins early adopters
sometimes saw it more as a computer game
than the start of a financial Revolution
to mine Bitcoin requires specialized
equipment and a lot of electricity
because the rate of production of
Bitcoin is fixed but the CPU power
expended on creating it is not the
variable that keeps it all in balance is
the difficulty of mining as more people
compete for each new Bitcoin the level
of difficulty is increased and that
creates one of two routes to mining
Bitcoin either wannabe miners can join
conglomerates called mining pools that
work together to solve the puzzle or
they can set up vast server Farms that
use graphical processing units over CPUs
for their greater number of cores such
server Farms have two problems first
they need a lot of cheap electricity
that's pushed some to set up shop near
hydroelectric facilities the cheapest
and incidentally one of the cleanest
forms of energy
and second all those computers need
Cooling and so in the Siberian city of
nerilsk beyond the polar Circle and only
reachable by plane or boat bit cluster
mining Farm has made its Mark quite
literally with a sculpture outside a
Stalin era nickel plant in temperatures
as low as minus 40 degrees celsius the
facility's 5000 rigs still need
ventilation to keep cools at full
capacity they expect a mine up to six
Bitcoins a day on average
and all of this for a collection of ones
and zeros that now regularly fetch more
than fifty thousand dollars ago this is
decrypted I'm Eddie vanderwalt for more
of the same follow us on your favorite
platforms
[Music]
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
thank you
coming up on quick take I think the
trainers who don't get into this
technology will lose it this is the
future of Fitness by Fall 2020 an
estimated 15 of gems across the US had
permanently closed amounting to roughly
480 000 job losses
but at home the relatively new fitness
company Peloton would not only see
astronomical growth but it became one of
the best performing stocks in 2020. we
saw the sales Spike you know almost
right away
then
the English Premier League is widely
regarded as being home to the very best
soccer in the world
it's watched by billions across the
globe making it the richest too
and while soccer
as we Americans call it isn't one of the
top sports here in the U.S it's never
seen so many American investors in the
UK
even American superheroes are getting in
on the action a billion plus people
interact with the EPL when you look at
any American sport there's nothing
anywhere close to it as radical plans to
transform the game have been revealed
U.S investors are increasingly viewed
with suspicion but will these changes be
for the good of the game or just the
wealthy owners all this and more on
quick take
[Music]
I'm here what once felt like the center
of the modern Fitness boom every workout
seemed to be within steps of here in
fact I worked out right here down the
street f45 berries boot camp a few
blocks away Soul cycle Equinox and so
many more
it all spoke to what we wanted to do in
terms of working out but even more than
that how we wanted to live our lives
what to eat what to wear it felt like
the future
the boutique Fitness industry grew so
fast it was almost becoming a bubble by
the end of 2019 it was estimated to have
been worth more than 100 billion dollars
then the global pandemic hit and it felt
like almost overnight the bubble had
burst and when we closed our Studios we
thought maybe we'll be reopen in three
four weeks we never could have imagined
how hard this was going to be
by Fall 2020 an estimated 15 of gems
across the US had permanently closed
amounting to roughly 480 000 job losses
but at home the relatively new fitness
company Peloton would not only see
astronomical growth but it became one of
the best performing stocks in 2020. we
saw the sales Spike you know almost
right away not just that people were
finding out about Peloton and interested
in the bike or the tread but that they
had no choice
Peloton went from a Kickstarter project
to a company worth more than 30 billion
dollars in just a few years but as the
world starts to solely return to normal
what happens next for at-home Fitness
in this episode of business of sports
we're going to sit down with Peloton CEO
John Foley to understand how this year
turned them into the new dominant brand
in Fitness and how they'll compete with
those Boutique Studios now starting to
reopen and the competition from industry
veterans looking to grow in the space I
can't imagine a year or a scenario where
more people realized
that Fitness and good nutrition
transcends vanity we'll also look at how
the technology that has made at home
fitness successful is also bringing in
both new voices and giving life to some
veteran ones
if I can make the camera be my student
then that means I would be talking to
the people behind me and the people that
I would have in front of me and I think
the trainers who don't get into this
technology will lose it this is the
future of fitness
[Music]
so full disclosure I'm a bit of a
fitness fanatic I've been a runner for a
long time and back in 2016 I wrote a
whole book about it called Sweat Equity
that gave me an excuse to try all sorts
of Boutique Fitness Concepts and yep I
own a Peloton so during the pandemic
I've been using that four to five times
a week
now with many things nothing's really
new Under the Sun we've seen at home
fitness enjoy huge success in the past
even making big marks on American
culture it is very important that you
always concentrate exactly on the
muscles that you're working on take it
up and down two and down keep that
energy up watch your posture well it may
not be as technologically shiny as some
things we know now the Thigh Master
revolutionized the way women approach
Fitness at home netting more than 200
million dollars in sales since launching
three decades ago
cementing its status and its iconic
spokeswoman as a household name
I think it's the titillating aspect of
you just put it between your knees and
squeeze we gave a little booklet with it
that said you know do these exercises
and you'll get you know uh thighs so
tight you can crack walnuts and although
there was a plethora of at-home workout
machines for every kind of exercise you
can imagine it was the personalities
like Suzanne and Billy Blanks that kept
people coming back when I came out with
taebo the goal was to be able to speak
to people and tell the truth about
Fitness I was not gonna lie to him I was
gonna say listen if you want to get in
shape it's tough if you're willing to
step out and use your will and use your
mind I'll be the person that'll help you
out Billy's tie boat classes would
become a pop culture phenomenon back in
the 1990s his programs delivered via VHS
tapes remember those they mixed
taekwondo with boxing and reached
millions of at-home Fitness enthusiasts
with a tough but approachable
personality still he even says it was no
comparison to one-on-one coaching
with the videotape I did my best to do
that but I did it Blindside but I knew
inside of my heart
because I wanted people to talk to me
you know how you you know how you want
somebody to tell you how to make
yourself be better you know so I would
just look at the camera and say hey I
see you over there I know you're tired
right now but come on get up you can
push through this after I start doing
Zoom it changed it really changed
because now I can interact with people
that desire for two-way personalized
interactions paved the way for boutique
Studios to flourish and soon it would be
the missing link the Peloton married
with content and Community Peloton
started like most technology companies
in its era pitching countless of
potential investors who initially and
roundly rejected the idea at you how
many no's did you get before you before
you gave it a yes I pitched over 400
institutions which included Venture
Capital late stage growth and private
equity and I got 400 no's Peloton
ultimately turned to Kickstarter to
fundraise what would become undisputedly
a revolution of sorts marrying form
function and Zeitgeist
the combination of interactivity
gamification and high quality content
make getting that Boutique Fitness
experience easier than ever inside your
own home and many were instantly
addicted
it also managed to incorporate the
fitness celebrities craze and got
members hooked on the instructors
so Peloton clearly was already on the
way up and the pandemic only boosted
demand to the point where even now
people are waiting months just to take
delivery of their bikes and Treads when
you have a product that's 49 a month and
then you divide that by two roughly
because you and your spouse or you live
in partner both ride you're looking at
twenty four dollars a month the location
is the best the instructors are the best
the community is the broadest the
software is the best and you start to do
the value calculation in your mind and I
think more and more people are piecing
that together
this is John Foley he's the CEO of
Peloton and we're here for an exclusive
look at the new Peloton studios in New
York they were just days away from
opening to the public last March then
the city and the world shut down almost
exactly a year ago like give or take a
couple weeks I was supposed to be here
in my capacity as a journalist you know
sort of checking this all out this great
unveiling that was then going to lead to
the public opening of these Studios that
visit didn't happen as you think back to
that tell me about those initial moments
those initial decisions that you had to
make very quickly when the crisis was
hitting New York City we had an event
planned for months and months and so it
was really disappointing and but we were
you know triaging how to move forward
like every other company and within uh
two weeks we had seven or eight
instructors streaming live from their
homes or their basement or their bedroom
yes welcome to my house I am coming to
you live from my parents homes
after the US went into lockdown Peloton
went from being that expensive bike from
that ad that people made fun of to the
bike everyone wanted to get their hands
or their butt on and in a little more
than a year peloton's the one actually
getting the last laugh the company
reported its first billion dollar sales
quarter this past February and much of
that could be attributed to people at
home those folks yearning to find a
common indoor activity with others to
help them get through the pandemic so
you know one of the funny things that I
mean I had this that experience as a
member was we're all used to the
instructors at least theoretically being
in our homes and now we're in in theirs
in some ways what was the feedback back
you heard and what was the net effect of
that moment again sort of a new level of
intimacy in some ways when those classes
live from home came out it was a super
special moment for for internally the
folks at Peloton I mean people were
freaked out people were nervous they
were scared they didn't know whether
their job was going to be there tomorrow
we really really wanted to be there for
them with not just content because you
could have taken a class from last year
but something authentic took place when
we didn't rely from home because it's
hey I'm here
Peloton stock which opened in 2019 to a
tepid response grew into one of the best
performing stocks in the world even amid
a massive bull market
and let's be honest the Peloton it's
expensive yes you can Finance it but
this is a bike that costs on average
about twenty five hundred dollars just
to get it then you've got a monthly fee
on top of that no matter people want it
and they're willing to wait months for
it it's become iconic a status symbol
like the iPhone of exercise
there's an interesting survey that we
saw that 59 of Americans said they're
not going back to the gym after covid if
you don't think that represents a big
opportunity for Peloton to continue
selling bikes and threads
[Music]
access the financial World On Demand
thank you hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
at bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
and while owning an exercise machine may
now be considered cool it's still a
giant piece of equipment that can pose
potential safety risks the US consumer
product safety commission recently
advised people to stop using the Peloton
tread when there are children or pets at
home after reports of injuries tied to
the machine
in a statement Peloton says it's working
to better inform tread owners of
safeguards to prevent these incidents at
home
still the market is saturated with
next-gen fitness equipment
Peloton first launched its bike back in
2014. Equinox and soul cycle have now
made their own at-home bike other
startups have adopted the Peloton model
for various types of exercise boxing
weight training rowing even kettlebell
training there's even been one that
received design treatments by the likes
of Eve Behar whose work you probably
recognized to the Jambox Herman Miller
chairs and SodaStream machines investors
in public and private markets sought out
companies to back and bolster companies
who could join Peloton in helping people
work out at home including some whose
brand recognition dates back decades
I could say as an entrepreneur in the
space I do have some anger issues that I
didn't see that coming and that I didn't
get ahead of it and it's our job to pay
attention to phenomenons and see you
know
can we improve on it in some ways for
ours this is Carl deichler more than 20
years ago he helped create the modern
Fitness industry rolling out workouts
like insanity P90x and many more under
the Beachbody brand funding the company
from profits ultimately left him looking
at other companies like Peloton grabbing
big chunks of the accelerating Fitness
market so to make its content better
suited to the way consumers interact
with digital media nowadays Carl teamed
up with New Media Executives behind
Disney plus and Tick Tock to help
modernize and scale the Beachbody
catalog we had to Bear the scrutiny of
these two professionals Tom Staggs and
Kevin Mayer and we could get their
expertise to help us steer through what
is a very ambitious plan of growth
our job is to create content in
Beachbody that is every bit as
interesting and could have as many
twists and turns and character
development as the best show on Netflix
and that's what we aspire to be that an
entertaining half hour that's not just
about how good the workout was but how
good I got to know the trainer and the
cast behind them
and instead of setting out to build its
own Hardware component Beachbody teamed
up with mixed Fitness a lower cost
alternative to Peloton to help get its
classes into more homes the combined
company ultimately filed to go public
through another hot item the special
purpose acquisition company or SPAC it
was like this perfect convergence that
came together that just made it an easy
decision far better for us than just
going public through an IPO
but competition is definitely coming
largely from those Boutique Fitness
Studios that are now reopening as the
pandemic subsides and back at home as
Carl knows there's lots of fun things to
keep you busy my problem with
competition is not the fact that I've
got more people in Connected Fitness and
digital Fitness content it's that there
is so much good entertainment available
that there is every reason not to work
out
other Boutique Fitness companies have
tried going the virtual route but are
still betting on the return of in-person
Studio classes and mallam the founder
and executive chair of solid core a
boutique Fitness chain was well on her
way to expanding her Studios when she
saw her Ambitions arrested by the
pandemic
still the company managed to win a new
round of capital earlier this year
it was my plan to sell the company just
felt like the right time to have 100
studios in seven years and obviously
that didn't happen and sitting here A
year later I have always felt you know
people are going to want to come back to
their life so synthesizing a lot of what
we've been talking about what is the
consumer look like on the other side of
this what's their approach to to Fitness
having you know like me and others been
you know working out in our homes in our
basements attics living rooms bedrooms
whatever it's going to be like what's
change do you think
I think it's actually going to propel
the industry forward because it's
everywhere you look as a consumer on
Instagram on any place you're being hit
with a lot of Health and Wellness
activity so I think it's going to be at
the Forefront of people's minds of okay
it's about time I get to it
[Music]
access the financial World On Demand
foreign hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
engaging personalities are a perennial
presence in the Fitness World whether on
a VHS tape a DVD a Peloton bike or in a
studio the pandemic technology combo
also boosted another category of at home
fitness influencers who don't need a
physical generous Studio a lot of
different muscles
firing up 10.
we were Avid gym goers at that time and
quite frankly like I was freaking out a
little bit so I leaned into my audience
on social media and I asked them hey
would you guys be interested if Nate and
I went on Instagram live and would you
want to work out with us
La based Remy ishizuka and Nate Pontius
are Wellness bloggers they launched a
workout program called home bodies
initially as a way to cope with the
first wave of shutdowns in California no
fancy setups no Studio production just
their living room and dog cameos
we decided to show up again the next day
and the next day and the next day we
ended up going live every single day for
three months straight every morning
and we wanted to make it as minimal and
accessible as possible for anyone around
the world who wanted to tune in and work
out
all you needed was your body weight and
your mat and you just had to show up
there are so many different things that
we do at home that you would not feel
comfortable doing in a like in a live
yoga class so whether that's farting or
wearing a sports bra it might be just
altering the practice in ways that the
teacher is not saying like maybe we're
doing 108 sun salutations and you would
rather practice corpse pose in a live
class you might not feel as comfortable
doing that as you do at home
yoga instructor author and podcaster
Jasmine Stanley has also embraced the
digital landscape she's reaching
audiences that never felt comfortable
with the boutique Fitness experience
she's advocated for a body positive
approach to Wellness for years but
launched a yoga app in 2019 it's called
the underbelly to help people practice
from the comfort of their own homes
independent creators like Jessman raymie
and Nate have all leaned into their
Niche to break stereotypes of
traditional gym goers demographics using
their personal stories to establish
close relationships with their followers
I had no interest in yoga like the
person who says oh my God I hate yoga
I've been before and it was awful I was
like one of the only black people there
or maybe the only fat person especially
in the beginning it was a deeply
alienating experience when I was looking
for fitzparation so to speak back in the
day I didn't see anyone that looked like
me or had my lifestyle who could relate
to loving hot pots loving noodles and
dumplings and Asian comfort food but
also living a healthy active lifestyle I
get a lot of messages from women that
are like I love when you share your
Japanese recipes they're so inspiring
like I think that whenever people see me
they're like huh fat black queer person
platform must be for other fat black
queer people and I'm like yeah that's
not the only type of person who has been
told to hate themselves like
all human beings deal with a desire for
self-acceptance just the other day was
looking at a message from someone who
was like I'm a man and I've never felt
comfortable in yoga classes and in your
classes I'm actually able to see myself
and I'm just like this is It's really
intense to me because ultimately like
again people aren't coming to us just
because like oh yeah I see someone who
looks like me they're just coming
because they're like you're keeping it
real
[Music]
beyond the classes themselves this new
wave of creators also use social media
to connect with fans beyond the workout
when they're not sweating alongside
their followers they use their platforms
to talk about everything from food to
books to clothes even their personal
struggles in life vital connections
especially during the pandemic it's a
reminder that exercise is not just
something we do but increasingly part of
Who We Are
members know us on a very intimate level
like they know what nay ate for
breakfast lunch and dinner they even
know that we've broken up at one point
and got back together and worked in a
relationship there is nothing that we
don't share and I think through being so
real and vulnerable on Instagram and
people watching can really relate to our
lifestyle and who we are as people I'm
pretty Cutthroat and I know how I come
off a lot of times and you know people
kind of get this image of me but a lot
of the homebodies members that have been
with us from the start they they get to
see the real me every day and I show up
and I teach them and I Inspire them
through movement and through my previous
failures
a sense of like realness is also
portrayed in our workout videos because
we don't edit out anything that happens
on the Reel like everyone at home their
kids running around their dogs licking
their face the postman ringing the
doorbell like all these real moments
happen while they're working out from
home I think that sense of like
relatability and like I feel like I'm in
your living room working out with you is
what people love
at the end of the day if it is fake it's
going to feel fake and it is not going
to provide success something that is
very common in the wellness industry is
kind of copycatitis where it's like you
see one company who's doing something
and so you're like oh yeah okay I need
to figure out a way to try to do what
they're doing it's not a good thing like
do not try to be like everybody else
figure out what your Niche is and just
stand in it
some Boutique Studios have found new
life in the at-home space remember burn
the place on 20th Street where I once
worked out well they've started selling
the slide board that was once part of
the in-studio workout and with a 9.99
month subscription they're looking to be
a low-cost at-home solution well below
the pelotons of the world and they've
got their own added star power Olympic
medalist and iconic speed skater Apollo
Ono
so as more Americans become vaccinated
against the coronavirus and more people
begin to think about the return to
normal now we're left wondering will the
new bubble of virtual at Home Fitness
First
I have been so glad to see this
transition of people coming home to
Fitness and and really allowing it to be
the most natural part of their lives
where you don't have to go anywhere else
but I also think that because of that
Comfort level at home that that will
increase the number of people who go out
to live classes and that that is really
what was missing from the before times
we weren't seeing this wide variety and
diversity of people like you were seeing
a very limited number of people
ultimately going out to a very specific
type of experience
and when the dust settles and the
pandemic is lying behind us where does
this all leave Peloton there was a news
journalist who was saying peloton's you
know had its day sell Peloton and uh and
of course he's wrong we have such a fire
in our belly the same fire that when
people didn't believe in US eight years
ago it feels like there's still so many
non-believers of Peloton and where we're
going every other person you talk to
will say what happens to Peloton after
covet people think that it's dark dark
clouds on the horizon for Peloton that
pessimism and disbelief in US fuels our
you know fuels our fire and there's
still so many naysayers that uh we're
excited to prove wrong
I finished my book back in 2016 with
what was probably not a very bold
prediction that this trend toward
Fitness and Wellness would continue
upward that we would only become more
enthusiastic about Fitness as we learned
the benefits not just physically but
mentally
now if you could have predicted that a
global pandemic would on the one hand
eviscerate the industry and on the other
embolden it
but the mega Trend it's intact we do
want to get healthier and there are a
lot more people to help us get there
thanks so much for watching would love
to hear what you think about this and
other episodes about the business of
sports I'll be in the comments section
can't wait to hear what you think
foreign
[Music]
World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
league is widely regarded as being home
to the very best soccer in the world
[Applause]
it's watched by billions across the
globe making it the richest too
and while soccer
as we Americans call it isn't one of the
top sports here in the U.S it's never
seen so many American investors in the
UK yay
even American superheroes are getting in
on the action hear the music
sports teams bring in a huge amount of
money for their owners but if you want
to buy into the NFL from the Dallas
Cowboys to the lowly Cleveland Browns
sorry Cleveland you probably need to be
a billionaire several times over
but for those who love what the rest of
the world calls football buying into the
English Premier League is way cheaper
and could give you a much better return
[Applause]
billion plus people interact with the
EPL when you look at any American sport
there's nothing anywhere close to it it
just smelled of opportunity to me
well the huge investment in the EPL is
intrinsically linked to the high quality
of the competition and its star names
Big Money talks and it doesn't care much
for history or tradition as radical
plans to transform the game have been
revealed U.S investors are increasingly
viewed with suspicion but will these
changes be for the good of the game or
just the wealthy owners
54-35
[Applause]
over aesthetic no northwich Victoria
Miller
[Music]
while our sporting sensibilities might
be drastically different
when it comes to sheer commercial
Enterprise the English Premier League is
right up there the Premier League's
broadcast revenue is more than 4 billion
dollars a season it's way richer than
the other European leagues even the ones
with global Superstars like Messi
Ronaldo and Neymar and more of us in the
states are tuning in too at the expense
of our own pro soccer league more than
twice as many people watch EPL games
than the MLS so how did English football
become such a hot deal for American
investors I needed an Englishman to help
me figure this out alright so Alex uh
educate me here like as an American I'm
intrigued but also a little bit confused
candidly by English football so what are
the main differences especially from the
business perspective I mean
fundamentally in the U.S uh you have a
league system whereby there are defined
number of teams in the league
revenues tend to be doled out a lot more
evenly between those teams obviously if
you finish a little bit higher at the
table you'll get a little bit more in
Europe particularly in the UK you have a
league system of four professional
divisions and then a number more amateur
divisions and theoretically if you or I
set up an amateur team tomorrow we could
inside a decade be playing in the
Premier League it's obviously in
practice a lot more difficult but by
being promoted up the tiers we could be
um a Premier League team
at 11 30 precisely the game gets
underway with Chelsea attacking it's
left Winger Tommy Knox working the ball
along across the Harrods then to
right-winger Murray straight into the
safe hands of England and Blackpool
goalkeeper Tony waiter a lot of the
history of these teams is so baked into
the community maybe in a way that that
it isn't here in the United States yeah
when you look at the names of teams
actually you can see some of that you
think about a team like Arsenal it was
actually the the team associated with
the Woolwich Arsenal a military base
south of the river in London with Aston
Villa that's my team it was a cricket
team that met up and said we want to
stay fit during the winter they met
outside Aston Villa a villa in the
Birmingham suburb of Aston name their
team after it this is a massive business
I mean the reason that this is
attracting so much investment ultimately
is because these team values have just
skyrocketed certainly
um in the EPL yes and a lot of that is
to do with the success in cultivating an
international audience the way that the
Premier League in particular has really
forged lead was in a sense by following
what happened in the U.S
foreign
in the early 90s they started doing
collective bargaining for their
broadcasting rights used to be the case
that if you were Manchester United or
Arsenal or whichever Club it might be
you would individually negotiate with
the broadcaster
they said actually we're better off as a
unit if we all negotiate together and
that's when the Premier League was
formed
you tied that up with the arrival of
Rupert Murdoch trying to bring a
satellite TV station to the UK
he recognized it was a huge amount of
passion for football if he could lock up
the rights for that he would secure an
audience for his pay TV station
[Music]
now since the Premier League was formed
we've seen a huge ballooning in the
valley of broadcast rights he's jumped
60 fold since uh 1992. so previously the
value of the rights was about 600 000
pounds per game in the most recent round
it was at about 9 million per game that
is astonishing so with those sorts of
figures it stands to reason that big
investors in the United States and
elsewhere would come calling and see a
lot of opportunity they've seen
opportunities for a bargain
you can buy a meddling football club for
several hundred million you can buy a
football club in the second tier for
considerably less than that you compare
that to the NFL where you know
franchises change hands for perhaps two
billion dollars it's a huge difference
then
[Applause]
the most famous US owners were the
glazers who owned the Tampa Bay Bucks
they came in and bought Manchester
United and they approached it with the
kind of attitude of a private Equity
company you compile a huge amount of
debt onto it extract some of that as
cash to line your own pockets and
because they are fundamentally media
assets you know it's quite resilient as
long as they invest enough in the
playing Squad keep them in the Champions
League you're going to be able to
generate enough free cash flow to
service your debt obligations
foreign
the glazers aren't exactly loved in
Manchester and to many British fans they
reflect the confusing emotions inspired
by U.S ownership incredible Financial
growth might also coincide with
declining sporting performance
if you're looking for a model of
American ownership to follow
it might just be man United's biggest
Rivals Liverpool
the current Champions have enjoyed a
Resurgence in recent years and that's
happened since they were taken over by
Fenway Sports Group those are the guys
behind the Boston Red Sox
an ownership group that knew what
success was about that knew how to build
um patiently everything that a football
club is about
Peter Moore he was the CEO of Liverpool
when they won the Champions League in
2019 and then the Premier League in
2020.
so Peter what did Fenway bring to
Liverpool maybe something specific that
they brought from running a very
successful and very fabled American
baseball team first thing that struck me
when I spoke with Mike Gordon is he said
we're not the owners of this football
club he said we have we have the
economic rights to do business on behalf
of this football club the owners of the
fans
for me certainly there was no true
interference in in how we manage the
football club we improved the structure
of the football club they applied
science and data all of the things that
they had learned you know in the days of
Theo Epstein and young general managers
and brought in actual scientists and
data analysts so that thousands of
players were analyzed that were in the
marketplace and our own players were
analyzed to get the best out of them
quick snap got protected in the pocket
but has to go underneath the ball comes
out and the 49ers are on it
one of the epl's newest American execs
comes with a deep knowledge of American
football and a business Acumen shaped by
decades in and around Silicon Valley but
he's the first to admit he's not a
soccer fan from the cradle
I started looking into soccer clubs
football clubs and in Europe gosh maybe
10 years ago at that time you know with
all due respect I still didn't know if a
soccer ball was puffed or stuffed parag
Morata is the president of 49ers
Enterprises which bought a stake in
Leeds United in 2018 part of an
ambitious effort by one of America's
storied franchises to expand its
portfolio at the time Leeds was itself a
fabled franchise but one that had fallen
on Hard Times leads were playing in the
second division of English football last
season they won promotion to the top
division the EPL
[Applause]
league
so tell me about promotion from a
business perspective because you're
doing a calculation here about a huge
potential upside you're talking about a
20x increase in per Club media rights uh
from going from the championship to the
Premier League you're still playing in
the same stadium with the same size you
know the same number of fans that can
come the same number of Suites and
premium but your media rights goes up
20-fold our motion to the Premier League
could be worth anywhere from 130 to 200
million pounds
just take this example in 2016 Another
Second Division team Wolverhampton
Wanderers were bought for around 63
million dollars they gained promotion
shortly after that and are now estimated
to be worth around 10 times that figure
taking a punt as they say in England on
a team rising up the divisions can
really pay off
but what goes up can also come down a
concept we Americans aren't exactly
familiar with two teams here who are
desperate for three points to avoid
relegation what are you looking forward
to well I'm looking forward to the
definition of relegation three teams
drop out of the Premier League every
season yes relegation is real and it's
kind of a you have to manage the
delicate balance because there is a
correlation between between acquiring
more players in the transfer market and
buying players to be able to comp to be
more competitive
um and and winning and matriculating up
the table right but at the same time
that comes with a risk because if you
buy if you spend a lot in the transfer
market you get relegated now all of a
sudden you're potentially more in a
world of hurt
um so yeah you do you do have to factor
that in and you do have to model that
one year ago uh the club's valuation was
much different uh than it is today right
and trying to figure out okay well which
one is the real sustainable valuation
like that's a hard exercise to do
I hope for parag and Leeds fans they
don't drop anytime soon the history of
British football is littered with
stories of Big Time clubs going down
and not making it back
but for many fans a relegation battle
can be just as exciting as the chase for
a championship
it's a very Performance Based system and
I'm sure there's probably some fans that
said wow I wish we had something like
that in America now I'm not suggesting
any owner wants that in America don't
get me wrong
Alan pace and his U.S investment from
ALK Capital have also just joined the
Premier League they've taken over
Burnley a team just 50 kilometers away
from Leeds in the north of England we
talk about performance-based stuff all
the time okay we in in business and as
entrepreneurs and as other things
Performance Based means you get rewarded
for performance and so it's it seems
kind of odd that you wouldn't have it
within your you know your own sports
process of like if you don't perform you
don't get to stay with everybody else
but it's it's also super interesting and
I think very cool that people can get
promoted and people can get relegated
based off of performance so Alan as an
investor what appeals to you about the
EPO you have a global audience that's
just very very different than any
American sport I mean you're talking a
billion plus people interact with the
EPL and when you look at any American
sport there's nothing anywhere close to
it now I'm not suggesting that you've
monetized that billion plus
but if you just even for you know a half
a second think about how could I
monetize that situation from a business
perspective you've got an audience
already it's like how do you bring that
capability and that Knowledge from
American Sports into an audience that's
just that much bigger and can you I mean
that that is a challenging question for
a lot of people is can you actually do
something with that and I I honestly our
bet is yes you can
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
the bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
what I have noticed about you know
football in Europe versus kind of
American football and college is almost
very similar that sense of community
that sense of passion everybody coming
together and really kind of gelling for
something a big event and so even though
we're 30 40 minutes outside of
Manchester
the whole Community is a Burnley fan
this is a relatively small town
everybody knows everyone and certainly
they know when an American shows up and
buys the team what does that feel like
for you well you know it's funny because
there's a lockdown and so we haven't
really got to meet a lot of people so so
no one's tried to burn down my house yet
and there's been no pitchforks or
anything
there's no reason to believe ALK will
manage Burnley badly but it's the kind
of Leverage acquisition that can make
fans nervous and has previously resulted
in major fan protests if I were Burnley
fan would be a little bit just a little
bit anxious because you know I thought I
was supposing a club that was earning
100 million a year from being in the
Premier League broadcast income had 40
million pounds in the bank
to the club now has quite quite a high
debt they're still in relegation trouble
this season they could be in renegation
trouble with most seasons and if they
are relegated then obviously their
broadcast income diminishes by 20 times
but only could be relegated and then
never come up again into the Premier
League I mean there's a definite risk
with that
if you're buying a team in the Premier
League the value of that team is very
closely tied to its on-field performance
and and that is just not the case in the
US you're de-risked to a great degree as
a franchise owner in the States because
you know if you have a poor year you'll
get you know top pick of the draft that
gives you
um you know better chances of improving
your subsequent years you have one poor
year in the Premier League and you're
down a division and losing a huge amount
of Revenue teams adapt differently to
relegation but some just go straight
down you know they just can't cope it's
like the whole fiber of the club seems
to collapse
so Alan I've looked at the message
boards and it's fair to say there's some
skepticism out there especially about
the structure of the deal so from a lay
person's perspective walk me through it
the best analogy that I would give as to
what we've done is think about you've
seen a house okay that you really like
but you think it's probably a little bit
of a fixer-upper and you take a mortgage
because it actually makes sense with the
process of what you're doing and then
you can use some of your Capital more
efficiently in actually investing into
the club in different ways or fixing up
the house in different ways yes there's
leverage there's no doubt about it
because we any of any of us that have
ever had a home or that have ever
charged anything on a credit on a credit
card there's leverage in our lives
now if burnley's a fixer-upper this next
Club is one of the most unlikely
recipients of an American makeover
and we're not talking about just any U.S
businessmen here we're talking about
a-listers Ryan Reynolds and Rob
mcelhenney
rexham are what's known as minnows small
fish in a big pond in normal times they
have an average attendance of just 5 000
fans which is actually pretty good for a
team in the fifth division
last season they ranked 111th in the
football pyramid so wrexham is a long
way from that sweet broadcast Revenue if
you start in the bottom you've got an
amazing upside of the possibilities of
promotion ultimately they I think are
looking for a story to be able to tell
Ryan Reynolds and Rob mcelhenney it
looks like they're seeking a vehicle for
a narrative and ideally that narrative
is get the team promoted up the
divisions and that would make for a
pretty compelling Show on Netflix or
Amazon Prime or wherever it might land
that team has not got a huge amount of
Revenue
um only sort of two or three million
pounds a year if you're looking at a
Netflix show which you're selling for
several hundred thousand pounds an hour
and you have an eight hour mini series
all of a sudden you've doubled that
team's Revenue in one Fell Swoop it's a
sort of active management it is very
much bringing special sauce and and
applying it to the asset
this isn't a punt either in recent years
streaming services have been flooded
with sports documentaries
for most teams it's a small part of the
business for wrexum according to a
letter sent to potential sponsors it's a
key part of the commercial pitch along
with the opportunity to get your name on
the shirt the stadium and working
personally with two interested Hollywood
stars
Sports documentaries cost less than top
level games and have a longer shelf life
the biggest problem is whether it makes
compelling television good TV requires
troughs as well as Peaks meaning losses
as well as wins next thing I know Rob
mcelaney gives me a buzz and says I'd
love to pop up to Santa Barbara he like
all of us started to consume massive
amounts of Netflix during lockdown and
stumbled across a documentary series
called Sunderland till I die and he said
I watched this and I was enthralled and
unless with the football action but the
people and the agony and The Angst and
they said I know these people this is
Philadelphia this is every city that has
gone on tough times that has been let
down by the one thing that can lift the
spirits which is their their team as a
result he said I call Ryan and said we
need to buy a football club just like I
had to turn to The Experts to really
understand football to begin with so too
did Ryan and Rob see stars they're just
like us and they had the perfect guy
someone who'd not only run a
championship Club but who'd actually
lived in wrexham wrexham I grew up there
I played football there
um I played for wreck some school boys
played at the racecourse ground where
wrecks and play so when I wasn't playing
I watched wrexham and in those days they
were a very good team uh playing in the
second division of of English football
giant Killers as it's known so the big
clubs would come in the FA Cup to
knockout competition and most famously
beat Arsenal
fast forward to you know as recently as
as a year ago when the club had fallen
into quite frankly disarray had gone
into Administration bankruptcy Nolan
well he's trip there now the situation
for wrexham fans was kind of win-win
they can't fall much further and in
their eyes American ownership probably
means climbing the ladder and maybe even
hitting the big time
what are the goals of the season but
when foreign owners pick up a team in
part to use it as a vehicle for a video
series it gives you a sense of how much
the game has changed football is a very
simple virtuous cycle you make as much
money as you possibly can you invest
that on the pitch those players bring
you victories when you win a lot
sponsors like that and they will give
you more money which you then turn
around and spend on the pitch and you
get even better players who win you
League championships and Champions
League trophies and sponsors want to be
a part of that as well and they give you
even warming so it's a classic virtuous
cycle ultimately what happens in the
best leagues in the world won't have
that much effect on the Grassroots kids
will still go to the park and play and
they'll continue to play for years to
come but the question remains will big
business spoil the beautiful game
in recent months a lot of chatter has
emerged about how the biggest clubs in
the world are trying to consolidate
power and get a bigger slice of the pie
for themselves which raises another
question can English football survive
this Americanization I think if you went
to Wallace almost any football fan
do you like relegation and promotion
they will say yes because it is actually
what brings the thrill to the game when
people talk about football evoking such
passion partly because there's more at
stake for the club you know if you lose
a game you could be out of the top
league for a number of years and and in
the doldrums there's a move to try to
get the top labs in a league which is
always the same members year in year out
it is a way of ensuring that those clubs
retain their value they have predictable
Revenue that will be recurring for the
years to come and because it's at a
European level where they'll be playing
against all the other top clubs uh they
will attract a bigger International fan
base now that might be at the detriment
to the detriment of the normal fan
everyday fan in their home City
for on a simple reason they may not be
able to travel to Munich or Madrid or
Milan every other week it's quite
expensive and so it's something that
investors like but fans on the whole
really don't
the biggest fear of course is that you
lose fairy tales like Leicester city
this is a team that Rose from being in
the third tier of English football to
winning the whole thing in a span of
just seven years at five thousand to one
to win the league That season bookmakers
had never paid out so much but there are
other types of fairy tales maybe still
to be written who knows maybe we'll see
wrexham in the Premier League before too
long
thanks so much for watching would love
to hear what you think about this and
other episodes about the business of
sports I'll be in the comments section
can't wait to hear what you think
[Music]
foreign
World On Demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
access the financial World On Demand
foreign
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
money and power Collide in Silicon
Valley and Beyond this is Bloomberg
technology with Emily Chang
[Music]
Ed
I'm Emily Chang in San Francisco and
this is Bloomberg technology coming up
in the next hour Facebook earnings are
out and The Social Network warrants
growth could slow this year especially
when it comes to revenue user numbers
are in line but investors want more
shares are falling
plus Tim Cook and Elon Musk say the chip
shortage may slow their companies down
over the next few months but it doesn't
seem to be slowing down AMD I'll talk to
AMD CEO Alicia Shu about how the chip
maker is Bucking the trend taking on
Intel and her outlook for when chip
Supply catches up to demand
and The Social Network for professionals
LinkedIn predicts the great reshuffle
with massive changes in the
post-pandemic workforce underway CEO
Ryan roslanski joins us one year into
the job we'll get to all of that but
first let's take a look at the markets
as investors continue to digest these
new CDC guidelines Google postponing its
return to work mandating vaccines for
employees along with Facebook Bloomers
criticupta taking a look at the markets
across the board critty how are
investors responding absolutely Emily
with that background of the virus and
what that means for a lot of
Corporations it puts the spotlight on
the fed and today's trading session was
all about positioning for that
potentially kind of risk-off move and
that's what you saw when it came to tech
stocks the S P 500 closing my flat on
the day but it was really that Tech out
performance you can see in the NASDAQ of
course some of that came of course from
those Mega tech companies thanks to last
night's pretty stellar earnings and of
course positioning ahead of those
Facebook earnings after the Bell today
so you did see some of that going some
of that money I should say going into
Mega Tech but there's also a China story
here we know that in the last couple of
sessions a 20 drop for Chinese stocks on
those regulatory scrutiny concerns until
Emily last night when overnight in Asia
you started to see Chinese officials
reach out to some of these Banks and say
well hold on a second that's scrutiny
that push to move education stocks into
non-profits well that's really only an
education story it's not meant to hinder
kind of the broader Tech Bid And when
we're talking about the broader Tech bit
it's important to keep in mind what's
going on with those sub sectors because
at the end of the day it is one big Tech
trade and you can see that here with the
semiconductors in Orange and then the
biotech index in white trading higher
and trading together Emily that's the
macro picture Ed let's get to the micro
yeah Tech earnings in full swing and
Facebook falling in after hours it beat
on Advertising revenue and profit user
growth pretty flat but it had a warning
for investors that there will be
headwinds ad targeting headwinds
throughout 2021 from Regulatory and
platform changes spoiler alert it's the
Apple iOS change that they're talking
about Qualcomm as well the world's
biggest smartphone chip maker pretty
good quarter relatively good numbers
talking about robust demand for handsets
5G driven a good quarter for them and
similar themes actually in regular trade
on Wednesday look at some of the names
that already reported this week for
example Google robust Rebound in its
advertising business consumers using
search for travel for retail things like
that Apple falling after warning that
growth would slow down after a robust
quarter where 5G drove handset sales
best performing stock on the S P 500 and
the Philadelphia semiconductor index AMD
such good earnings in the quarter and
such a bullish forecast for four-year
sales that once Oscar Hana analyst Emily
said these earnings were quote amazing a
lot of superlatives out there had to
describe amd's quarter thanks so much I
want to stick with AMD the chipmaker as
Ed said giving a bullish third quarter
sales forecast indicating it's gaining
share from Intel in the lucrative market
for Server chips second quarter Revenue
almost doubling to 3.85 billion dollars
an analysts using words like Flawless
Superior amazing as Ed said to describe
the quarter AMD CEO Lisa Sue joins us
now from their offices in Austin Texas
Lisa it doesn't get much better than
that and coming into this quarter there
was a lot of concern about whether the
chip shortage would hold you back and
yet you're posting 99 Revenue growth
here how are you navigating what seems
to be a really tough situation better
than almost anyone else
well hey Emily it's great to be here
with you um you know always I love
spending some time with you guys
um I will say it was a very strong
second quarter for us uh we were excited
with the momentum that we saw you know
we're in an environment where um the
demand is very high for um you know the
products um that we're building and
customers are preferring our product
we've worked hard on the supply chain
there's no question there's a lot of
work to do in the supply chain for
semiconductors and we're happy that we
were able to exceed our second quarter
guidance as well as you know guide up uh
for the rest of the year so you know we
now expect to be up 60 year on year so
it's just you know a very very strong
business environment across our
businesses now AMD is getting stronger
at a time when some say demand is going
to start to Peter out what's your take
on how much fundamental demand there is
and how long the surge that we've been
seeing really lasts
yeah that's a great question and you
know the way I like to say um Emily is
there's really you know two components I
mean one is just we need more Computing
you know whether you're talking about
um you know the PC market or you're
talking about the data center Market or
the cloud Market I think you need more
Computing and um that's like an
overarching uh principle on top of that
I think you know AMD you know we
currently have just very very
competitive products I think we're
showing you know leadership in a number
of market segments and that means
customers are really demanding our
products and and that's that's great for
overall business so um I would say that
the market continues to be strong and we
continue to believe that the demand
environment is strong and on top of that
uh you know we have a very strong you
know customer preference for our
products so you know we're excited about
that environment and we continue to work
closely with our customers to keep uh
keep tabs on how the demand environment
shapes up you have sounded a bit more
conservative than others on Outlook for
PCs which I know is one of your key
markets I did did talk to Intel CEO Pat
gelsinger last week and he's bullish
what do you see when it comes to PCS
well let me say I think the PC market
has had just a tremendous last you know
four or five quarters I mean 2020 was
very strong for the PC market
um 2021 is very strong for the PC market
and so I think that's good you know
that's all the work from home school
from home now we have returned to office
people are looking for more PCS but we
also see that as we go into the second
half of the year
um you know we do see there are some
constraints in the overall supply chain
so not necessarily of AMD processors but
more uh you know let's call it some of
the other components that you need in
the PC market and so we just want to
make sure that we take that into account
as we forecast for the second half of
the year but you know look we we see
growth as we go into the third quarter
and as we go into the fourth quarter
we're now growing overall 60 percent uh
year on year and that's even with let's
call it um you know perhaps a little bit
of a conservative look at PCS going from
the first half to the second half
um that means a lot of pieces of the
other pieces of our business are growing
our data center is growing our gaming
business is also growing and so that's
the nice thing about having a portfolio
like we do
I was going to go to Data Centers next
investors are really concerned about
this lucrative server chip Market how
much share how much more share you can
grab there how much more room is there
to grow
well the data center Market is our
strategic big bet and well you know
we've talked about that before it's been
a multi-year multi-generational journey
we're excited you know in the earlier
this year we launched our third
generation epic product it's code name
Milan it's just a fantastic product we
saw great adoption here in the second
quarter with a lot of uh you know Cloud
folks you know really adopting Milan
very quickly as we go into the second
half of the year we see Enterprise also
picking up um you know Milan and again
you know the way we look at this is it
is a multi-generational uh journey and
we've made great progress this year with
our overall um you know Data Center
business and we expect it to be a growth
driver for us as we go into 2022 and
Beyond as well and yet we're seeing the
in-house efforts of companies like AWS
ramping up to design their own chips
does that cap what's possible there for
you
you know I really don't think so Emily I
mean I think what you're seeing is that
um you know the entire infrastructure
data center you know Market is realizing
just how important compute is and when I
say that that's compute in the big sense
of compute and so you have a lot of
different applications and a lot of
different workloads but you know we
specialize in processors and you know we
have uh you know thousands of Engineers
that are looking you know um you know
every day at how we continue to push the
envelope on Computing our roadmap is
very exciting you know as I said we just
launched um our third generation
um epic uh you know Milan generation you
know we like Italian cities as our
product code names and so um you know
next year we're launching our Genoa the
Next Generation family of um in five
nanometer and we're gonna go you know we
have a long roadmap beyond that so I
really look at it as an opportunity to
partner uh with the largest data center
customers in the world and ensure that
you know we're actually building a big
big ecosystem to satisfy all of this
compute that is needed you know
throughout the industry
meantime you know your competition is in
part Intel and there is a new ish CEO
there who claims he is fighting for
every single order many of you are
predecessors enjoyed these fleeting
periods of success but then struggled to
keep up with Intel scale
um how do you avoid that fate investors
seem to believe you will but I know that
you're thinking about it
well Emily it's a very competitive
market and we always think of it as a
very competitive market but you know
given that to being the case you know we
believe in playing our game and playing
the long game so our game is about
pushing the envelope on technology
executing generation after generation
making sure our customers trust and love
our products and really adopt our
products across their portfolio we think
that we're doing that well but you know
we're still underrepresented in the
market so we think that there's plenty
of growth room as we um you know exit
2021 and go into 2022 and Beyond and you
can count on the fact that you know at
AMD we're pretty competitive as well so
I think we want to be aggressive and
make sure that we are satisfying um what
the customers need in the go forward
plans all right meantime apple and Tesla
speaking of the broader shortage they're
warning that the chip shortage is
potentially going to slow them down over
the next few months when you and I last
talked you explained that this is a
really diverse Market there are all
different kinds of chips which kinds of
chips do you see rebounding faster than
others and how does that impact various
Industries whether it is mobile phones
or cars
yeah I think it's a a good question
Emily and you know I always like to
start with the context and the context
is that the demand environment is just
very strong you know above what any of
us would have forecasted if you asked us
six or 12 months ago and so the entire
industry has been working on you know
just meeting that very strong demand and
I think we've made good progress so I
think in different parts of you know
different sub segments you may see
different constraints right now there
seem to be some constraints on what's
called components so not necessarily the
main processors but other things like
you know other integrated circuits that
you need and I know that there's
progress being made and it will continue
to get better I think second half of
this year is still you know quite tight
but we're working closely with all of
our supply chain Partners to unlock more
Supply capability and then it'll get
better as we go into 2022 um you know
for sure
meantime the pandemic seems to still be
giving us uncertainty ahead lots of
concerns about the Delta variant Apple
and Google are pushing back the return
to work Google and Facebook are
mandating vaccines for employees we just
saw spike in cases in Texas where you
are how are you thinking about the
return to work given this evolving
situation and what does this mean for
business in general given the tumult
that we've seen and that you have
weathered over the last year
yeah so I would say uh you know first
and foremost and I know this is true for
all of my uh my peers as well our
employees safety is the number one
priority and we've shown the ability to
work in a remote environment and just
you know execute uh phenomenal results
and so I think we know how to do that
um that being the case I'm looking
forward to being able to do more in
person and I think we need to do that
you know very carefully and within all
of the CDC guidelines and the other
guidelines we're of course encouraging
our employees to get um you know
vaccinated as well and um you know I
look at this as a process so we are
navigating it we've navigated it for 15
months um you know we're all looking
forward to uh to a time when this is
less of a concern but right now it's
about employee safety and employee
flexibility all while still executing
you know just a very aggressive roadmap
all right Lisa Sue CEO of AMD thanks so
much for joining us good to have you
here today on the show
meantime Qualcomm out with earnings
delivering also a bullish quarterly
forecast the world's largest smartphone
chip maker being boosted by the growth
of 5G increasing consumer demand for new
devices CEO Cristiano Aman saying the
company is also trying to expand its
reach beyond the phone chip market and
win orders in PCS cars and home
electronics we spoke to him right before
the earnings call and he said he's also
optimistic about the chip crunch
and we expect material Improvement in
Supply by the end of the year and as I
said before we're we're still seeing
more demand within Supply across our
business but things are continued to
improve on the supply side consistent of
what we said and that's reflected in our
guide
coming up Facebook shares plummeting as
the revenue growth will slow
significantly we're going to tell you
why next this is Bloomberg
foreign
[Music]
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
major headwinds under the weight of
Apple's new ad targeting software The
Social Network warning that Revenue
growth will decelerate significantly
this after reporting 29.1 billion
dollars in revenue for the second
quarter with user growth coming in in
line but after massive big Tech beats
investors seem to be wanting more
joining us now Scott Kessler Global head
of Technology at third Bridge Scott got
to talk about the revenue growth
warnings here that it could decelerate
significantly in part due to this new
Apple ad tracking software users just
aren't opting in which is not a surprise
what's your take here
yeah so thanks a lot Emily um I guess a
couple things look idfa from Apple
um it's interesting because the social
media companies that reported results
last week notably indicated that idfa
didn't have a negative impact on results
and they didn't really indicate that
they thought it would
um so to some extent sure this may
influence Facebook but I also think that
Facebook has some difficult comparisons
in the back half of the year uh perhaps
this is just them being reasonable and
conservative in terms of the guidance
they're providing
what's your focus on user growth I mean
obviously Facebook is now this family of
products the Blue app there's Instagram
there's WhatsApp are you at all
concerned that as people return to work
that you know we're spending less time
on our devices we're spending less time
social networking
yeah for sure I think that's going to be
an influence on what goes on uh with
Facebook and frankly the other social
media companies
um we saw seven percent growth in Dau
and Mau look it's significant
acceleration from the 12 we saw from
each of those uh in the year ago period
That's not surprising because of course
we saw so much uptake and engagement
last year when everyone was at home uh
that being said I think this is really
now a story about uh the rate at which
pricing can increase that was probably
the single biggest contributor to
revenue growth in the second quarter and
I'm just not so sure that they're going
to have the favorable comparisons as
well as I'd say kind of the pricing
Tailwinds uh to maintain that momentum
that's why we're seeing the guidance uh
where it is and that's frankly why I
think the street was already below 20
Revenue growth for next year in the out
year as well
we're listening into the earnings call
Mark Zuckerberg talking about AI talking
about new tools they're giving to
creators let's take a quick listen in to
what he's been saying
now people like to watch videos
recommended by our personalized
algorithms so this gives creators a good
way to reach new people who don't follow
them yet and this is also a good
complement to our social feeds and it's
an area where our progress in AI is
going to make the experience a lot
better in the coming months and years
meantime Scotty's been talking up the
metaverse which is this idea that there
is a future internet we will be in
rather than on and you know I wonder if
this is something that Zuckerberg is
chasing because he knows that you know
sort of uh traditional activity on
social platforms isn't necessarily going
to last as technology is saying changing
so quickly around all of us you know how
do you think about that when you think
of the future of Facebook and how big a
threat is it
well look um I think it's fair to say
that the company is looking for other
growth drivers right I mean a big pivot
to e-commerce understandably last year
they've been talking about AI for a long
time I feel like Oculus was acquired
about seven years ago and it's not I
think Unthinkable to suggest that other
social media companies are actually
doing
um AR and VR better than Facebook so
understandably it's a priority I think a
lot of people want to see that in the
product and driving
um operational and maybe Financial
benefits to come
all right well we're going to continue
to follow along with the call Scott
Kessler of third Bridge always good to
have your input here thanks so much for
stopping by
we still have plenty more Tech results
this week Amazon T-Mobile Pinterest all
out with their results Thursday and of
course we're going to bring you all the
details but next she is the PowerHouse
behind hit shows Gray's Anatomy and
Bridgerton after the break we're going
to hear from Hollywood heavyweight
Shonda Rhimes stay tuned this is
Bloomberg
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
that bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
more than 100 protesters gathered
outside Activision Blizzard offices in
Southern California to protest the video
game makers handling of a sexual
harassment lawsuit they were joined
virtually by fans who called for a
boycott of the company's games in
solidarity with employees the lawsuit
filed last week also details a workplace
culture in which women face unequal pay
and retaliation in response to news of
the walkout CEO Bobby kodec sent a
letter to staff calling the company's
recent actions quote tone deaf and
promised Swift action to Stamp Out
harassment
well for nearly two decades Shonda
Rhimes has been one of the most
important entertainers in Hollywood she
made her Mark of course with Gray's
Anatomy a show that is still going
strong after 16 years and the hits keep
coming for Rhymes after she shined a
multi-year deal with Netflix and
Bridgerton became a pandemic
binge-watching favorite peer-to-peer
host David Rubinstein caught up with
Shonda Rhimes to talk about her success
but also the challenges she's faced in
her career
I just found that to be a difficult
question to answer and I say that
because
um I don't know what it feels like to be
a white man so I don't know how people
were treating the white men at the time
I only know how I'd always been treated
and I was you know raised very clearly
by my parents to be a person who did not
look at things as obstacles I looked at
things as Hills to climb and when
anybody treated me in a way that was not
100 respectful I was taught that that
was always their problem and that they
needed to be put in their place and then
I should move forward and so I'm sure
that I experienced a lot of things that
were not probably what other people
experienced I just chose not to be
defeated by them or or even bother some
of them I probably didn't even bother to
notice so today given how prominent you
are in the entertainment world do you
feel discrimination at any point now or
you don't feel any discrimination
um no I mean I'm just there is an ins
there's an insularity that comes with
you know being in a certain position in
Hollywood but that doesn't change the
fact that you know if somebody doesn't
know who you are they still see you as
you know just another person of color
you know person of color the racism in
this country is the racism in this
country
you can watch more of that interview
with Sean Alan CEO Shonda Rimes herself
on the David Rubinstein show at the
following times take a look there
all right up next I'll be speaking with
Ryan roslanski the CEO of LinkedIn as it
tops 10 billion dollars in annual
revenue for the first time his insights
on the future of work and the challenges
leading the company through the pandemic
this is Bloomberg
[Music]
foreign
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
welcome back to Bloomberg technology I'm
Emily Chang in San Francisco one of the
highlights of Microsoft's latest earning
release was LinkedIn which Microsoft
acquired back in 2016. its annual
revenue surpassed 10 billion dollars for
the first time up 27 from the previous
year amidst of course a very tumultuous
year for the workforce joining us now
here in the studio LinkedIn CEO Ryan
rosslanski on your one year anniversary
as the CEO of LinkedIn congratulations
and good to have you you took over as
CEO I guess you'd been working there for
more than a decade but in the middle of
a pandemic when not only were you
dealing with a lot of transition
internally but the entire Workforce the
whole platform was going through a tent
transition what was that like to
navigate yeah I mean if I went back a
year ago by no means did I think that
I'd be starting this role from my
bedroom with my kids doing school work
around the house trying to navigate the
company through a global pandemic so it
was definitely it was challenging it was
a challenge engineer though for everyone
across the world and you know you don't
get to choose to be a CEO only when the
sun is shining you can't be a leader
only when things are good and more than
anything I'm really proud of how our
company came together we're at a place
now where we're over 6 000 people are
getting a job on LinkedIn every day we
help train 42 million people on the
platform last year to navigate the
pandemic resulting in what we just
announced yesterday which is uh for our
first time in history 10 billion dollars
in revenue for the year for the company
which I'm very proud of not too shabby
you're also talking about the great
reshuffle this post-pandemic
change underfoot in the workforce and
I'm curious what the changes are that
you see you say hiring is back above pre
pandemic levels yeah I mean if you take
a step back and by virtue of us being
LinkedIn and seeing professional
conversations happening across the globe
one thing we're seeing by far is that
every company right now every CEO every
leadership team is having to rethink
what their company means how they work
where they work on are they hybrid are
they remote fundamentally they're
rethinking their entire cultures and
their entire values as a company on the
other hand every employee in the world
has worked remotely for the past 18
months is trying to figure out for
themselves not only how they work but
where they work and why they work so
we're seeing this just change and people
understanding what they value in work
and that's pretty what we're calling
this great reshuffle people are trying
to figure out where they want to work
how they want to work moving forward and
I think that over the next 18 months
you're going to see a lot of you know
uncertainty and a lot of confusion going
on but my guess is that over time it all
kind of shuffles out in the right spot
where employees and companies are coming
together where they share their values
and the way that they want to work this
ends up being a very positive thing for
the workforce years out Apple and Google
just push back the return to work Google
and Facebook now matading vaccines for
employees there's a lot of controversy
about how companies are managing the
shift and I wonder if it could also for
some companies if they don't get it
right could it lead to a great Exodus of
talent yeah and like like I said I think
all these decisions that companies are
making and by the way they're not easy
decisions none of us have ever gone
through them before but they're really
related to how we want our companies to
work and our culture and values and
right now employees are able to vote and
with their kind of idea where they want
to work it's very easy to move around
roles right now and they're going to
align with the companies that share
their values now
um
how are you thinking about return to
work I know Microsoft policy and
Linkedin is an independent company but
vaccines for example will you require
that employees have them yeah you know
it's fascinating I just saw Google's
news right before I I came in and you
know the way a lot of this works is
there's so much uncertainty and we you
know we watch other companies are doing
and we all kind of learn along the way
having a growth mindset is the key to to
all of this for us we've been embracing
flexibility is the is the core tenant of
what we care about we rely on our
principles and most importantly rely on
our culture we trust each other to get
our jobs done where it works best for us
and that's kind of key to what we do at
LinkedIn so does that mean you're
thinking about the vaccine issue or I
think we're always open to kind of
better understanding what works best for
us and I I don't know what that means
long term for LinkedIn my guess is we're
all going to keep learning and you know
watching Google's news today my my
thought is that you know the more that
we give employees choice about where
they work things like requiring vaccines
to come into the office as long as
employees have a choice to work from
home that'll probably be an okay thing
longer term when you're requiring
someone to have a vaccine and come into
the office that could be more trickier
for companies now you've been owned by
Microsoft now for five years 10 billion
dollars in Revenue I'll never forget the
morning that I got woken up
in about an hour the the news of the
deal that nobody seemed to see coming
how has being Microsoft being part of
Microsoft changed the company I think
it's been one of the most positive
experiences of the company uh by far you
know when when Microsoft acquired the
company satya's vision and Jeff at the
time you know they kind of sat down and
said this is a deal about growing
LinkedIn period And by being part of the
Microsoft ecosystem how can we help to
grow LinkedIn but keep LinkedIn as an
independent Standalone company you take
a look now five years later I mean
revenues nearly tripled since that
acquisition we're growing faster and
accelerating off a larger base now so I
think that that thesis that they started
with five years ago is really playing
out and for me it's just such a pleasure
and honor to be part of that leadership
team and to watch people like Satya or
Amy hood or Brad Smith I mean best in
the business to learn from and to help
you know move LinkedIn the company
forward you did have some layoffs last
year I saw that was maybe maybe that was
like one of your first memos that you
unfortunately had to write in the Talent
Solutions business because people
weren't hiring right are those kind of
structural changes behind LinkedIn what
is the growth story for the company look
like yeah absolutely I mean LinkedIn is
an 18 year old company and last year
around this time we saw an opportunity
for what we needed to do to move the
company forward and we and we made those
changes right now when you see this
great reshuffle happening when you see
every company and every CEO and every
employee trying to navigate the future
of what work looks like for them they're
all turning to LinkedIn to figure that
out and I think that's a really valuable
place for us to be in terms of people
find the skills they need the roles they
need the opportunities they need to
navigate this so across all our business
lines this further engagement people
coming and turning to LinkedIn is only
lifting all boats across the company and
I know you're historically a product guy
you've been at the company for 12 years
LinkedIn has you know some people have
complained about spam and that the
product isn't as slick as it used to be
how are you thinking about that I think
across our you know 774 million members
have joined LinkedIn we have about three
members that are joining per second
engagement is an all-time high people
are connecting more than ever they're
learning skills more than ever they're
finding opportunities more than ever and
it's you know our job as a product
organization as a company to just keep
ensuring that we can connect that Talent
opportunity as much as we can through
the product we're also seeing you know
out of our membership 125 million
members now are our first line workers
it's the segment that's growing 35 of
all signups right now are first line
workers and they're more engaged than
even the knowledge workers so we're
starting to expand even beyond our core
uh globally right and Linkedin had made
some progress in China which was one
mark one pla One Market where where we
thought that maybe a U.S tech company
would succeed what are you actually
seeing there now given the the Crackdown
and you know challenges for company
Chinese companies yeah that they're
having I mean I think just taking a step
back in general one of the things that
I've learned in this role are the number
of constituents that you have to manage
as a CEO and more and more governments
are becoming an important constituent to
work with be it how we work to create
Economic Opportunity in China uh last
week I actually sat down for lunch with
Spanish prime minister Pedro Sanchez I
know you talked to him as well they came
to us trying to you know figure out how
to help you know grow technology in
Spain turning to LinkedIn for uh help
with skills data and opportunity data
met uh two weeks ago with uh former
secretary John Kerry who's now the
special Envoy to President Biden on
climate that fundamentally climate
change is is going to be about a human
capital problem to help ensure that
people have the skills they need for
companies to move forward so working
with governments is becoming much more
part of the job than it ever has and I
think that's okay because they all share
Broad and prosperity and turning to
LinkedIn to help them can you work with
China
we have and we will continue to yes so
what does the jobs picture look like
then next year this time a lot of
uncertainty ahead but a year from now
what do you see
you know my guess is that we'll continue
to see uh for probably 18 months uh the
idea of companies really trying to
understand what their culture and values
are what companies mean for them what
their business model looked like moving
forward at the same time employees
trying to understand what they value
we'll see a lot of reshuffling we'll
continue to see hiring at large Pace But
ultimately my guess is that this all
settles down into the right place
probably 18 months from now right
LinkedIn CEO Ryan roslinski
congratulations on your one year
anniversary appreciate you stopping by
and coming here in the studio in person
hopefully we get to do this more thank
you
all right meantime Spotify added fewer
users than expected this quarter the
audio streaming giant blaming the
pandemic for its second straight quarter
of sluggish growth shares down almost 25
percent so far this year so why aren't
as many people signing up Bloomberg's
Lucas Shaw joins us now to discuss Lucas
What's Happening Here
you know there were two factors that
Spotify blamed one was the the ongoing
pandemic especially in the countries
that it called sort of the rest of world
that's not the U.S or Western Europe
it's especially in Africa and Asia
places that are still newer for Spotify
so for example in India where the
pandemic has obviously been pretty
brutal Spotify delayed or postponed a
marketing campaign that it thought would
have been helpful in signing some
customers up it also talked about sort
of some fluky thing that happened with a
third-party distributor where people who
had problems signing up for Spotify the
company didn't specify what that third
party was but it said it did impact
growth kind of strange in the quarter
because spotify's new subscriber growth
in terms of actual paying customers was
quite good it just didn't sign up as
many of those free customers in some of
those newer markets
what does this mean for the broader you
know whether it's Apple music or you
know some of the other competitors in
this space that had seen you know such
epic if you will pandemic growth
you know I think long term it still
feels like Spotify Is On Solid Ground I
mean it's going to hit 400 million users
by the end of this year the amount of
time that people are spending listening
to music and podcasting on the service
continues to go up but we are in this
sort of weird moment I think with a lot
of subscription Media Services and and
Media Services in general where the
growth is a little lumpier than it has
been they got used to very consistent
strong growth and whether you're looking
at Netflix or you're looking at a
Spotify some of the growth they're
posting right now is not quite the same
and I I'm not actually not sure how much
we're supposed to extrapolate from that
is this a sign that a service that
already has so many customers like
Spotify is starting to slow down and
entering a new phase or is it a sign
that they really did just add a lot of
customers last year and so it's going to
be a little bit slower I'm not sure and
frankly I'm not sure the executives at
Spotify know either
so what's next what are you following
you know they're going to keep investing
in podcasting in a new markets for the
most part you know they have yet to hire
a new head of their podcasting Studios
the company it's been a position that's
now been open for a couple of months
that they're looking to fill uh they're
going to use those to develop more and
more original podcasts which they hope
will boost the ad business one of the
few bright spots in the quarter was that
their ad business has grown more than
100 year over year and they're going to
hope that not only by creating new
podcasts in the US or licensing new
podcasts like call her daddy but they'll
also do that abroad and use that to
facilitate growth whether it's in India
southeast Asia you know Spotify has a
pretty diverse out of user base right
now but they'd like in particular to
boost the number of subscribers in
places that aren't the us or Western
Europe
all right Lucas show for us in La thanks
so much Lucas for your Insight there
all right coming up in our city lab
segment I'm going to talk to the founder
and CEO of carbon Health his Insight on
the Delta variant vaccine distribution
and how to provide Affordable Health
Care in the United States when we need
it most that is next this is Bloomberg
[Music]
access the financial World On Demand
foreign hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
foreign hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
the bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
it's certainly not the direction that we
want to be going it it's it's very
simple what needs to be done which is
every American needs to be vaccinated
this is now a disease of the
unvaccinated
Commerce Secretary Gina raimondo there
speaking on Bloomberg earlier her
sentiments shared by Tech Giant Google
the search engine giant announcing that
all returning workers must be vaccinated
Facebook doing that as well Google has
also delayed its return to the office
the ocean darpachai telling staff in an
email because of the rise in Delta
variant cases employees will now return
starting mid-october instead of
September meantime apple is expected to
reinstate a mask requirement at most of
its U.S retail stores for both customers
and staff even for those who are
vaccinated although the iPhone maker
isn't making it mandatory for retail
staff to be vaccinated it is strongly
urging them to do so
and the pandemic of course has been a
test of a lifetime for doctors nurses
and other medical professionals on the
front lines joining us now for today's
City lab segment is Aaron Bali founder
and CEO of carbon Health which has 80
medical clinics in 12 States across the
United States in an interesting view
into coven
um so Erin thank you so much for joining
us great to have you back on the show
talk to us about what trends you're
seeing when it comes to testing when it
comes to vaccines as we confront this
really dangerous and scary Delta variant
so thank you for having me Emily
unfortunately we are seeing
um very high quid positive the rates
after uh after a time frame where it was
feeling like we had control that awesome
with Delta variants
um
um but the overall positive rate is high
but what they are seeing is among the
vaccinated adults uh there are some
breakthrough cases but fairly small
compared to the rest of the compared to
the rest of the population
um and I think with the we also are
seeing a lot uh less severe symptoms
among them so I think the I would still
echo the same same guidance let's let's
get as many people as possible
vaccinated and carbon Health has been in
both in the front lines of the pandemic
we have finished 1.5 million vaccines
vaccine Administration and and we are
hoping that the remaining population
will also see the need for do the same
are you seeing anything specifically
regarding the latest surge I mean do you
see vaccines slowing down do you see
tests positive test results clicking up
so the positive test test results are
really uh just growing very fast right
now
um and actually one of the uh the
patterns you are seeing is uh Delta
variant like it becomes transmitted a
lot faster so which means even if you
have some antibodies uh people are still
like showing positive positive tests uh
but again if they're vaccinated we are
now seeing a lot of kind of concerning
symptoms among them
now you grew up in a small village in
turkey and I know that your upbringing
is in part what inspired the vision to
start carbon health and make Health Care
More accessible what is the vision and
how close are you to getting to where
you want to be
so our vision our mission has always
been making
um like high quality Healthcare
accessible to everyone when I came to
this country as an immigrant
I was pleasantly surprised with how good
the healthcare experience was
but only for the high income people only
for developing and you'll if you look at
the healthcare experience of an average
American it is actually it's arguable
worse than a lot of even developing
countries like turkeys um and we and I
think I thought the technology companies
were not doing enough to really help
average average Americans Healthcare
problems and we started carbon Health on
the first day with an obsession to
making care better better for average
Americans and what we have achieved is
we now have have the sort of experience
that someone who's on top one percent is
still considering as a really high
quality to Consumer experience but that
in a way it is accessible to people
living paycheck to paycheck so the main
goal of the company is growing the
becoming the first Nationwide primary
care provider we have recently closed
350 billion dollars in financing yes you
guys uh first I think I shared uh she
will just grow that and the other thing
we working on as
doubling down on this concept that we
call omnichannel Healthcare
we have had clinics we have had
telemedicine providers we have had
consumer devices and more but nobody has
really integrated these different
modalities innovated to truly reduces
patient friction that is the core
product Regional Covenant that we've
been investing in all right and you just
raised another 350 million dollars to
help build that Vision out Aaron Bali
carbon Health founder and CEO thanks so
much for joining us
coming up the company behind the app
that fueled the meme stock frenzy gets
set for its trading debut we're gonna
have all the details on Robin Hood
hitting the public markets next this is
Bloomberg
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
trading at Robinhood set to make its own
trading debut on Thursday sources
telling Bloomberg that the company is
seeing demand from investors to buy
stock in the IPO within the marketed
range at this point that's 38 to 42
dollars per share the company not
planning to price the offering above
that at this point we've got a lot to
unpack with the story joining us now
Bloomberg's Katie roof who's been
working to try to get the scoop uh what
exactly do we know at this point so at
this moment in time Robin Hood has a
meeting at to decide what the price is
going to be the bankers and the board
and the lawyers are all discussing as we
speak what it should price at the latest
we've heard is that it will be probably
within the proposed range of 38 to 42
dollars but not above the range you know
sometimes when there's a lot of
excitement around a particular stock
they'll go above range but so far we're
hearing it's within the range and this
would give Robin Hood at the top of the
range what like a 35 billion dollar
market cap yeah so up to 35 billion if
it goes to the top of the range of
course if it's the bottom it could be a
few billion dollars lower uh so they're
deciding that right now of course
they're also trying to factor in a pop
usually that's what uh people want on
the first day of trading is for their to
be a pop to show some excitement for
from Wall Street so we'll see what
happens with that but certainly you know
right now
um they're figuring out the the formula
one thing that some people were
disappointed about was that they didn't
do a new Range sometimes you'll see this
with
um IPOs especially the big IPOs they'll
do a range and then if the Roadshow goes
well they'll issue a new filing an
updated range and Robinhood didn't do
that and and they're not pricing above
range either so probably not the best
sign for how the road show went now I'm
wondering how investors are feeling
about Robinhood in general
um given that you know obviously they
set aside a huge chunk for their our own
users there could be a lot of retail
interest and you wonder if Robin Hood
could become the target of its own
customer base For Better or For Worse
sure yeah so there's a lot of mixed
sentiment amongst its own customer base
obviously Robin has has a lot of traders
who have helped fuel a lot of this
excitement in in tech stocks and meme
stocks in the past year but a lot of
them kind of turned on Robin Hood after
the GameStop frenzy where Robin Hood
controversially like suspended trading
for a little bit on GameStop and so some
of them you know whenever I do a story
there's people that will tweet at me I
can't wait to short Robin Hood so
obviously there are some people that are
pretty angry still about how this went
but then there are people who look at
Robin Hood's financials which showed
strong Revenue growth in spite of all
this negativity and they say you know
why I'm excited about Robin Hood and I
believe in this company so definitely
mixed sentiment is what we're hearing
and they do have demand within the range
right and a lot of the people who are
complaining are still using Robinhood
because it is such a simple product I
know some people think it is too simple
but in reality is people are using it
exactly and if anything a lot of this
negativity probably drove some attention
to Robin Hood and informed a lot of the
world about Robin Hood which is an app
that's easy to use and you can trade for
free certainly there are some
controversies in the way in which they
make their money and that they you know
the payment for order flow and so some
people feel like that's not necessarily
a fair practice and that maybe there
will be some regulatory concerns there
but for now they've been showing really
strong user growth and revenue growth in
spite of all these controversies okay
all right well we're waiting for that
pricing we'll be following your coverage
tomorrow thank you so much for joining
us we'll of course be all over the Robin
Hood IPO as well Bloomberg's Katie roof
there and that does it for this edition
of Bloomberg technology we've got
another bumper show tomorrow T-Mobile
CEO Mike Seaver will be here pack few
president Melissa Burdick talking about
Amazon's results and Cisco Executive
Vice President Fran katsudas joining us
right here on B Tech I'm Chang in San
Francisco this is Bloomberg
[Music]
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
foreign hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
tougher than any man-made material It's
a combination of strength and elasticity
no other material can actually combine
these two features either material
strong or it's elastic and spider silk
is both
five times stronger than steel spider
silk has been tantalizing the human
imagination for decades you want to be
Spider-Man you have to make fibers
can't just Farm the silk because spiders
eat each other the scientists have
pursued other routes a DNA sequencing
breakthrough in Germany means
manufacturing spider silk fiber is no
longer Pure Fantasy the next step is
really producing tons of the material
and all the offices we have spiders and
you know they're like pets we like to
have them around we think they're
beautiful
if eight-legged co-workers make your
skin crawl then the biomaterials lab at
biote University probably isn't for you
[Music]
it's here that Professor Thomas scheibel
and his team study natural substances
like spider silk in the hope of turning
them into Super materials spider still
cares for a lot of Material Science it's
been the holy grail for decades if we
take a thumb thick spider fiber we could
actually get a jumbo chat holding up in
air without tearing it apart it can
withstand hundreds of tons of load in
Full Speed without breaking the best
soap producers or odd weaving spiders
they have seven different types of silk
with different properties we find
dramatic differences there concerning
mechanics but also concerning other
properties
wanting to harness these characteristics
led to scheibel's breakthrough in
genetically modifying bacteria to
produce spider silk proteins this
patented technology formed the basis of
am silk the company schaible founded
with a postdoc from his research lab
Lynn Roma the bacteria we are using as
working hours are very simple organisms
they only try to grow and we exploit
that we we feeding them we give them
perfect conditions to live and they
multiply and multiply and afterwards we
changed their way of living we give a
trigger so that they stop proliferating
and they start producing our protein
after purification we have protein in
form of a white powder
am silk takes the protein powder and
Spins it into a fiber
so what you can see here is our spinning
machine very produce our biosity fiber
which is then transferred to the yarner
who can make the yarn and then later the
fabric out of the material
is a vegan and biodegradable synthetic
biopolymer
rather than use the biostill material in
their own product amsilk wants to
produce it for established Brands who
have expertise Adidas used it to create
a concept shoe and Omega made a special
edition watch strap Airbus are also
exploring how it can be used in aviation
they know their product we develop
together with them the product has a
much higher quality in comparison to
what we could do on our own
the company has raised millions in
Venture Capital but producing enough of
the material is the biggest challenge
yes it's very thin you need a lot of the
fiber in a normal sport shoe there are
more than 170 kilometers of this fiber
processed into the yarn and later the
fabric of the shoe
[Music]
the company says it has made hundreds of
thousands kilometers of fiber so far but
scaling it up further will take time and
money
but like the all weaving spider which
uses different silks for different parts
of the web am silk is putting the spider
silk proteins to use elsewhere
in the beginning we had this great
Innovation we had thousands of
opportunities how to use that for
industry and this was a beautiful
problem
you can use it for different
applications
everyone had the experience when he goes
to the basement that there might be a
spider's web and if it's an old house it
might be there for hundreds of years and
it's not degraded so the question is why
microbes have big problems sticking to
the web if you lost in the woods get a
web you can use it as a wound coverage
device you can wrap your food you can
actually prevent your food from rotting
for a few days
material is a proteinaceous material we
are all made out of proteins and our
body responds very good to the protein
and that's very suitable for a lot of
medical devices we probably have more
than 80 different variants of silt
molecules that we can play with some of
them are very well suited for tissue
regeneration some of them are absolutely
opposite we really just at the beginning
into understanding how this material has
evolved to actually feature different
kind of applications and that's exactly
what we want
am silk is building up production
facilities to make its material at Mass
scale it's hoping to capitalize on the
product's broad potential and take a
lead in an industry harnessing the best
attributes of natural substances
we are living in a time where materials
made from proteins will become more
important every day
[Music]
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
if you take a look at concrete
structures like breakwaters or sea walls
the water around them is often clear
that's not actually a good thing because
it means there's no life
marine species are actually most
abundant in coastal areas but it's also
where us humans prefer to live too
so when we build here we drive away
marine life
the concrete in the Marine World has a
lot of additives a lot of chemicals and
some of those materials are actually
leaching out and they're actually
prohibiting marine life to thrive
we keep developing without any regards
to Natural communities there is a
tilting point for me to be honest we
cannot really go back
in the coastal city of Tel Aviv an
Israeli startup wants to revolutionize
our Urban coastlines
their sea defense is a transforming
lifeless man-made structures into
teeming ecosystems they do this by
replacing Standard Concrete with their
own special cement formulas as opposed
to regular cement based concrete
e-concrete includes certain elements
that enhance the growth of marine flora
and fauna plants and animals
our admix which is kind of our secret
sauce is basically kind of sealing the
concrete making it less aggressive for
the marine environment that once we add
it we enable life to flourish in the lab
the team run tests to identify what
mixes will work best for marine life so
we take really Ice Cube size concrete
slabs of different compositions
larvae 20 30 50 we need to have a lot of
replicates we're geeky scientists so we
have to have a lot of replication and
controls and then within a few days or
just a few weeks we can get an answer on
their preference so obviously if they
die they have a very low tolerance to
that specific concrete mix design and if
they Thrive or they flourish we can
quantify that very quickly
e-concrete says it typically sees double
the biodiversity of regular gray
concrete
from fish and sea caterpillars on their
armor blocks to crabs on these tidal
pools that sit on the shoreline
before it has a very comfortable habitat
for crabs and sea anemones and sea stars
Etc these pools have been here for less
than three months and this is already
what you can see it's covered with life
see the rock around it which has been
here for probably 10 20 maybe even more
years only has a thin layer of green
algae and that's it
as well as the composition of the cement
mix e-concrete designs its products
specifically to the marine environment
it will be deployed
create niches for endangered species or
to develop nurseries like these oyster
beds
the final part of the equation is
creating complex surface textures to
mimic natural rock or Coral an
environment that helps anchor young
organisms when concrete elements are
being cast a typical goal is to have a
very slick surface very very smooth the
idea is to get the water to flow right
across it when we're designing
e-concrete with a rough surface we want
to do the complete opposite we want to
slow the water when they are crossing
the structure so that the larvae can
actually adhere and attach to the
surface
the concrete has to offer its clients
more than just ecological credentials
over time they've discovered that
creating hospitable habitats for marine
life adds another Advantage one that is
surely hard to ignore we've seen
evidence to the fact that the growth of
the organisms on the concrete create
kind of a layer of Defense
just the addition of weight we can
actually gain stability and strength
over time
this is the let's say the the unit when
we put in the water and this is after a
year in the water and what you can see
here is all the oysters are completely
covering it we designed the units so
they can withstand the forces and
perform in terms of structural
performance but they can also be a
backbone for uh ecological enhancements
the company tests its miniature designs
in tanks full of real sea water rocks
plants and animal life from around the
world what we're looking for is the
accumulation of cosmic carbonate on the
surface of the concrete of different
mixes and different designs this is the
process we call it biogenic buildup so
with time we're going to build up of
calcium carbonate that is sourced from
marine organisms on the surface of the
concrete and we actually encapsulate the
concrete with a natural rock so when the
organisms die in case of a coral it will
die and then another core will sit on it
and that's how a reef is growing
foreign
structures could become stronger over
time also means better economics
the units require less maintenance and
could therefore stay in the water for
longer
e-concrete though is just a few years
old so it needs more time to really
quantify the longevity of its products
the company are certain their products
are better for the environment and not
just in terms of improving biodiversity
or kind of trying to offset some of that
immense carbon footprint of the concrete
industry construction is responsible for
about 11 of global carbon emissions by
adding a biological crust to their
products e-concrete prevents some CO2
from being released into the atmosphere
for every kilogram of the Carlton
carbonate being created by those marine
organisms we're offsetting 120 grams of
CO2 so think about building a poor
infrastructure or a City Waterfront that
is an active carbon sink I think that's
a great advantage of the technology
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
foreign
[Music]
we have a constantly growing population
this means that we will need 50 to 70
percent more food by 2050. so where are
we going to find 50 to 70 percent more
food in only 30 years
nature is already building and
sustaining all life on Earth we don't
have to reinvent the wheel the calories
we need and we eat and we uptake from
food comes from the sand
oh
the starting point for all food on Earth
is photosynthesis
sunlight combines with carbon dioxide
and water in plants and forms oxygen and
glucose
this sugar is stored in fruits roots and
vegetables
one startup in London thinks harnessing
photosynthesis in microscopic plants
could go some way to solving our
planet's imminent food crisis
we have to start with a microalgae
stream
they are the fastest growing
photosynthesizing organism on this
planet this very tiny microscopic plants
contain hundreds and hundreds of very
precious healthy food molecules that can
be extracted and utilized in our own
food
microalgaes aren't on many menus yet but
they might be the new superfoods packed
full of vitamins antioxidants and
minerals they sustain trillions of
animals on our planet
arboria claims its technology the bio
solar Leaf helps grow this food at rates
rarely seen in nature arborist by solar
leaf looks like similar to a solar panel
it's a technology that can produce and
can grow
hundreds of different microscopic plants
to produce hundreds of different
ingredients it enables to grow them very
quickly but also in a very efficient way
therefore consuming very little amount
of energy we can produce a lot of
protein in a very small surface area so
imagine that we can produce more protein
for a defined surface area than any
other plant-based or animal-based Source
on this planet by orders of magnitude
we Harvest some of this liquid we
separate the liquid from the microalgae
and then we dry it and usually it's
either in a flake form or in a powder
form ready to be shipped to food
producers so that they can utilize them
in all sorts of food products that they
want
arboria imagines their food
but as a supplement all being sold on
its own in stores
there are hundreds of thousands of
species of microalgae all with different
qualities flavors and even colors
something that could be interesting to
food producers
what we can do with these ingredients
that we extract from from this
microalgae is that we can utilize them
for all sorts of processed food it's not
only replacing a synthetic or
unsustainable food ingredients but it's
also adding health benefits active
health benefits to our processed food
let's say that we have arborius big blue
together with a yogurt This Yogurt might
contain more antioxidants that you find
in an apple originally blue was
associated with something synthetic
something unhealthy right maybe blue is
going to become the new color associated
with health why not
arbory's powdered food might not look
all that appetizing but their intention
is substance over Style
feeding our growing population with the
right things in a better way might
improve our chances of future food
security
[Music]
I strongly believe that if we as human
can harness photosynthesis then we have
high chances to help solve the issues
that we are facing today and that we
will face in the future
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
at bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
is an issue that is happening in more
than 99 percent of Earth's inhabitants
intensity of LEDs is so high so it has
increased lighting pollution
we need to find alternative solutions
that are both more respectful from the
environment and also offer a new energy
sobriety
[Music]
we use a reaction called bioluminescence
which is the ability that have a lot of
organisms in nature to produce light
like fireflies or glowworms but also 80
percent of marine organisms
so we use this chemical reaction to
produce a biological source of light
I was fascinated by the fact that it's
so simple it exists in nature it works
pretty well so why not just translate
that into a product
in the sea is something that is very
common it's not extraordinary and so you
have to understand that if it's common
it means that it's efficient and behind
us we have 3.8 billion years of research
development through evolution in nature
to really find this efficient Solutions
like bioluminescence
so the first goal behind glory is really
to use a growing and unlimitedly growing
raw material to replace the sliding
systems
our job today is to identify the best
bacteria that are able to produce the
best bioluminescence
once we have them we work with them in
Labs we engineer them to make them more
efficient in terms of intensity in terms
of stability over time in terms of
temperature resilience and when we have
that we can grow those bacteria mix them
with a nutritive medium and then find
the best conditions for them to grow
the type of water is in one first
variable the temperature is also
important the way we feed them is very
important
the reaction of biomasses needs oxygen
to produce light when you switch on the
oxygen again then the light switch on
the overall goal of playing with the
different settings is first improving
intensity second in improving stability
over time to make the bacteria light as
long as possible to make them be fed as
less as possible to really improve in
terms of cost efficiency
our goal is to go Outdoors so we need
bacteria to resist at less than 50
degrees more than 30 degrees to cover
the more geographies possible
once we have all the recipes we can put
this raw material into different shapes
to make Lighting systems happen
[Music]
today we don't really face nature in our
daily lives as Citizens living in cities
and this connection that human have to
Nature is just essential for the
well-being we figure out that this light
it is very hypnotic it's very soothing
and so it really brings well-being
feeling so we've designed the glossing
room which is a biophilic experience of
bioluminescence
foreign
the goal is to really fully relax to
reconnect to Nature
so when you look at the self light you
can look at it without getting your eyes
tired which is something that is very
unique because it never happens with
electrical lighting
as you're in darkness and your eyes get
used to Darkness progressively then your
brain focuses on little details that you
see and those little details are very
simple things flowers leaves a tree
when you brain think about all these
simple things that you just don't think
about what you forgot to do yesterday
using a biological material to produce
light change all the value chain of
flighting from producing it because we
can grow light to using it because it's
not a bulb an object like a bell but you
can really play with the raw material it
can take a lot of shapes
[Music]
it can also really change the way
Building looks like the way silence
looks like to really give more design
possibilities to it
so we're going to start by you've been
Furniture signage but the more the time
is going the more we think that we can
really rethink the whole way we light
our cities so they tomorrow maybe
there's been Olympus but just different
ways of lighting the areas because it's
going to be more pedestrian because it's
going to be less cars
the interesting thing is that light
won't be like a One-Shot use
when there is a problem or no more
bacteria or no more light you can just
restart a little culture of bacteria and
then few hours later you will have the
system working again
in the societies where we live in we
cannot just switch off all the lights
it can be used to illuminate for
security purposes to enhance something
to give visibility
we need to find the best energy sources
at the best place so that we create this
mix of energy to really have positive
effects it's really interesting in terms
of how to think the cities of tomorrow
[Music]
foreign
to plastic is catastrophic
remnants of our products have spread to
every corner of the planet
the properties that make plastic so
useful cheap malleable durable also make
it damaging plastic can't degrade so the
more we make the more ends up in our
environment
what goes into your recycling bin at
home more than 80 is actually being
landfilled or incinerated
pollutes the water we drink and the food
we eat it suffocates Wildlife I don't
think anybody anticipated the real
problems that Plastics were causing
but Innovative companies around the
world are working towards a solution
[Music]
plastic waste is a global problem
but it's especially bad in certain parts
of Asia plastic waste issue in Thailand
is quite bad we use a lot of plastic bag
and plastic container you just use a
single juice plastic because it's more
convenient
Thailand is one of five Asian countries
that combined contribute more than the
rest of the world to the plastic waste
in our oceans these countries are
experiencing rapid economic growth with
that comes the benefit of growing
consumption but also the increasing use
of plastic especially single-use
Plastics like shopping bags straws and
food packaging which are often tossed
away just minutes after buying
but one of these sorts of products
didn't have to be made from plastic at
all
for anything that you only use for one
time biodegradable material could be a
better choice
we are producing biodegradable packaging
our packaging are made out of cassava
starch and the natural fiber together
it takes 6 to 12 months to decompose
depending on the environment
[Music]
thank you the cassava crop plays a major
role in the entire economy it's not a
staple food crop but it's produced in
vast amounts for animal feed and making
things like starch
Asawa is very easy to grow you can grow
all year round and in a lot of area in
Thailand
my product can tolerate the temperature
from -20 to 100 degree so with the hot
food or with the boiling water we still
can contain that in our packaging our
material can work as an insulation it
keeps the temperature of the food warmer
longer than the other material
the company Universal bio pack say they
make around a hundred thousand items a
month mainly for hotels and restaurants
with environmental concerns compared to
plastic their products aren't as
malleable or durable and are at least
twice as expensive but using packaging
like this could reduce the amount of
single-use plastics we consume so either
these kinds of solutions will have to
become cheaper to compete with plastic
or consumers will have to make a
difficult choice
now our products are more expensive but
it definitely is better for the
environment people will have to think
differently right now if you pay for the
plastic you pay for only the cost of
making the plastic you don't pay for the
cost of making the plastic go away
because the plastic stay like 450 years
[Music]
foreign
on the other side of the world a company
is working on just that
we need to find alternatives to burying
our waste into the Earth
plastic energy takes waste plastic that
can't be recycled today
and converts it into usable oils
one of the biggest problems with
plastics is how many different kinds
there are the majority of it can't
actually be recycled the many products
use a mix of materials which makes it
even harder to recycle
it means most of what we think is
recyclable ends up in the ground mixed
Plastics is a is a real problem
plastic energy is targeting these
problematic Plastics using technology
called thermal anaerobic conversion
the company heats the plastic to 400
degrees Celsius in a system without
oxygen
plastic waste breaks down into an oil
similar to petroleum extracted from the
Earth
for every ton of plastic that we've
processed we produce around 700 liters
of oil
by converting plastic into a base oil
plastic energy is creating a virgin
substance that can be used in many more
products
some of those oils can be used to make
plastic again or can be used to make
commodity fuels but we can keep moving
plastic waste into our facility through
our process using our technology to
produce the oils to produce Plastics
again and that's a continuous process it
doesn't have that finite life
it's this IP that has helped the company
give waste plastic value
it has agreements to build sites in Asia
and by building modular plants they can
attach to petrochemical companies who
can use the oil they made from waste
while this process doesn't eradicate
plastic it could go a long way in
reducing the amount that ends up in
landfill or floating out to sea that
material has value and if it's dealt
within the right way the material that
it goes into the bin can actually arrive
back on a shelf wrapping in your local
produce
this circular economy could prevent more
being made from fossil fuels in the
first place
companies like plastic energy and ubp
have different ideas about how to tackle
the plastic crisis but what they share
is a vision of the world where our
throwaway culture is buried for good
one thing is how we use the plastic or
how we can recycle eco-friendly material
could be another choice but I think to
overcome the plastic waste problem we
have to do both sides at the same time
we don't have to make materials just
from raw materials or materials
extracted from the ground we can
really have a circular process across
the board not just Plastics but for all
types of materials
access the financial World On Demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a living fossil that has called
Earth its home for almost half a billion
years
it's outlived dinosaurs and survived
mass extinctions and ice ages but today
it's facing a new threat their
adaptations have worked with the way the
Earth has changed and it's only in
recent years with the with humans
bringing impacts to their population
that they've started to have declines
rising sea levels habitat loss and over
harvesting all threaten the population
but if you've ever had a vaccine
injection or a medical implant then you
might not know that you've been relying
on this prehistoric creature's blood to
save your life
now after Decades of waiting a new
synthetic solution could change all of
it
here on our beaches on the Delaware Bay
it is a place that people are witnessing
a phenomena that they cannot see
anywhere else it's the equivalent of the
wildebeest crossing the Serengeti
in May and June here on on the Delaware
Bay where we are right now millions of
crabs come out on a high tide lay their
eggs about six inches deep in the sand
and they will stay in the sand and hatch
in about a month and horseshoe crab eggs
are a really critical part of the
ecosystem here if a single crab is
laying almost 100 000 eggs that is
providing a food source for Shorebirds
for gulls for fish for Terrapins and
then all up the food chain for that and
then what happens with the horseshoe
crabs then trickles down to the whole
ecosystem here
they just have managed to evolve with
the changing oceans and the changing
land
the reason this crab has been able to
evolve for so long
it's blue blood
this copper-based Blood contains special
cells called amoebasites which are
extremely sensitive to endotoxins these
are contaminants released from the cell
walls of harmful bacteria and they can
cause life-threatening fever or toxic
shock
as soon as the amoebasites detect any of
these endotoxins the blood clots around
the Intruder immobilizing it and
protecting the crab from infection
in the 1960s scientists found a way to
harness this unique superpower to make
sure our medical supplies were free from
contamination and it replaced slower
more unpredictable tests involving
rabbits
the formula is called Limitless amoeba
site lysine or Lal
and relies on amoeba sites taken from
horseshoe crab blood
and so every year half a million crabs
were collected along the Atlantic coast
as well as across the Eastern shores of
Mexico and China
a third of the crab's blood is drawn
before the release back into the ocean
it's estimated that 15 percent of crabs
collected dye as a result of this
bleeding process which could mean a loss
of 75 000 crabs in the U.S every year
foreign
was found however almost 20 years ago
here in Singapore
in the past say 20 30 years ago we
managed to collect 30 pieces in one
afternoon
but now
it is difficult to find even a few
in the mid-1980s professor ding Jack
Ling needed Lal for work involving IVF
embryos but there was a problem
Singapore research was not very well
funded so because the LEL was so
expensive we had to find
a good way to understand how the
hardship blood works
so my research collaborator also my
husband
together with our research students went
to the crunchy mud flats to look for
hustle crabs and to bring a few samples
back to the lab
we cleaned them we tagged them and we
took only a small volume of the blood
isolating the blood cells from the hushu
crab and we could produce our own
equivalent of Lal this synthetic
equivalent is called recombinant factor
C and it's a clone of the main Gene in a
horseshoe crab's blood which is
sensitive to bacterial endotoxins
it was a moment of
realization that it's going to change
the biomedical industry and it's going
to save
a very very highly threatened species
[Music]
but pharmaceutical companies didn't come
around as quickly as professor ding had
hoped and so years and then decades
passed
we're a highly regulated industry and to
say we would like to Market a new
medicine a lot of people are reluctant
to take a chance on on trying something
new that's until a scientist at
pharmaceutical company Eli Lilly with a
particular hobby came along birding is a
hobby of mine so to go to Delaware Bay
and see the horseshoe crab spawning
um
it kind of put it all together for me so
the the horseshoe crab is a keystone
species in its ecology obviously for its
own sake but then for a lot of other
animals that depend on it
if we use RFC
then then there aren't any crabs that
are affected whether it's mortality or
whether there's some behavioral effect
by taking by taking the blood Studies
have shown that the RFC test is a more
effective and a potentially cheaper
solution than Lal changing Minds however
remained the biggest challenge
there's been several times I I was I was
ready to throw in the towel so it's been
uh it's been a difficult Journey
um to fight internally to fight
externally nobody likes change but we
think we're doing it for the right
reasons
um we have had success and we do we have
the data at the end of the day
paid off and in 2018 the first drug to
use the recombinant factor C test was
approved by the FDA and Eli Lilly is
planning to transition 90 percent of its
tests to the synthetic by the end of
2020.
I think the consequence if industry
carries on with bleeding crabs is at
some point there won't be any so there
are real impacts to what we're doing and
and the longer we say oh you know
they'll be available forever it's it's
likely not true
it is important that we as humans are
playing a role in protecting
biodiversity and not impacting
biodiversity the synthetic version of
the horseshoe crab lysate used by
pharmaceutical industry is going to have
a major impact on horseshoe crab
conservation it's not the only factor
that we need we also need to continue
with Harvest limits and with Beach
restoration
but reducing the need to
Harvest crabs for the use of their blood
will have a major impact
[Music]
thank you
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
ecosystems is one of the biggest threats
to our planet
whether through climate change natural
events or human interference we are
losing vital habitats
areas like forests or coral reefs not
only Harbor millions of species but they
provide valuable ecosystem Services
benefits us humans gain from nature
thankfully people across the planet are
working to restore them
in some instances fire is as important
to a forest as water and the Sun
it can release valuable nutrients
clearing space for light stimulating New
Growth but in areas like the American
Northwest increasingly warmer and drier
climates are changing how and if forests
can recover this fire here is a Williams
Flats fire they had about 45 000 Acres
burn and you can just see what the burn
looks like after it goes through and how
there's just nothing left normally you'd
have a low severity fires go through and
the tops of these crowns would have all
kinds of cones ready to open up and drop
seeds because these fires are so large
and massive due to increased
temperatures from climate change there's
just nothing left here
Gran Canary runs drone seed and hopes
the tech startup from Seattle can make a
difference the mission of our company is
to make reforestation scalable for the
purpose of making a dent in carbon
emissions now how do you do that
utilizing drone swarms
[Music]
drone seed surveys the land using 3D
laser scanning technology known as lidar
this gives them a huge number of data
points which they use to build a
detailed map of the area
we run software to then identify the
obstacles off of that 3D terrain map we
actually get a point cloud of about 800
000 points per second most like lidar
and self-driving cars around 200 000
points per second so it's incredibly
dense
we're able to identify these micro sites
where seed vessels will grow really well
[Music]
the software then plans out all of the
missions for the aircraft and so it's
exactly what you expect if you were like
planning out like how to mow your lawn
it's a lawnmower pattern that goes back
and forth in different areas
the operator controls takeoff and
Landing once the Drone is Airborne AI
takes over to fly the predetermined
route
we put about a thousand seed vessels per
acre each one of those has somewhere
between four to six seeds in it a human
planter can do about two acres a day
maybe three drones we're targeting 20 to
40 depending upon the terrain
according to Canary it can take two
years to grow trees in a nursery which
is time these forests just don't have if
these areas are left without having
trees planted immediately after a fire
invasive species quickly move in
changing the landscape and making growth
of trees much harder the big risk is is
this going to transform and turn into
step or Savannah and it's going to come
back as 10 foot tall shrubs
as far as like mitigating the worst
effects of climate change there's really
a handful of things you can do
the best one is planting trees because
they are the most efficient thing you
can do to sequester carbon
just as forests of vital ecosystems on
land show a coral reefs in the ocean
they're home to a quarter of all marine
life despite making up less than 0.1
percent of the ocean they protect land
from storms and waves and provide
valuable resources such as the fish we
eat
but Reese are in Decline thanks to
overfishing and climate change half of
all Reef systems have already been
destroyed
scientists
ears if we not do any things more than
95 percent of the coral reef around the
world will be in dangers
on a small island 140 kilometers from
Bangkok a team of biologists are working
on ways to restore coral reefs damaged
by global warming
the ocean absorbs much of the heat
trapped by greenhouse gases since 1993
the rate of ocean warming has more than
doubled
that we got was 34
Centigrades and that makes many Corals
in Thailand bridge and eventually die
when stressed by conditions such as
temperature change corals expel the
symbiotic algae that gives them their
distinctive colors a process known as
bleaching
the algae lives inside the coral for
protection and in return uses
photosynthesis to help feed the coral if
a coral is severely bleached the chances
of disease and death increase the
important thing that we have to make
sure is that the baby Coral that we
produce they have to be able to
withstand to the changes of the
environments
Professor challenich's work is centered
on growing resilient coral one way she
believes is to improve the Coral's
genetics
Challenge and her team have developed
artificial fertilization techniques on a
mass scale during the spawning season
between January and March they collect
eggs and sperm from several Coral
colonies and bring them up on land to
fertilize in their Hatchery
here the larvae are grown on concrete
plates in tubs full of seawater
they're kept in the Hatchery for two
years so they're strong enough and then
replanted by hand on the sea floor the
baby corroded with produce they have
high diversity of genetics and this can
help them to survive in a changes
environment
funding issues mean the Hatchery doesn't
have reliable air conditioning running
water or perfect lab conditions but in a
twist of fate the crude facilities might
just have helped the baby corals so
usually the temperature of the water in
actually is higher than normal about two
degrees
Centigrades our hot chili is like a
one-star Hotel resting the Coral in this
one star hotel actually make our baby
Baby Coral stronger and can withstand
the real temperature when we release
them back to the oceans
the team have grown about 10 000 corals
so far corals with this genetic
diversity have a survival rate of at
least 50 percent while the natural
survival rate is just 0.01 percent
but the success comes at a cost a
hundred dollars for each Coral replanted
in recent years Mass Coral bleaching
events have happened all over the world
from Hawaii to Australia the Gulf of
Mexico Madagascar and the Maldives but
projects like this in Thailand show
There's Hope for our delicate ecosystems
so to see more fish more animals like
crab and trims are coming to the areas
using our corals as a habitat as a home
so far in 2019 weather and climate
events killed more than 4 000 people
globally and caused around 42 billion
dollars in insured losses
scientists widely agree it's only
getting worse
replenishing habitats like forests and
reefs are viceline ensuring the health
of our planet reversing climate change
and protecting us from its disastrous
effects
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
they do not know how to use water
that's why we're running out
yeah
which in Navajo means water is life
[Music]
body carries memory
living living
being and we're
the planet is running out of clean water
it's not that we don't have water
somewhere but we can polluted and
diverted and mismanaged the world's
water very badly you crank that glass of
water literally your blood pressure that
you could be hospitalized one glass of
water
oh we just went and paid for our poison
for the month
people just assume that once your water
is running it's safe that someone out
there is taking care of it on our behalf
in 2010 I covered the Resurgence of
uranium mining in the Grand Canyon area
I'm at the Arizona one uranium mine and
this is the uranium Mall which has been
dug up from 400 meters Underground
get one more if you were at a high rise
in uh in downtown London this would be
120 story building equivalent that's
what you're going from the top of that
building down to the bottom of that
building
[Music]
so this is this is what we call a
radiometric probe and it directly reads
out in percent u308 is it like a geiger
counter
almost one percent or
you feel happy about mining uranium
it's just sounded all about
it's all over your face
yeah it's it washes off
[Music]
but when I went to the nearby Navajo
Native American reservation I saw a
different side people told me uranium
mining had poisoned their drinking water
I met a sheep herder Milton Yazi and he
showed me the Old Mine Pit filled with
rain water where he swam as a kid aged
50 had been told had not got long to
live later on I saw him coughing up
blood
the next morning I had an interview with
the local woman when she didn't turn up
I assumed she'd got a flat tire but I
later found out she had died that
morning of cancer this seemed like a big
Scandal yet back at the BBC I wasn't
allowed to include anything about people
getting ill there wasn't enough evidence
at the time to link the deaths to
uranium contamination
as a journalist this was so frustrating
as I knew there was more to say
I was crushed
I knew I had to return to America and
give the story the time it needed to
properly investigate
so I've come back out to Arizona the
Navajo reservation was heavily mined for
Uranium from the mid-1940s to the
mid-80s for nuclear weapons cancer rates
doubled from the 1970s to the 1990s
what other possibilities does a future
hold for the use of uranium
the implication of the future of uranium
is simply fantastic and it's my guess
that the minerals and the metals that we
will extract from
will it be the basis of our very life
for a long long time to come
I'm meeting a young woman Janine Yazi
who helped organize
I remember getting the texts and the
calls the results there's uranium
and Sanders schools water system yeah
almost two times the acceptable drinking
water limits and you're now a part of
that never-ending struggle to prove that
this was unjust that our babies didn't
deserve to be poisoned
and the last thing you want to know is
that you are unable to protect your
babies from something that you know is
extremely harmful for them
so sweaters what do you do when um
[Music]
um there's no water in school if I don't
take a water bottle there's no water in
school
[Music]
parents saying that like yeah the
standards are 30 and years 34.6 but
there's nothing you can really do if you
have a compromised immune system if
you're an infant pregnant or elderly you
may have increased risk and you should
seek advice from your healthcare
provider how about if you should drink
this water or not we've gotten pretty
much no assistance from
any governmental agency
I said why don't you have water trucks
up here live with it basically is you
know what I was told
Janine did you go to that school yes I
went to both the Sanders Elementary
school and the middle school
so you
we're drinking uranium contaminated
water yeah and we didn't know it then
either
so all of us were severely exposed over
a very long period of time you know
considering the the size of this issue
and the fact that the school itself
serves about five to six communities in
the surrounding area we don't have
cancer screening what do you suspect
might be to do with the contamination I
I definitely suspect the Church Rock
uranium spill of 1979 was a major
contributing factor
what was the Church Rock uranium
minesville the Church Rock Dam break of
July 16th 1979 Remains the largest
release of radioactive waste by volume
in U.S history right now probably in
terms of radioactivity release it ranks
third behind Fukushima and Chernobyl
this is bad stuff you don't want to be
exposed to it you don't want it to be
released
that's why they put it in ponds behind
dams
but that morning the dam broke so that
must be all Radioactive
fluids went from the site Northeast of
Gallup New Mexico in the community of
Church Rock about 75-80 miles Downstream
the government said they couldn't assign
responsibility and that was it
it wasn't until a curious PhD student 37
years later decided to do some water
testing that the truth was finally
uncovered this is where the spill
happened back in 79 this is where all
the problem began for Sanders
the groundwater contamination
but when he took his results to the
authorities he found out something
chilling they knew all along that there
was elevated we remaining in the public
water system in Sanders but nothing was
done
Sanders like undoubtedly has the highest
concentration of the of those Metals but
like we have no data to show why and in
this case since we're taking gamma
readings it is showing that there is
some sort of deposit of uranium I mean
it's all this yellow stuff that seems to
she let me things pop up
it started to get really sick in college
around 2005.
they told me that I had ovarian cancer
that was extremely scared
but I kind of just resolved
[Music]
to resolve myself to die
I got treated using alternative medicine
go back to a traditional diet an
indigenous diet
it wasn't until
I found out I was pregnant that I got
really scared
they were going to do an ultrasound and
find that I was never better that I was
worse and you're like oh you have two
spots on your your ovaries but that's
not a big deal like don't don't let it
freak you out I remember like nearly
falling out of that chair it was real it
was real I was going to be a mom
and have this miracle baby
that's amazing that Janine recovered and
went on to have children and it seems
plausible that she got ovarian cancer
from drinking uranium-contaminated water
but I remain unsure if this could have
been the origin of her illness so I'm
going to meet an expert who fed rats
water with uranium at similar levels to
that found on the reservation to see
what she has to say
the Navajo unfortunately I've had a lot
of exposure to uranium both in their
water and dust that flows around the
reservation
our study was proof of principle that
exposure
to uranium and your drinking water might
lead to gynecological problems uterine
cancer ovarian cancer given some of the
health problems that are well known on
the reservation
uh young girls high school age girls
having hysterectomies and so forth
it makes you think is there a link
great power and great crimes are
inseparable
it is only those with great political
economic power
who can with the stroke of a pen or the
utterance of an order or even a knowing
nod of its head send thousands of people
to their deaths or consigned Millions to
lives of unrelenting want and misery
when economic and political Powers
pursue common interests the potential
for harm is magnified these harmful
collaborations are called State
corporate crime All American Indian
tribes have and continue to experience
extreme exploitation since the 1950s
multinational mining corporations went
to the Navajo reservation to mine
uranium with the only customer being the
United States government at the time
many of the Navajo men are employed in
the uranium mines where they are valued
as conscientious workers day by day they
take their places in operating Power
Machinery and the numerous other jobs
about the mines
so this is a map of the Navajo Nation
and it spans Arizona New Mexico Utah
Colorado and if you can see here all
these red dots
these are all the uranium mines
am I afraid to be here yes I am it's
radioactive but the point is is that
this is not the only abandoned uranium
mine there are 520 abandoned uranium
mine sites and with more than one mine
at each site there's something like 1300
abandoned uranium mines on the Navajo
reservation alone that's not including
piles like this one which has just
exposed and out blowing in the wind some
of it has been covered with clean dirt
but a lot of it hasn't I really want to
meet someone from the uranium industry
about this unfortunately all the
companies that operated here have closed
but the uranium producers Association is
in Santa Fe New Mexico
the U.S was the the major producer of
uranium in the in the 50s 60s 70s there
are several abandoned mines on the
reservation you see numbers that range
from 100 to a thousand uh the uranium is
just a small particle of you know a
piece of sand and you break that off the
sand the product is then dried in what
we call u308 or yellow cake and it's
called yellow cake because that's what
it looks like is yellow cake dangerous
not really it's it's you know like like
we mentioned you could eat it it doesn't
really uh you would advise you to do
that but but it's not terribly dangerous
it's not very Radioactive
this place is the highest readings that
I've got I mean I maxed out the geiger
counter the highest reading possible
you were reading five thousand
that's higher than the levels around
Chernobyl
much higher
what I found that keeps me up at night
is I found readings that were half of
what you found in an unmarked geranium
mine that was next to a grade school and
it's not just the external dose which is
what you measure but they'll be
breathing in dust
they'll be getting it on their hands and
swallowing it
and anything that's edible becomes
radioactive and then contributes to
24 hours spent at this site exposed me
to the yearly maximum dose of a nuclear
worker this freaks me out but imagine
what it's like living here and that's
not all the Bureau of Land Management
and the Environmental Protection Agency
say there's at least 15 000 abandoned
uranium mines Across the Western United
States how radioactive they are and how
they're impacting communities is not
known
at least not publicly anyway
at the same time as residents in Sanders
prove their water was contaminated so
did residents in Flint Michigan on the
other side of the country this morning a
lead poisoning alert near a major
American city residents in Flint
Michigan under a state of emergency
being told don't drink the water don't
even touch the water in Flint the water
is contaminated with lead after the city
switch from a clean source to the Flint
River and didn't treat the water
properly the river water was actually
more corrosive and dissolved to the lead
pipes into the water and that's what
people drank I'm on my way to Flint to
find out more because this willful
neglect that I see here on the Navajo
Nation is so shocking to me I want to
know if it's because of racism against
indigenous Americans which I feel must
play a part or if there's something more
widespread going on
Flint residents Christina and Adam have
agreed to meet me
people have died from this freaking
water and then they're gonna charge us
for it funerals are cheaper than paying
everyone back for everything or or
treating you treatment is going to cost
more than it is to bury somebody
Adam used to earn good money as a
Millwright at the General Motors plant
but that life is gone now
the toxins have attacked my central
nervous system
yeah you get the Tremors though real bad
it's a bad roller coaster ride
it's like well what's going on with you
right now
it's like everything's tense
yeah I gotta take a break yeah okay can
I help it over oh yeah
[Music]
that's what my husband goes through all
the time that's why we don't go to all
the meetings because he's he's wreck
our doctor gave us a packet to get our
will together
so you know
we don't know if he's gonna die or not
I'll get a brand new parts on these
machines like just fall apart corrode
and then warp these these engine blocks
that they were that they were cutting so
it's corroding their parts but they
don't tell the public hey don't drink
this water dude what do they tell the
workers how did they explain this to the
workers in the patient they shut off all
the drinking fountains and plants
did yeah
yeah they have them all yeah they have
them all off and they have these water
jugs next to them so you get water from
these water jugs not
you couldn't use the plant's water
to drink from the fountain yeah so they
knew so they knew Mr Murphy presented to
my office on
April of 2017. we did a number of
different tests to actually prove that
he had problems with neurotoxicity he
did have seizures of course his lead
levels were found to be in excess of six
times higher than what they should have
been to the point where he was
dysfunctional and disabled
protests at the city hall are now
relatively regular in Flint
it's not so much that local officials
aren't listening but they were stripped
of their powers as Flint was put under
an austerity manager whose sole goal was
to save money
General Motors engine plant in Flint
said we have a problem since the
switchover engine parts are rusting
before we even get it out of the factory
the emergency manager allowed
General Motors to change back to the
Detroit system yet when the Flint city
council voted to return to the Detroit
system the emergency manager overruled
that vote Capital was protected and
people were poisoned
period
everybody we are here
to celebrate the life of cheyanda
Robertson she's 30 years old today
she's truly missed
we doing what
as a family is supposed to do
we keeping her name alive
happy birthday to you October 31st 2015
my daughter she wasn't feeling good and
they told her she had pneumonia
Monday morning we called 9-1-1 and she
was unresponsive they rushed to the
McLaren they was able to resuscitate her
then she started seizing she was having
anywhere from 100 to like 150 seizures a
day
and she was 28 years old
and that's when they found out it was
the Legionnaire that opened the
threshold for the season and they
couldn't stop the season because the
Legionnaire was so far in our body
we had recently done experiments that
said if a city should ever do what Flint
did which is to stop adding corrosion
control to their water they would have a
serious problem with dangerous bacteria
causing each amount
so who's responsible for the deaths
interesting question
we're gonna have to collect data
ourselves I kept on my water okay okay
like this crap I kept it all and we
didn't drink it when it looked like that
we would let it run like they they told
us let it run and then boil it and then
this was one of this one I think this is
out of my hot water tank
and then like this one's had like slime
in it
there's got to be a explanation for this
this can't be so horrible the government
couldn't possibly be changing data and
this doesn't make sense now when you're
in my world of science and
experiments and conclusions and and
you're still ignoring it that was scary
when I got sick I had to be in isolation
because I had dysentery and it's so
incredibly contagious and then coming to
my home and I was afraid of my house if
I wash my hands with antibacterial soap
what do I rinse my hands with
the Medical Society of Genesee County
put a statement out saying we recognize
that there are certain populations
pregnant women infants elderly people
people with autoimmune diseases should
drink bottled water but the state had
extended an idea to the physicians in
the plant that perhaps Physicians could
write prescriptions to people who need
bottled water and then and then with a
prescription somebody could go to one of
these pods and get their bottled water
and the doctors found it ridiculous and
said absolutely not and at this meeting
that I was at the representatives the
state were so incredibly disappointed
with the Physicians who weren't willing
to work out an arrangement because you
know there's so many people who are just
taking this bottle of water maybe they
don't really actually deserve it
and we water
sometimes it'll smell like poop or it
will smell super chloriney people were
taking their water down to the city
but the thing is is those City Council
meetings nobody had any power so now we
pay like the highest rates in the
country for water that now we can't use
and it's poison people and just kill
people some people like their water
bills are more than their mortgage
they're paying two to three hundred
dollars a month just in the water in
Michigan if you don't have running water
your home could be condemned they can
remove your children put them in foster
care
you're listening to Stateside I'm
Cynthia candy it has been nearly two
years now since the first indictments
were handed down in the state's
investigation into the Flint Water
Crisis 15 current and former state and
city government officials were charged
we were on the record with people versus
Nicholas Lyon I find this Behavior over
this time period corrupt based upon
misconduct in office for probable cause
standards
therefore these
four charges will be bound over to
Circuit Court for further proceedings
again involuntary man and solder count
one involuntary manslaughter comp two
misconduct in office count three as well
as the willful neglect of Duty of office
and count four
so does this mean Flint residents will
get Justice it's quite challenging in a
situation like this to prove cases
against higher and higher up officials
frankly it's not unlike organized crime
in organized crime you're typically able
to catch the low-level people red-handed
they're the ones who are doing the Dirty
Work the higher ups are usually by
Design insulated from the illegal
actions that occur on the ground
government and government decisions
often result in people being polluted
poisoned losing the quality of their
life and losing their life itself in a
very harsh way that's how our
environmental law system works I've come
back to see Janine because she's
actually trying to get uranium banned in
this County and she's petitioning the
town hall here I'm pretty excited
because she could really make a
difference here now we know New Mexico
state is looking to reopen uranium
mining because they're currently
considering legislation to classify
nuclear energy as renewable energy
source and we know that we will again be
ground zero for the type of Iranian
operations that will be needed to
support that type of Industry we implore
you to at least reconsider the
moratorium I've lived in New Mexico all
of my life I went to school at Los
Alamos High School I lived down in
Alamogordo I used to play volleyball out
at White Sands Missile Ranch
and I'm full of tumors
we live between two uranium mines and
just like half a mile away from a
uranium Mill our younger generation
we're raising them up
and what are we teaching them to destroy
the land to destroy this world I feel
like you are we're voted in to represent
us and to protect us and if we
contaminate the water
we're kind of done for
I am for the moratorium well we've had
people here from the state land office
threatening
to sue us if we passed a moratorium
unfortunately
where hands are tied
those are some really strong testimonies
but I can't believe that the local
officials say they don't have any power
to do anything about it just like in
Flint I mean here in the southwest they
don't have an emergency manager to
officially take away local authorities
Powers but it seems like business
interests take priority again
one of the things we recommended was
that all the people who lived along the
Parco River who may have been exposed to
the tailing spill in 79 that there
should be a registry set up and so to
examine their health over time
we were laughed at we were ridiculed
there was this constant
voice of industry and government and
elected officials in in state and
federal government
making excuses denying effects and
turning the tables and accusing anyone
who raised concerns of being an American
coming
anti-nuclear zellots things like that
so do people off the reservation need to
be worried about all this uranium
contamination I think they should be
worried about that and also be worried
about the Colorado River the state of
the Colorado River because I know
Arizona Nevada and California you use a
lot of that water
um like San Diego Las Vegas
um Los Angeles Phoenix Tucson
so yeah they should be worried about
that
what the whole issue of climate change
that's precipitation there will be less
rain less snow and if that happens then
the Colorado River will be reduced a lot
when that happens then the issue will be
like a concentration of uranium and in
the water
should worry about that
in both Saunders and Flint residents got
independent scientists to test their
water and in Flint that was Mark Edwards
of Virginia Tech University
first manifest itself in the other big
water crisis in U.S history the
Washington DC LED and Water Crisis I
prove that the government's claim that
no one got hurt from that unprecedented
wet exposure was false that in fact
thousands of kids have been leading
poison I'd hoped we'd learn from that
mistake so that we wouldn't repeat it
but that was not to be that the Lessons
Learned From The dc-led Crisis were that
these agencies could really get away
with just about anything and frankly
they just got better covering up the
problems you admitted to say that even
after the whole world knew that Flint
residents were exposed to unimaginable
levels of lead you did not declare a
state of emergency until January 2016.
isn't that true I took immediate action
as soon as I learned there was a lead
issue we started issuing filters to
people doing water testing doing blood
testing I wish more possible deniability
only works when it's plausible and I've
had about enough of your false
Contrition and your phony apologies and
there you are dripping with guilt but
drawing your paycheck hiring lawyers at
the expense of the people and doing your
dead level best to spread accountability
to others and you need to resign too
Governor Snyder I yield back
is it not a crime to have known that the
water was contaminated and that people
were losing their hair and getting ill
saying they were getting ill
that's not necessarily crime you know
what we might see come from this case
are the shortcomings of the criminal
system in achieving Justice for the
powerless against the powerful
the amount of pollution that is allowed
under the environmental laws is
determined through methodology
that begins fundamentally with valuing a
human life in dollars and if doing that
math the result is that the cost of
preventing the pollution is more than
the system values the human life and the
pollution is permitted that's why the
Safe Drinking Water Act allows
municipalities to serve its residents
water at 15 parts per billion lead a
level that no doctor would say is safe
and it does nothing to protect the most
vulnerable rather it sacrifices them
children
are undervalued because the child's life
that's going to be lost in 20 years is
worth far less than life today
what are you hoping for from this
meeting
apparently they're spoke supposedly
supposed to tell us what they're going
to do with them with the money
supposedly supposed to go to go to the
industry
you can see that there's been a huge
from the upper hundreds you know Peak
lead values were significantly uh
not enough
shame on you guys shame on you you're
wasting our time and we're dying people
have died from this damn water and all
you guys can sit up there and just
pretend like it's no big deal you should
be shamed of yourself this is what
you're showing our kids you guys can
just say what you want to say and
everybody's just supposed to believe
I lost my job to provide away for my
kids
[Applause]
while Flint residents demand Justice an
unprecedented movement for water has
ignited in North Dakota the Dakota
access oil pipeline is being built under
Lake oahi America's fourth largest
Reservoir
but this is more than just another
protest many people believe it's the
fruition of a prophecy held by
indigenous people around the world that
a time will come when humanity is at a
Crossroads
one way is the path well-trodden of
materialism and the destruction of
civilization the other is protecting the
Earth ushering in an age of unity
with the urgency of climate change some
10 000 people from across the country
and indeed the world have set up a
ceremonial Camp directly in the path of
the pipeline
if they succeed it will be a huge
inspiration for other environmental
movements which really worries those in
power
we are on our way to Standing Rock
reservation
to join the stand for the protection of
water against the Dakota access pipeline
beautiful Forest Beauty behind us Beauty
below us Beauty above us Beauty
surrounding us and with that we speak to
the universe
standing up is a call to everyone hold
in a spiritual way to this fight for
water and this understanding of its
significance to us and to all life
we're on a new threshold
for the longest river in America that
provides for 17 million who drink the
water from it the new threshold is
Humanity
and we are in the Vanguard
we are the Buffalo Nation
we are the ones who ride into the storm
[Music]
we are water
if we deplete the water system if we
contaminate the water system if we
ignore what's happening to the water
we sign our own death sentence whatever
they take to purify the waters to purify
the waters to purify the waters all
you're drinking is chemical upon
chemical upon chemical this Awakening of
the eight fires and what was written in
the birthmark Scrolls and of all the
prophecies throughout it is surfacing
and the bottom line to it is enough is
enough it's water
[Applause]
so we see the convergence of different
nations dealing with these issues and
where we're we're uniting and that's
their worst nightmare just hearing about
like your story like really early I was
like I need to come here just to put my
body here to be in solidarity with all
of you people are coming all over the
country to come here to Standing Rock
like I came here from Flint because
transnational corporations are
consolidating power and resources and
black brown and Indigenous communities
have always been the front lines and
I've always had like this undue burden
um for resource extraction and people
need to wake up and recognize that every
single Community is becoming a front
line against these industries as we're
facing these stresses from climate
change as we are dealing with the Legacy
have all types of fossil fuel extraction
in a water and soil pollution
this is the new wardrobe for America
this is what Freedom looks like in
America
this is what protecting water looks like
in America as a nurse this is a public
health issue and we need to stop this
now we let corporations become our
government and we let it happen but
we're waking up now and we're we're
coming together and we're putting down
our divisive differences in coming
together under the cause of protecting
water and leaving clean water to
generations of children from now on
foreign
[Applause]
luckily I didn't get hit with it but it
landed at my feet it is completely
Hollow on the inside for extra pressure
we do have to face rubber bullets tear
gas sound Cannon water cannon there's a
lot of talking about professional
grenades
endures to the tympanic membrane which
is your eardrum can also cause internal
organ damage they say they're less than
lethal rounds well
those are barely non-lethal I myself was
a combat medic with the United States
Army for three years from 1987 to 1990
um
I was I was shot by a bean bag type
round it's a sack and what it contains
are metal BBs and they put in shotguns
and they shoot it up
non-violent protesters
so I was shot in the back that Thursday
also point blank with a rubber ballet
went on Sunday they added a new element
to it which was the water in it and due
to the freezing temperatures up there we
had well over 100 miles to moderate
hypothermia cases that we had to take
care of there was no call for that they
tried to lie and say that we started
fires the only fires we started was to
stay warm and they just was shielded and
controlled the only one that was not
under control was due to them throwing
out a sea as canister and starting a
grass fire and it was our people that
actually put that out
insurance department the governor and
everybody in between is being paid by
Big Oil
to do this
I mean it all comes down to Greek to
very simple thing and we are here to
fight even for them for their drinking
water for their kids drinking water and
it's very hard a lot of the people here
want to make it a race thing want to
make it a tribal thing want to make it
something a political thing it's not
this is a human thing we just gotta go
balls to the wall like of all the stuff
that we that we do and not have any fear
and like escalate and really like build
like a global movement on on water
rights update the governor issued an
executive order to have everyone removed
slash evictive evicted effective
immediately this is with respect to the
construction of the Dakota access
pipeline
Dakota access parking
39 people were arrested and there wasn't
any violence
that's a victory
yeah what are you worried about with
discount well I'm worried about all the
camps basically there's a war against
all the camps
excessive use of force and it increased
militarization of the police
they're protecting private property
rights to over
U.S citizens and the indigenous people
of this territory that should have
protections under the Constitution Bill
of Rights Etc but it's private property
rights its Corporation
and the history of the pipeline is that
originally they were supposed to go
through Bismarck but the white Community
said no
and they came here and they didn't care
that the people here said no that it was
good contaminate their drinking water
and their sacred sites and burial sites
obedience but they're standing in prayer
they're singing and they're drumming
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
came out with your dignity
that's who we are
what this says about the future of the
right to public assembly the right to
free speech
the right to stand out for your beliefs
is is frightening
the camps were illegal on interest
passing on private property human rights
groups have called your policing methods
excessive and indiscriminate
uh none of that is true
what would you care to elaborate they
were talking about so the use of
um for example let's take the use of
water cannon in Sub-Zero temperatures on
people on November 20th causing a number
of hypothermia cases which is
potentially lethal the we look for one
thing we don't have a water cannon it's
just a regular old fire hose and the the
the water was down there to uh to put
out fires that were started by the
protesters uh fires on the side and
vehicle fires uh that type of thing and
then the water uh basically was there
for the protection of the officers
because of of uh logs being burning logs
being thrown at the officers so it was
another tool at that point that was
that was put in use on another for
another purpose
but in the end water was sprayed in that
area for the protection of the officers
they were warned to leave the area and
it would have been over but some chose
not to do that
[Music]
I represent a new generation of
leadership that looks at things from not
only a cultural perspective it means
running for PRC District uh four
signs up there I decided to run for the
public regulation Commission because
there are a body that regulates all the
energy corporations in the state I mean
we made the most out of our Grassroots
campaign and having just wonderful
volunteers from all over the place like
make their own signs like organize
themselves get the word out and then two
weeks before the election four hundred
and forty thousand dollars comes from
one of the largest Utilities in New
Mexico that is regulated by the PRC to
influence the race you know how can we
fight against that
this is my first trip to the Great Lakes
region and it was important to come here
and meet firsthand the people who are
fighting for the safety of their water
now
clean water
the key in all this has been making sure
that the water is meeting all quality
standards which the latest results have
been very good
foreign
ERS are recommended because of the lead
service lines and the pipes that are
being replaced we've seen that across
the country when they do that that's a
question I want to know like why did
they end the the partial Bill subsidies
because we still are paying for water
that we cannot use
the water is safe for all populations
you gonna kill me you're Snyder gonna
kill me and my husband
[Music]
yeah you too
I've heard a lot about you I know you
too
so you're hanging in there yeah yeah as
much as we can right
that's all we can do
we'll come on in and show them all the
stuff yeah good morning
when I was at home working on uranium
water quality testing project with a
group that's when we heard about what
was happening here in Flint
and like
of
it was so difficult
to read the stories about how
[Music]
about how they lied to you guys and how
they poisoned you and how already your
babies were seeing effects
because
it was almost like a like a double blow
you know like we are here we aren't
fighting for so long and thinking that
oh it's because we're native it's
because we live in like we're isolated
we're rural all these reasons why our
stories aren't getting out that's that
we have to overcome that's why we're not
getting justice but then to see it
happening in a city affecting black and
white Americans who are doing everything
that they're supposed to be doing
according to this American dream and
living in this side society and propping
it up and they still did the same exact
without caring
and it was devastating I'm really sorry
that
more people haven't woke up before you
know now it happens to uh I feel like I
feel like Flint's getting a lot of uh
I don't even want to say it but I feel
like Flint gets a lot of headlines
because there's a lot of white people
speaking up
and I don't think that's right but at
least there is something happening
I just didn't know
that this was going on underneath
everything and I I just apologize for
our lack of knowledge and I'm grateful I
don't want anything to happen to my kids
but
even though this happened to us I'm kind
of grateful it did because it brought
the situation to light this was declan's
blood the day he was born my husband
demanded that they test the cord blood
for lead so that way when we got home
they couldn't say that it was because of
our house his his lead level went from a
two
to a three even though he didn't touch
the water and I just breastfed him so
I'm imagining
that there's no safe way for a mother to
take care of her child in the city of
Flint
I've literally been poisoning my own son
for the last year and a half and I just
found that out and then right when I
found that out I weaned him immediately
all of the issues that we're dealing
with they're bringing the problems of
the global South here and it's making us
in a way one family and building a water
Justice movement becomes more powerful
when you understand that it's not just
over there no it's right here and as the
as the planets water sources deplete and
are polluted you know we're going to
segregate off into who can buy it and
who can afford it and who can make
decisions around it and who who is a
victim the United Nations says that
within 15 years the demand for water
will outstrip supply by about 40 percent
so we just simply will not have the
water for everyone
as we're in the Great Lakes area we're
visiting a new oil pipeline protest in
Wisconsin inspired by Standing Rock the
pipelines being built by Enbridge who
are also investors in the Dakota access
pipeline when it's finished it will
carry Tar Sands oil from Canada and
connect to an older Pipeline on the
bottom of The machinore Straits which is
a volatile waterway that connects two of
the Great Lakes now the Great Lakes are
a fifth of the world's fresh surface
water so it seems insane to have an
aging oil pipeline sitting on the lake
bed of such an important water source
the front lines are everywhere like if
you look deeply enough like the water
system near you is probably threatened
by a similar dynamic between State
corporate entities Art's already been
impacted
when Christina
broke down
let me know how much she's been learning
about what we as indigenous peoples have
been going through that that was really
important and
Powerful for my own spirit
because I saw a sister
and I want to fight just as hard for her
babies
and I know she'll fight it's hard for
mine
that's the community we need to develop
that Community we need to let thrive
that's going to be our Revolution
excuse me did you have to try to get an
interview with Enbridge like a number of
times I never got any response it'd be
great to have your business card and and
maybe try and get a proper interview
when you're when you're prepared well
you know I didn't bring a business card
but I can give you the same number I'm
not sure the guy's name there in the
camel jacket
tow trucks you heard me I didn't arguing
10 minutes
[Music]
you never shut me up
you got the wrong one today
they said 10 minutes
[Music]
all right you're interested
this is my mug shot I look like I'm
about to cry but it's really the look of
shock and disbelief that I had been
arrested strip searched and jailed
before making bail the next day all for
doing my job as a journalist I never did
get that interview with Enbridge in fact
they pressed charges against me and
demanded 85 000 in restitution luckily I
had a good lawyer and after six
stressful months the charges were
finally dropped
Standing Rock was an inspiration but
it's still an uphill struggle for
activists and scientists to bring change
and make people realize that our very
survival is at stake
creator
and who we are as a spirit had this
original agreement
that we would treasure the four elements
Mary Lyons the Ojibwe Elder who gave
water sirens in Standing Rock has
invited me to a gathering of shamans
when you ignore these four elements you
ignore yourself
and you ignore all your ancestors that
rest in you watching the ice sheet melt
and hearing the sudden rumbles of huge
shells of ice crash into the
ever-growing river is sobering Vanishing
ice means less water for people and
crops in the future as well as the
flooding of many coastal cities
you and I we have failed to be caretaker
and custodian of Mother Earth
We Believe those fossil few people
for you and I we don't become rich
we become poor we make them very rich
and they are very very rich
if he could stop using them
they will change the policy
now the people are ready to hear
that they have a responsibility
to change
without hope
people who will run out of water
because they do not know how to use the
water
what is the hope for the world
all shamans
they are the guide
for you to find the PATH which you are
meant to walk
you have to walk your path all the way
out and at the end
you personally will come home to
yourself
and realize your own Beauty
yes
the spiritual Revolution
oh
I think what the shaman means is that
living in the rhythm of money and
self-interest has hollowed out our
Humanity leading us to destroy
everything around us
I think anybody that hears a politician
say that they want to run government
like a business should look at Flint
government is not there to make sure
that shareholders get a maximum profit
government is there to make sure that
people's lives are protected
we shouldn't be telling people their
water is safe when it's not that was the
trash implant that was the tragedy
that's occurring too frequently all
across the United States
putting out water there there is no
civilization as we know it
oh no All My Children
to tell me thank you Grandpa thank you
for standing up
and telling them this is enough
water is everything water is life
[Music]
all living things are born in water
so it's our responsibility
to step up
and practice and exude our power to
create the balance that needs to be put
back in place
and in the Seventh Generation prophecy
that talks about in the time of the
seventh fire there's going to be a
people that are going to rise up once
people are awoken
they can't go back to sleep
CA fire
[Music]
when I started this journey I wanted to
find out more about water contamination
on the Navajo Nation but what I found is
that it's happening in many more places
and is similarly being covered up if
this is happening in one of the world's
richest democracies imagine what's
happening in other places access to
clean drinking water is a looming Global
crisis and none of us are immune but
what I found that gave me hope are
communities coming together and helping
one another and what I've realized is
the journey that we all have to take is
one inside ourselves to decide what kind
of future do we want is it one of
pollution and greed or is it one where
we have clean drinking water in a clean
environment for all our future
Generations the answers lie with all of
us
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
World On Demand
foreign hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring just to see what's
moving the markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
so how does Michigan go from having the
biggest and the best Regional Water and
Wastewater system in the world supplying
Flint with some of the cleanest drinking
water in the world
to poisoning an entire city with lead to
save money the city stopped pumping
water from Detroit and started pumping
it from this the Flint River but the
corrosive river water wasn't properly
treated and stripped lead from pipes
December of 2014. we had our first bout
of groundwater if you were pouring water
into a cup for your child and it was
rotten would you give that to your child
no you'd Revolt for almost two years
we've been crying about this and you
know begging and asking for some clean
water as of right now there is no daily
government-run water distribution of any
kind for the roughly 100 000 people who
live in Flint a city in the United
States of America has been drinking and
bathing in lead contaminated water it's
absurd it's outrageous it isn't true all
of us are outraged by what happened and
we should work together to solve it I
cannot recall in my political life every
hearing
such an outrage as to what I heard from
the people in Flint it's not just about
Flint I am Flint I am from Flint you
know what you are too today President
Obama declared Flint Michigan a disaster
area and I know that if I was a parent
up there
I would be beside myself
that my kids health could be at risk
we're not just looking at Flint we're
looking at our entire state but no other
state was poisoned by policy
Detroit Water and Sewage Department had
been supplying Flint with the cleanest
drinking water on the planet for 50
years in trying to negotiate a new
contract with Detroit Water the city
decided that they wanted to switch to
the new set of water being brought in
from Lake Huron upon making that
determination Detroit Water and Sewer
said uh if that's the way you want it
take a hike and the emergency manager
made the decision to switch to the back
to the Flint River I used to work down
at City Hall when they started switching
and talking about it at City Hall we
couldn't talk about it outside the
building you know they found out that
you talked about it outside the building
you were subject to be getting fired
very bad decisions came along from the
Department of Environmental Quality to
allow the city to not Institute
corrosion controls who would ever have
suspected that the state would go from a
treated water supply to an untreated one
and then not treat it nobody ever came
to me with a jug of this dirty water
there are these bottles of dirty water
it wasn't until it really blew up in
September just like everybody else that
I became aware we were were all getting
rashes before the water looked bad but
once the Water started coming through
the tap in January consistently Brown
it got to the point with my son's skin
where he was breaking out severely
everybody had their own individual
experiences ours was rashes and hair
loss and we couldn't figure out why we
were concerned but we didn't find out
anything until February 26th literally a
few weeks ago this one's definitely
yellow
and you can see floaties this was our
tub water Cole came out running and
screaming mom the water's yellow the
water's yellow I'm like oh colors of
water today
this is safe by the way but that's what
they told us it's safe
I have five grandkids that attend
Freeman Elementary School
the state DEQ come in and did a test
and said that the only thing wrong in
that school is the water fountains
all five of my grandkids that go to that
school have tested positive or lead
[Music]
all right
foreign
no longer has a Water Crisis it is going
to have a lead crisis lead is a
neurotoxin that impacts the cognitive
and behavioral development of children
across their lifespan some people in my
class that that they asked my gym
teacher
to go get a drink from the water
fountain they just go drink the drink
out of the water fountain what do the
teachers say when that happens
they really don't care we still deal
with the water issues um all my kids
when they bathe in it they get rashes
that are horrible our babies are getting
sick for what we don't know
when I have four-year-olds asking me if
they're going to die
because they're poisoned
I have twins one's 56 pounds one's 35.
he hasn't grown in a year
he's still having issues with the anemia
and them realizing at five years old
why there's a difference between them
yes it keeps me up at night yes it makes
me emotional
these are my kids these are everybody's
kids
it's also known to cause spinal defects
which can cause neurological damage of
all kinds so for my Specialists they're
really looking into the spine of the
baby I have one picture of my baby where
I can see part of the face and I've got
300 pictures of the spine my daughter is
13. she has a disability by nature but
because she's been poisoned it made it
worse that is not a nine to five job it
is not something you sleep on when you
know the potential consequences of lead
when you know it's life course damning
potential you need to know what's going
on they've been telling people if you're
over the age of six you're fine I'm 37.
you want to see my meds yeah no my liver
is failing also the seizures are fun
they're just great you know to watch the
Panic on my husband's face when I can't
stop and he doesn't know what's going to
happen to me I want to get tested
came back positive oh well we're gonna
take your information down the health
department is going to get with you
the health department never called me
back the worst part is that the full
effects of blood poisoning aren't seen
for up to five years so I'm waiting to
see it having my kids
we take care of extended family like
immediate family family is family when
their house is tested off the charts
they came to our home it just happens to
be that they all have many children you
know I happen to have one and one on the
way but when you kind of put us all
together there's over 20 of us that come
here on a regular basis our house is
testing at over 1 600 for lead the
landlord when he found out that there
had been a post on Leanne Walter's
Facebook about what our lead numbers
were it was our first time of making it
public knowledge the next day he showed
up to get the keys to the house we
willingly gave him the keys and he
immediately boarded up the house and
told us that the house was being sold we
couldn't go back in for our possessions
and we couldn't go back in to finish the
water testing I had to have my daughter
climb in and break in just to get water
samples
this makes me think the whole situation
we are not going back in photography
we're just going back in for water
because at this point I mean they've
already pointed in two generations of
our family one more thing they take from
us you think the furniture matters you
know the photographs that we got in
there you think that matters it just
hurts so are you coming out okay
be careful
Mike I love you but don't drop the water
okay that's all the evidence we got
just get on a joke
it has already seen animals living in it
it's already seen people breaking into
it honestly if we could get the water in
the two homes
to where we feel it's safe you know
tested for everything
you know five ten years from now we
would take care of this home I would
have family in here my brother-in-law
sister-in-law will be living here
if they don't we're going to abandon it
and it's going to look like every other
house in Flint the truth is is our home
is a decent home
but this is what you see when you come
to Flint
[Music]
audio
good evening
uh I'm Michael
I'm with a little group called cross and
water you heard of them
yeah we're not a band but we look like
one crossing water has been technically
in existence for a couple years see it
was really not anything at all related
to Flint but then Flint broke out and we
went from sitting on the couch
in disbelief to next you know where
we're all in up to our eyes when we
identify a household that needs services
we we get a call back to our operations
center and within an hour we send a team
to that door we give them water we go
into houses to make sure the filter is
installed properly that the family
understands what the filters do and how
to operate it properly we see that some
folks giving them water just isn't
enough a single mother for example with
three kids she's homebound imagine if
you know you work in your job every day
you got three kids all sudden you're
thrust into this unbelievable disaster
where you can't use the water imagine
you don't have a car so now you have to
take water from the fire station or
whatever these water distribution
centers are and you're carrying water to
your home every day with kids in tow a
book bag or groceries it's just not
going to happen so you don't have nearly
enough water that you need and you're in
dire circumstances there's no winning in
this situation because
sometimes it's convenient in a spot for
you but then you have older people that
can't get out and get it
so you know what are they supposed to do
foreign
water every single day and they and I
think they don't like it oh it's
ridiculous I mean we have to use it to
brush our teeth wash our faces otherwise
my oldest will break out and Scar this
is a water room every house and plant
has a water room that's normal don't you
know that's normal I mean you can't
shower in it so you might as well bathe
in a bottle right or if you have an
elderly grandmother to take care of I
mean I'm sure it's really easy to bathe
her over with a bottled water right I
have to use bottled water to cook to
wash our vegetables to rinse our Meats
it takes 14 bottles of water to make a
pot of jambalaya and steamed asparagus
when they first started giving out the
water you would only get a case of water
per family it's terrible you know some
families just might use one case but
it's we got family and children so we
use like two and three phone cases a day
of winers and whatever resources we can
deliver we see to it that other agencies
get involved and step in community
foundations are the place where we put
long-term resources to impact problems
that are going to be with us over the
Long Haul we had a couple of leaders
come together and they established our
Flint child health and Development Fund
it's become known as the Flint kids fund
nearly two million dollars has been
contributed from all 50 states in the
United States we've gotten donations
from countries like Afghanistan
Australia Belgium France but what is
also wonderful is to see the kind of
help that Flint residents are giving
each other I'm happy to be able to go
deliver water and you know go canvas and
go find people who need the help
I had no volunteers today I'm like oh
God please and so my husband's like just
forget it you know for 50 bucks we'll
run a U-Haul and get the water out of
here
my name is Charlotte Lancaster McCann
and I am the founder of building strong
woman and we are a non-profit
organization that take care of homeless
womans that are in need for placement
that don't have nowhere to stay
[Music]
foreign
we hear people often say
did you check on Marjorie down the
street because I don't know if she's got
water her husband died last year and
she's alone what's that adventured yard
across the street yeah they need water
this is affecting everybody and so it's
good to see everybody come together
regardless of what their race or
religion is to help each other out we're
getting assemblance that people really
in the midst of the worst days of their
lives they're worried about their
neighbors okay
okay those are fun
helping flip people and flim people are
tough we are strong we are resilient
okay okay
we need to have power in numbers and we
need to have each and every one of you
guys stand up for you instead of
Michigan or your children for our lives
do it
anymore
[Applause]
[Music]
where do we want
it yeah
[Applause]
because economically they didn't think
the citizens would put up a fight or be
able to put up a fight we might be
ghetto and we might be poor but we're
really loud
really loud when we stand together
[Music]
I always wanted to get married receive a
kiss from someone who would shift solar
systems just to stimulate my smile my
name is Harvey I am an inspiring actress
full-time activist an overall melanin
goddess for the many ways he will say I
love you poets from Flint we agree on a
lot of stuff number one violence is
messed up number two this water stuff is
messed up Flint was known for a lot of
other stuff before the Water Crisis you
know about the school system you know
about GM growing up with that you know
about crime rates a lot of stuff like
that has always surrounded you and this
is another thing surrounding you I've
only lived in two cities for a long time
in my life one is Flint one's Midland
Michigan
Midland Michigan is predominantly white
Midland Michigan has a high economic
status if this would have happened in a
predominantly white area that it would
have been fixed on the spot I guarantee
you they would have ripped up that whole
city in 30 days 45 minutes south in
Flint they don't care okay what I
haven't heard at all tonight at all at
all is any discussion about Emergency
Management and how this is targeted
predominantly black communities you talk
about you've got some policies I haven't
heard one team one team about resisting
absolute subversion of democracy in
Black communities like Detroit Benton
Harbor and flint and this poisoning is
about Emergency Management and you
haven't said a thing about it let me let
me answer your question okay
we appreciate what you're saying we
agree with you
you know what let me give me a minute
okay
so we are in the poorest most
underserved communities in Flint right
now where everyone's angry about this
it's hard to find the right target it's
it's a Target that keeps moving you know
there's plenty of anger to go around and
actually I don't I don't begrudge anyone
their anger but for me there'll be
plenty of time for that later in my life
if I took a minute to get engaged into
politics that's a minute I take away
from these children these families and
I'm just not willing to engage with it
that way
it's unreal I I cry every day over this
and I can't stop crying anymore and it's
sad that I can't keep my home where I
want to raise my family
our long-term goal was to have just
family living right next to each other
and now the long-term goal is get out of
Flint as quickly as possible the next
question everybody says is well why
don't you move
okay well right now I couldn't sell my
house if I wanted to I wouldn't be able
to say hey my house poisoned me but you
want to buy it now lenders are also
saying they need water tests to pass an
inspection not many of us would we are
all in prison we are all being poisoned
by our homes the folks who live in that
community did not make this disaster
this is not their fault and the state
has a huge part of being complicit in
what did happen there wasn't anything
that anybody in the city or state could
tell me that I believed because every
bit of research we were getting was
proving what they were saying is wrong
they had kind of the same attitude that
we saw back in the agency well this is
going to go away soon everything's going
to be fine as soon as we can make the
change over I mean the department
continually insisted that and when you
have all these experts
you trust them the mdeq said well you
know whoops
we misinterpreted the lead and copper
rule that's your one job says according
to the LCR a water system that has
optimized corrosion control with
treatment such as the addition of
phosphate corrosion inhibitor should
continue to operate and maintain
corrosion control treatment when
switching to a new water source so it
seems to me this is the sort of most
clear and obvious place where you're
identifying the the DEQ violated the
lead and copper rule is that how you
would interpret it or would you
characterize it more as a
misinterpretation
I think our
yeah I think you got to write against
the term that you used to describe that
we'd say they weren't in compliance with
the lead and copper rule or they
misinterpreted the leading Capital et
cetera their job was more than just the
technical detail they should have been
concerned about the public health issues
they're potentially exposing more people
as we speak
there's nothing substantial that's
changing they got the money they can
just go ahead and fix what's broke
instead of just sending this water and
they can go ahead and just fix what's
truly broke so we can save our kids and
save us until they can completely get it
fixed I don't even know why anybody's
paying for water forcing us to drink the
Kool-Aid they've made and we all know
they never really could make Kool-Aid
right never enough sugar always too much
lead pay for your poison the girls and
the boys in the city can't drink let
alter in the way they think Future's
gone in a blink do you feel safe
drinking
Municipal bonder here in Michigan at any
municipality
yes
a failure of government at every level
so I think it was one of those
catastrophic systems failures in our
government and I've seen show very
little remorse
very little empathy and care and
compassion and that is
terrifying to me I don't think any of
them were
somehow bad people who were trying to do
something bad I I think they just
didn't take their job seriously enough
look at
the decisions that you made
how many people
it affected
and just I really asked myself wasn't
worth it not only did they fail they
went out of their way to cover it up
they all need to be in jail because they
participated in a cover-up that led to
the deaths of human beings I don't know
if I believe in God
but I believe in evil
and I think there's some evil going on
here I think that's indisputable
you know Snyder's proposing tougher
standards
dwsd Engineers wrote many of the water
system standards for the country when uh
when they were running when they were
running the show okay Mr Cash your time
has I I just need a few I drove four
hours to get here Mr Cash I appreciate
your passion and I appreciate that
you've taken the time to be here and
that's why we also have provided the
opportunity at
flintwatercommittee.com to submit a
written statement as as you would just
bunch of nonsense you're wasting more
more of the people's money and you're
not going to come up with a solution
thank you with that seeing no additional
business to come before the committee
the committee stands adjourned until
Tuesday March 29th at 10 A.M
[Music]
won't you take good care of my Michigan
watch over the Great Lakes my
heart will be yearning to return to the
Pines the golden Rocky Shore
promise to take you to Wild Royal
when you are a little more time
I'll teach you the flowers I'll show you
on the moon and I'll sing you the
sparrow sad song
little one always remember
[Music]
travel to one of her Shores
cheer for the sunset each year for the
islands each year just to see a phone
here just to see a full moon
won't you take good care of my Michigan
watch over the Great Lakes my home my
heart will be yearning to return to the
Pines you're calling Rocky Shore
place I've always called
[Music]
I want to take good care of my fish
again Watch Over The Great Lakes my
whole my heart will be yearning to
return to the Pines
golden Rocky Shore
is the place I've always called my home
[Music]
foreign
World On Demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
I just love that Bold Flavor
I put it on almost everything it's an
obsession really
people are totally stoked on it it is my
favorite hot sauce I eat it on
everything if I don't have it like we
need to that's like the next thing we
need to get on the grocery list
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
it's just different there's really no
hot sauce that you can say tastes like
Sriracha I love Sriracha I do love Sara
hello
I love it you know I use it like ketchup
Sriracha I don't know what I would do
without you
it just adds flavor to whatever it is
you have it on
thank you for making the world's
greatest sauce
foreign
I like seeing people discover Sriracha
because I put it on almost every meal
but like most people I knew almost
nothing about this hot sauce I want to
see like a sea of jalapenos
so I embarked on a journey to uncover
the story of sriracha where it comes
from How It's Made and met plenty of
cool people along the way
I honestly I don't think I could live
without it of all the hot sauces that
exist out there I would definitely say
Sriracha is my absolute favorite
I have a bottle at my desk at work
people during breakfast and lunch will
come by and they'll use some on their
food so I get to indulge people with my
love for sriracha
spicy and flavorful in a respectful way
yeah I take it with me I've smuggled it
into different restaurants friends
wedding reception I didn't expect to
wind up sharing it with the whole table
I just I don't know one day I was like
man it'd be really cool to have a
Sriracha license plate and I couldn't
believe that no one else had it and so I
got to get it before someone else does
my name is Randy Clemens I'm the author
of The Sriracha Cookbook and the veggie
lover Sriracha Cookbook I'm arguably one
of the biggest fans of sriracha on Earth
I think there's this fascination with
Sriracha where it kind of has a cult
following there have been bottles
spotted on the International Space
Station which when I saw that I was like
that's pretty freaking cool
there's just this kind of obsession that
people have myself included with putting
it on everything
I like it on pretty much everything
actually literally everything I love
putting Sriracha on pasta nachos mac and
cheese stir-fry sandwiches every day I
put on my eggs this morning scrambled
eggs eggs have to have it candied eggs
without it I would not put it on ice
cream
but I actually don't know about that now
with these Sriracha ice cream sandwiches
they're massive they're like the size of
your face it looks like the stoner's
paradise you can put it on Pizza Pizza I
do the zigzag fill in as much space as I
can onto the slice my dad really likes
it so it's in my house outside just I'm
too scared to try it I'm nervous my dad
will be proud
[Music]
that is good let's see pasta pizza hot
dog I like hot dogs
[Music]
yeah it definitely it tastes like
Sriracha you haven't tried this yet it's
pretty good everybody is crazy about
Sriracha right now anyways so they love
kind of finding it in new and
interesting Outlets it's called the not
just peachy Sriracha Jam the peaches are
sweet and then you get the the heat that
comes with the Sriracha as it finishes
people love it people really do love
Sriracha 20 million bottles were sold in
2012. and yet for all its popularity
Sriracha is still a mystery to most
people I think there's a lot of
confusion about where Sriracha comes
from well I just would have thought it
came from Asia China Thailand from like
Asia or something because I like the
letters it's no it's not I know that
it's American I believe well if you read
the you know it's from California really
yeah for real I didn't know that how
it's made or the history behind where it
comes from it's all a mystery
[Music]
foreign
Foods
we make the silica hot sauce
I'm David trans son-in-law also his
go-to guy right-hand man
he leads by example he works so hard
Monday through Sunday he's always
thinking about how he can better the
company
he's always very humble Dave is a very
humble guy I'm famous no I went to the
Vietnamese noodle fall anywhere
they don't know I am the owner of the
father
[Music]
the whole building smells strongly of
garlic David's been producing Sriracha
here since 1987 when he bought the
building from wamo makers of Frisbees
and slip and slides before that building
feel full with hula hoop now filled with
cheating
would make the bottle 3 000 per hour and
24 hour six day per week
every day we make at least 70 000
bottles
but David just upgraded to a brand new
Factory in Irwindale California where he
can produce 18 000 bottles per hour
and that's just on one line
the building 650
000 square feet
about two and a half times bigger than
my old building
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
I can tell David is proud to show me
around his shiny new Factory it's the
realization of over 30 years of hard
work
impressive considering David arrived in
America with nothing
[Music]
at 30 years old David saw the fall of
Saigon which brought the Vietnam War to
a close when Vietnam changed to
accommodate them they stopped any
business the new Vietnamese government
considered ethnic Chinese like David and
his family an unwanted minority and
pressured them to pay their own way out
of the country on crowded dilapidated
Freighters All Around Me My my friend I
read him they leave Vietnam so I
followed them after a five-day Voyage 3
300 refugees codenamed Frozen ducks
arrived unannounced in Hong Kong Waters
sat stranded on that ship for an entire
month before British authorities allowed
them to land and David like many
refugees was relocated to the U.S but we
start from nothing David needed a job
and all over Los Angeles were thousands
of Vietnamese immigrants eating their
national food a noodle soup called far
and they like it spicy everyone like me
we need our hostiles so
I tried to make it
in 1980 he poured his new sauce into
glass bottles it would feel by spoon
one spoon one spoon to fill it
and personally delivered orders all over
Chinatown in his blue Chevy van
Delight my product
but some Merchants suggested he changed
sriracha and they said you mix little
minor and you can sell him more so I
said no hot sauce must be hot we need
the fresh tea when he first started
making the chili he would have to
manually dump the chilies into the
grinder and what that was doing is
causing juice to run down his arm and I
don't know if you've ever had chili
sauce on your arm or anything it's it's
not comfortable and it doesn't go away
quickly so often he would come home and
not be able to hold his his daughter for
fear of having that transfer over to her
you know the spice so he's a tough guy
you know he's a he's a tough guy
when I started business we need to
create a company name
[Music]
what name for me so I said okay we fall
so actually remember it
hoi Fong Foods makes three products
sriracha and two others chili garlic and
sambal Olek they all use the same chili
Mash that's mixed with salt and vinegar
and stored in these blue barrels if you
just want to taste chilies that's sambal
Olek but add some garlic from Gilroy
California to make chili garlic and if
you take that chili garlic add a little
sugar and puree it you have Sriracha
which is by far the most popular the
past 30 years
the economies sometimes up and down for
me I feel nothing every day every month
the volume increase the market increase
every year Sriracha sales have increased
almost 20 percent
but that requires a lot of fresh chilies
this year it's going to be 48 000 tons
grown on
1750 Acres
it's a lot of peppers that's a hundred
million pounds of peppers if Sriracha
was grown in New York you'd have to fill
all of lower Manhattan south of Houston
Street with pepper Fields I would say
we're probably the largest red jalapeno
grower in the country
a green jalapeno as it matures goes from
green to Chocolate to Red sometimes the
sauce will be a little bit different
color because of the the weather and the
nature of the variety that we're growing
you know with that volume we'll be
shipping about 30 semi loads a day
before we'll have it on their doorstep
in about two hours from the time of
harvest and we're their soul supplier
Craig only sells his Peppers to David
and David only buys peppers from Craig
it's highly unusual in the processing
business as long as they're selling more
product we have to be able to grow it
for them it's a big job huge job
17. old messages
wanted to call the number on the bottle
and I appreciate it so I'll talk to you
later bye I just like to compliment your
hot sauce like thank you so much it's
the best podcast
almost everyone loved my partner I'm
feel very proud hi there how you doing
this
Sriracha does not need to be
refrigerated
it's like gallons gallon bottles that's
a good idea in addition to their 17
ounce and 28 ounce bottles the new
Factory is adding a gallon size and a 9
ounce Sriracha hi I just want you to
know that your
Sriracha
Powers you omit the r you just say
three very distinct syllables there's a
little break in between each one
not three lashes
but I I don't say that every time
because people look at me funny just
here I think it's Sriracha that's kind
of what everyone says before that cannot
pronounce
rooster sauce and
that's because David was born in the
Chinese year of the rooster wow you
learned something new every day
never advertised for it that's crazy it
makes it a little more hipster every day
we have no enough product or selling it
so we don't have time to make the
advertising Hui Fung food has seen
massive success with no advertising with
no real online presence to speak of on
their website it looks like it's
straight out of 1996 busy to looking the
chili so I don't have time to go to the
Facebook twister but if you search
Sriracha on YouTube you will find plenty
of fan made ads oh yeah
oh yes sorry it's made in America land
of the free so it may look peculiar
don't let the bottle fool you it's hoi
phone Sriracha the American garlic chili
pepper sauce what we bout to do right
now is drop the rooster sauce
the only kind of my in my fridge don't
give me a smidge to send this rate to my
veins with the tips around there's a
special song Set over you so I'm talking
about the ratchet it's a sauce I choose
generally speaking there are a lot of
sriracha freaks out there I
definitely have a nice kind of hipster
following
it's absolutely iconic and I think it's
completely unintentional too we're
surprised where are my TV stuff to grow
we always enjoyed getting the emails or
pictures sent to us
there are some pretty awesome Sriracha
tattoos out there but the coolest one
actually that was like someone had
spelled out across their knuckles
I think I've seen stiletto heels
[Music]
my myself one bottle lasts for three or
six months but every day we're selling
hundreds thousand dollars a bottle
don't know where to go search
Dakota
[Music]
this is an official warning do not try
this
[Music]
am I sweating
it's pretty popular in food circles and
I think a lot of what had to do with
that is you know showing up on Top Chef
Harold dieterle who won the first season
of Top Chef is a big fan one of my
favorite ways to use it is just fold it
into some mayonnaise and make an aioli
out of it and it's like bam do whatever
you want on it throw it on a crab cake
sandwich throw in a hamburger that's
awesome I really love Sriracha I
invented these Leathers that are
flavored with Savory sauces what they do
is they absorb all those juices and kind
of uh keep the juices at Bay every Chef
has got a bottle in the refrigerator I
don't care what they tell you Sriracha
how much Sriracha do we go through uh
six bottles a week so half a case a week
David Tran has two cultures to thank
Vietnamese culture for the fall movement
there's not one Vietnamese place that
doesn't use sriracha and he's got the
Japanese Kitchen for the spicy tuna roll
every sushi place I've worked at they
use Sriracha in their spicy tuna
like every single one if spicy tuna
rolls were not popular I would argue
Sriracha would not be as popular we're
all using it for offense yeah if someone
tells you they don't like sriracha's
food
yeah
I had a red one with a a black top and a
clear one with a green top morph the two
of them together into a Sriracha water
bottle I wish I was in the dining dining
centers here because more people would
eat it no it's not it's in the dining
centers right orange chicken right there
it is right there okay I'm gonna go eat
Sriracha pasta today
oh my gosh Revelation sriracha's cheap
so college kids will eat it very
important the price very very low
they're looking for something to enhance
their Foods I try to do something for
the my chilly friend they have money and
no money they can pay they can get it
I'm a pretty Frugal person but you know
win or lose I'll walk out with
more money than I ever had going in
Hitler is having a really good year all
thanks to Sriracha I live in a house
that all we eat is sriracha sauce so
when lays asked the public for flavor
ideas Tyler suggested Sriracha they
called and said that I was a finalist I
won fifty thousand dollars and my chip
was one in three out of four million
that made it that's amazing it's not a
bad amount of money to get but I mean
who wouldn't want the million the grand
prize winner is
cheesy garlic bread
so maybe Sriracha isn't mainstream yet
but several big brands are testing out
the flavor which begs the question why
isn't the Sriracha name trademarked
because
most people don't know where Sriracha
came from right and it's actually Thai
originally and if anyone would know it's
jet Tila the Thai government appointed
him the first culinary ambassador to the
United States it was created in Thailand
yet uh the most prolific version of this
is from the Tran family who's Vietnamese
but manufacturers in America so if David
Tran didn't invent Sriracha who did
I met Anne Kia chinda who represents
Sriracha paneer the original sriracha
sauce from Thailand and today it is one
of the most popular brands in Thailand
and says it all started with a woman
named Miss tanam chakapak she's a mom at
home making her own sauce so does David
Tran owe his success to a woman in
Thailand it's very different from the
Thai version I don't think he set out to
create a Thai version I think he set out
to create his version he's made a
household sauce of it he's a genius
business success story but as a Thai
person I'm conflicted about how it's
done you need to go eat
Sriracha the way we eat sriracha
[Music]
foreign
there it is we arrived in Thailand not
sure what we'd find if we could even
track down this inventor of sriracha
but we knew where to look we will travel
down the road along the seaside
[Music]
foreign
Coastal trading post known for its
Seafood its hot sauce
and a Tiger Zoo
there's lots to do in siracha but it's I
wouldn't call it like a very popular
tourist destination yet
bring out a little bowl of sriracha with
you have to get like a fried egg omelet
or a muscle omelet with a little bit of
jasmine rice they have lines out to
catch fish so you're getting very very
fresh seafood ordered some oyster omelet
and some grilled squid all of it was
fantastic with with the Sriracha I think
the Thai versions quite a bit different
from the hoi Fung Foos version it's not
quite as hot it's thinner in consistency
and it's a little bit sweeter
we love it we don't love it as much as I
think other people love the thought of
sriracha it's not glamorized
it's said that in 1949 Miss tanam
chakapak created her sauce here and
because she used local peppers and
garlic she named it after the town
baseball there is a little different
with a J at the end of it right yeah and
the fact is that there's no actual 100
way that you can translate the Thai
characters into the Roman alphabet Miss
chocolate would be almost 100 years old
if she were still alive today
but at the Thai tepros Factory in
Bangkok where they produce Sriracha
penied we met the woman responsible for
carrying on her Legacy died
[Music]
laughs
Sriracha here is made with a long red
pepper called prick chifa and fermented
in these large silos before bottling
it comes in two flavors medium and
strong hot and they're testing Sriracha
mayo which is genius
[Music]
foreign
they do omelets here is just out of this
world
very good the sauce that started with
Miss tanam chakapak in a Seaside town
has led to a whole world of variations
yes it's a whole beautiful world out
there it's not just you know the hoi
Fung Foods version if you want to try
something that's a little different
there's some cool options out there Dark
Star Lee come key The Saigon sisters T
Racha awesome sauce
there's so much I use them all and it
gets to be like cigars the garlic can be
stronger sometimes can be a little
sweeter it just depends on the brand you
get and then there are some other brands
that have come around recently that are
you know smaller batch a little more
Artisan produced there are more people
that are into Sriracha than I could have
ever imagined one of the things that is
happening out of Brooklyn is this
excitement about making things again
well right now we're producing the
upwards of about a thousand units a
month so it's all small batch we do
about 20 pound batches at a time so
every batch is really this unique thing
that you're getting it's never going to
be the same the next time people are
just really into Sriracha so when they
see a new kind they're totally stoked on
it
[Music]
[Applause]
hi how you doing we're here at this
roster festival 2013 is the first one
ever
[Music]
it's kind of funny because I mean when
it comes down to it it's hot sauce right
but I've become pretty obsessed with it
on many levels
the idea that there's this American
style hot sauce based on a Thai style
hot sauce made by a Vietnamese guy of
Chinese descent and you get the best of
these four incredible Cuisines kind of
coming together
I only project girl
[Music]
David Tran doesn't often make public
appearances so when he stepped into a
crowd of sriracha fans
no one really noticed
at First Once word got around that this
is the guy everyone wanted to talk to
him and David finally connected with his
chili friends
I mean that's the most important thing
is we care about the our customers and
we'll continue to work hard for them and
for our family I need someone to
handle to take over so only my children
the right person to to handle it this my
level one I don't care my loved one for
anyone
try and paint a picture of the
hard-working man that cares about his
family that you can see through his hard
work and the product that he's created I
tried to make continue to make my good
product for my fans
until someday they don't lie as a doctor
back
[Music]
thank you
I just wanted to say thank you guys for
manufacturing from the best chili sauce
ever had and I look forward to eating
more thank you about I love throughout
the company I have greatly enjoyed your
bottle of sriracha and I just wanted to
let you know you guys are doing a very
good job and keep up the good work hello
I want you guys to know
if you are the pride of the Vietnamese
people
always do what you guys do what you guys
do
good morning I'm calling from El Paso
Texas I'm just calling to say thank you
for agreeing on such a delicious product
I was wondering if you could send me the
recipe
bye-bye we love
you've made all of my things here for
like
hi my name is David
and I'm sitting here enjoying a late
night snack
I'm making a sandwich here I just want
to say how much I love your hotspot
thank you so much for what you do I will
continue to be a consumer
and maybe you'll hear back
thank you
hi um
my name is David I just called a few
minutes ago
I was just talking about your hot Philly
sauce how much I loved it
and I just really want you to know and I
love what you're doing
and keep on doing it
you have a great morning
oh my God this hot sauce is good you
guys be a good job thank you
hi I just want you to know that your
Baraka hot show itself is the best
thing
I mean it's just this
how the hell
there's somebody in advance
such an unbelievable sauce I mean it's
so damn freaking call
but it's not too hot with intolerable
it has just a
a hint of sweetness to it
which makes it
instead of this fire
I mean it's just unbelievable
end of messages
[Music]
foreign
and I said the 825
but there is the stuff comes in we put
them in place
before 11. before
11 15 we're gonna make 17 pies
and then another 17 12 30.
we gotta do what I gotta do
even if I should
be on the beach some places now at this
age after 45 years
and relax and the Sun but for how long I
stay here at the place
I would like to do things
get down on my way
even if sometime I'm wrong I know
someone right all the time but that's
how I am
located
that means the eye of the owner make the
horse fed
foreign
[Music]
she could be going that way and don't
worry about nothing so am I even live
another 15 years
[Music]
oh my God
that's it
next to the machine
[Music]
you're a very strong man for your eggs
you're not the only one that's saying
that I'm 36 now I don't want to work no
more you're 36 yeah I think I could beat
you yeah I bet you can
making two sandwiches to the delivery
guys
so I give him a sandwich and the Surah
each
they do that extra work see this can be
it is a dollar
to make it 25 cents
John it has to sandwich thank you very
much
is in New Jersey don't be late next week
[Music]
good to see you
instead of messing around when I was
young that's how my father spit the hell
out of me because I grew sneak in the
neck food then I'm just supposed to you
know I don't know what you're cooking
you know and I still do now
we have been coming to Rudy's in the
last 45 years I've been living in
cluster for 17 years and I come here at
least once a week
years ago
12 years for me
we've been coming to Rudy's for 27 years
foreign
I think every family needs to have a
place a go-to place where they can be
comfortable have a great meal and also
get to know the people who run the
restaurant and they know your name
um you know James Beard used to say when
people would ask him what's his favorite
restaurant he'd always answer the place
that knows my name
correct anytime I come through that door
they know who I am
they respect me I respect them and we
just have a good time when we come in
there this is home to me
this is home
I started over there 1970 I worked for
somebody else five years then we bought
the place
and I thought Tom everything was
rendered well
decent stores nice people
then the year going by the the owners
they started to let the place go
some people it's not to move out like
four or five years ago this company is
the the decided took over and redo the
shopping center the first thing is that
when the lady come over later she was in
charge and listened and she says uh you
might get a close
so wait a minute let's look at it close
what the hell are you talking about so
we're here for at that time it was
I was here that time like 43 years
I said now you come over tomorrow I
gotta close and then we don't want to
close and I walk out I walk out
so then we started to
get together and after work and Fred and
Josh and Dad as you guys due to the
negotiation
it was falling apart they needed a lot
of work to be done and stuff like that
so we
you know we made the you know we made
some agreements to move over here so
that way the construction could be done
on the other side
[Music]
well this before was a rafter they used
to call it which it was Cronin store men
and ladies
you know moving and movies you know is
no good there's a lot of money
involving it and most generics to move a
restaurant is not a you don't move a
desk and a chair
[Music]
hi name hi
how are you man good good are you hungry
the food's here
are these disparagus should I put them
on a plate
oh perfect
Rick we're waiting for you
yeah I'm coming I'm coming it never
changes oh we can put it we can switch
it
Rick what's the what's the formica table
situation
uh I don't know
putting it over there oh the tables are
done at Big Friday dinner right
finish them in wood so we're done with
Brick we're done with talking about
brick I like to do brick but they don't
want to do brick why don't you want to
do breakfast
we're going to break for why did you
stop loss would you like a different
kind of wall
you know with different
age situation over time or whatever it
is you know me I'm a very simple person
the food is good the dishes they clean
the table they clean the place is clean
and already looking for the granite
marble black red green whatever you know
what I mean but I think we're all
different that's what I I
I'm gonna do that
okay but do you think that every single
person who comes to your restaurant is
also like that or do you think that
people other people look around
well you know what we do this for four
to five years
supposed to be different they've never
said it yeah well you can always I think
we're not in a position where we should
necessarily waste money frivolously but
I think that you can still accomplish
having a beautiful place within yeah
we're gonna we're doing this no one has
ever wanted to waste money frivolous
right right
Charlotte
in two months
you're the time wait can I ask you
something speaking of you retiring if
you're rich wait wait I never finished
my fortune thing over here you're too
much you're retired you're gonna get
your check
every week
how much should we don't know but we're
gonna get something
all right thank you
that was good thank you what do you want
fortunately yeah no not one of those
uh-huh
all right the play is going to come out
beautiful your legacy your legacy will
be protected forever
it's really the truth the pump does not
see he does not even see
Aesthetics he doesn't see anything
around like in a restaurant he doesn't
see anything he doesn't he doesn't even
see it to appreciate it or not
appreciate it well it's Focus he's been
an operator his whole life those focus
is on the food the service he's never
really
from their point of views you got you
know they have their perspective that
they know but they don't have the other
perspective we have both we've been
lucky enough to see both I've never
cooked on like a like a full-scale
behind the line for weeks and months
I've never done that I could figure out
how to make most of the dishes I know
how to make them but that's not what I
do yeah
that wasn't what I chose to do right the
day of the independent Italian off the
boat operator that that generation's got
foreign
you see that
okay
I don't know with two hands the general
is winning
two
and we're even one see
well the little tunnel where we come
from is very very very important for me
doing a female friend
to get his former friend though it's
about 15 minutes to drop
well we grew up in Italy
in the farm in 1945
I'm the frost of seven of us we seven
all together I'm the first one and most
of the time America
him because two years younger than me
and then the others and then when the
internet was just five years five years
younger than me I think Doreen John it
was a pain in the neck
Freddie and Charlie are my oldest
Brothers I'm in the middle
they were the ones that really had most
of the responsibility outside of the
house we had to go to get a
loaf of bread you had a walk
a couple hours go to the little town to
get a piece of bread
if you had to call someone you got to go
up and uh
high and high spot to call Vincenzo John
people
making sure this guy the person will
hear you
[Music]
um
come on
what the good things was there though
you learn how to survive you learn how
to feed yourself
and you learn respect
um
we had what we needed not what we wanted
bedrooms no we didn't have any no no
electricity
no water we used to drink the water out
of the to the creek there was like
streams of water right there yeah
sometimes
yeah a fake fig Leaf yeah it would make
it like a cup and drink it and we would
use that or we use our hands
over here we used to plant the tomatoes
and uh
uh with the wheat
got a minute also
that was my grandfather my father father
he's the one who fixed this the house
was here
but was in bad shape and he fixed it up
a little bit
while the Roma was a little kitchen down
here
all day with wood wood burn
stove and that was like like a little
dining room inside there in Italy these
shirts in bed in the wintertime is cold
you know if we had no heat in the house
nothing
I go to bed and I started pushing you
know I push him so he moves back in the
cold spot and I get nice moves
and that's the truth
I don't remember that
I went to school five years from six to
eleven of course the world was another
school close to us at that time I was
like I said before no bus no cars they
don't think it was a donkey I uh to go
to a different School condition you
gotta walk like an hour and a half
and my father is you know what I can do
that so we gotta start to do some work
but by the way I'm in school I was very
smart you know there are so many things
I could figure out my numbers in my head
and we'll get out of school my five
Scholars
six seven o'clock in the morning
get that sup
I've got turned up this Lane the lap
piece of dirt
upside down to plant some vegetable
ah and then a 12 o'clock comes my mother
choose to make some Thomas
spaghetti with string beans and potatoes
I put them on the table
if you want to eat that's what you eat
today
if you don't want to eat go take a walk
there was no choice
a lot of animals one rabbits chickens
pigs
and dangy which someone killed that
tongue later
by that was an accident
but a thing happens also we got a
a bull not a bull
um
what that you call him
a cow
oh oh look what's in here
another one of my friends
looker
we learned to be successful we learned
to be disappointed and live with
and never blame anybody that was life
there
God you know like I I remember Freddie
somehow always getting in trouble me and
my father when I was a kid he didn't
like me too much I used to do anything
to get away from my father
Charlie was more like the the like the
second when there wasn't around he was
like the dad like he was the one in
charge
um
I remember once my mother said to me I'm
going to make some eggs
you know so I get the fry pan I get the
eggs she almost killed me she says this
is my kitchen
and that's the myself my head is you
know one of these days I gotta have my
own kitchen
when I could go over there and do
whatever I want
that was years back right
and now look today I still remember that
I said yeah I got my kitchen out with
two 24 burners
[Music]
this is gonna test it just a good looks
I don't usually go out for Italian food
because nobody makes it better than at
home but that's why this is so good here
because it's like it's home cooking if
my father came back
to this place for putanesca that means
it was as good as my mother's and you
can't beat that
they would never buy anything unless
it's only the freshest and the best
because it shows in you know the
presentation and what you're eating and
how good it tastes I just came back from
Italy and they're just as good as Italy
I think it's only it's one simple thing
in in the rest of the business
to now
sell
any food that you
not eat yourself
[Music]
yes
get a room
which I was American 1963
and a ship at that time and this 63
Christopher Columbus my father
and my brother
they will get ready
to leave
I was not too happy about that you know
so he left the media with uh and half
dozen kids and my mother
and all the other mess that shall
describe the chicken the pigs and
whatever whatever so I suppose if you
know what I went to the to the military
into the Air Force so if if I find that
over here so right away
you know you put the paperwork in for me
to come over here too
when we landed in New York and I'm
sitting in the back seat and I'm looking
out at all these lights
it was fascinating
the lights and the movement and the
people and when I got home like the TV
oh my God a television and lights and oh
my God a toilet
you flush I was happy because I knew
that I think you're more aware of what I
was away I knew that staying there I
would have had my mother's life
that was very nice to see things lights
and streets and Cars Moving
compared to what we left in Italy
my father had no money I remember once
it came a couple of bucks a couple of
dollars
and they said well you got to get a job
the guy was a friend of us he had a
bakery
in the city so I started to work there I
start to mix dough
for bread so all night from five o'clock
to seven o'clock in the morning
at that time it was no soda
no coffee no air condition
was just working working and working it
was a working night which was a blessing
so I was living there for you you know
so it comes over the morning and I'm
leaving
I mean this country is in 1963
it when I talked to someone
an American person you could call right
away and never went to school do you
think I went to school at night school
when I used to work in a bakery from
five to seven I went to that school one
night
the second day the owner of the bakery
he said the guy who makes the door
leaves
tomorrow and now you got to come up with
five o'clock and start to work so that
was my old school out in the United
States
two hours about two hours or one day no
I know my English is no good
I know that sometimes I asked my
granddaughter to spell something for me
but you know I'm not ashamed of it I'm
not
it's not in the wrong spot it is I
buy your lunch buy me lunch every right
you know we're gonna go with amazing
what's happening there's a the space
that they left for the walk-in box is
not the right space
they measured someone who measured wrong
okay
no don't take his his tape measure
screwed up you see what happened those
people that come over here look at this
guy with the with the shoes full of dirt
no dirt and I gotta clean the floor
right here
are you guys familiar with this
that's the reason why it's wrong okay
[Music]
we're thinking about variation but
you're thinking of doing this outfit
in horizontal wood and this on this
angle
my father fundamentally thinks that it
doesn't matter what the place looks like
as long as it's clean and the food is
good and
it's just not true hard part lick food
is good the food is good remember a
question the problem is for 50 years
he's been the only game in town so you
have three other restaurants coming into
the mall thank you plus Whole Foods
serving food yes so people are given
choices right all right listen something
put them in the middle but you know
nobody talks about to make a couple
dishes you know a couple new dishes
we think it's important that the room
looks good you have one chance now to do
a brand new restaurant the second day
we'll move there Charlie retired ah I'm
right now
wait a minute how many years he's been
saying that entire second day you got to
make them signed it
so tell me what's going to be in these
shops do you know the shop or Winona is
going to be two Mexican restaurants oh
burger place whatever
we're going to be Target
up there
or Home Goods the movie theater is going
to reopen when everything is done it's
going to be one of those movie theater
which you quit inside also you watch a
movie so in other words you're gonna
have like six different restaurants
besides where it is
but
who is the original one the only one
original since the 1960.
with the bar what we're going to do
I don't want to put a TV in the back
anymore because the TV is going to take
up too much space can you change your
mind yes what I want to do with the TV
over here
50 inch TV put it up there and then that
serves everybody Chase is going to have
the two by four ceiling tile the
rectangle
this is going to be sheetrock sheetrock
over there so this is the pizza ovens
yes the pizza vinegar from here to here
okay
and then this is the counter
I have to measure the old days
[Music]
foreign
top
we have to get a plumbing inspection
and then we need to just finish ordering
the materials
to do the uh the walls
and you start thinking about the
finishes what for the space it's really
six weeks it's supposed to open in six
weeks six weeks April 19th
do you feel like you're on track yeah it
feels that way
cop said today that you're gonna have to
be at the restaurant several days a week
starting when the new place opens
probably
but is that possible
the thing that concerns me is is all
these new restaurants in the shopping
center
I mean right it's a real thing that
these all these restaurants are real
competition
that's it no no I don't there's more
than enough to go around restaurants are
going to open and close but if you
control
what you do
within the restaurant your own place you
don't have to worry about competition
right they are with 50 years of history
and a big following
I don't think that they need to worry
about that you know if anything is
always a plus it brings more people to
the mall yeah but my question is Whole
Foods is still going to have a pizza
which pizza it's seven dollars for a
slice it's almost been seven dollars for
a slice like I'll drive into Manhattan
and get a slice of pizza then I could if
they're gonna be in close looking for a
slice of pizza I could spend seven
dollars slice of pizza have you ever had
whole food pizza
everything's good at the whole food take
out there it's good super expensive it's
expensive and it's Chichi and it's
organic and if you're eating organic
you're probably not going to be going
for a pizza
yeah
well I did to make make a pizza good
more the most important to use of the
building good ingredients and in this
dodge is flour
water
East
and salt
and nothing else yeah no oil no no sugar
which some other places that do that
Sugar give us a brown color but if you
make at the door every day
you don't need that
I had my first slice of pizza at Rudy's
in 1963.
my mother would give me a buck and let
me go to Rudy's for a slice and a soda
during lunch
I didn't get pizza anywhere but if you
want to get really good pizza and at a
really good place with really great
people Rudy's is you know your pizza
spot 50 years old I I won't eat no other
Pizza
what this whole business
1960. the company makes the solvents 30
years ago that tournament should never
get rid of these solvents because they
don't make volunteer like this anymore
these elements are the best you can't
beat them they're the best someone's so
thick takes an hour and a half in the
morning to get the stone hot enough and
then when you put throw on on a hot
stone like that you get a crispy crust
that's what people are looking for at
least I think they are
thank you
okay bro
[Music]
Andrew here's your pie from here and you
get a chef salad and you get a shot
all right
[Music]
I made my first piece in 1965 in New
York
then it was a little pizza place around
the corner whose name was Mimi
51st at 10th Avenue
the castle was going to sell it
so my uncle is white I think we should
buy it
so we get together
and we buy ten thousand dollars
I don't have that five thousand I have
and Iris asked a friend for a loan so I
put two thousand dollars of my money and
this friend to give me three thousand
which are paid back anyway
worthless so to make a pizza and all a
few kind of sandwiches that was so five
years then the little dope the rain and
with ferrato we said no for the rent we
froze the place and also the original
owner of rudis was the person I know for
a long time
to work with you oh yeah this is your
brother sure say bring him over and
brought it up there brought away start
work there
and they never got out
is that it got stuck there it's still
staggered
food isn't close to started September
1963. so here's my mom
where it is there's my dad and
as he and my mom were fantastic Cooks he
was the Fanatics of food if it wasn't
right
he wasn't satisfied he would make a pot
of sauce and he'd tasted it if it wasn't
right he'll dump it he had no qualms of
throwing it out rude is just like a jack
says was business man nice person a
little bit tough
Maria we used to make a dog with Maria
Rudy's wife she used to go to bake mixed
flour but the water in the machine and
makes the flower 50 pounds of flowers
pick up in the bake and put them in the
machine and mix then I used to go back
there put the dough on the table I used
to roll it with two hands it was like
she was like my mother really
I work from six months for the original
rubies
then it sold the place he asked me he
said Charlie why don't you buy at that
time I was 25 years old I don't have ten
dollars maybe out of ten dollars but not
much
foreign
[Music]
and there are three places
and I work for them
for seven years
so the guy says Leo is Leo he said
Charlie Wilson we're going to sell the
place
he says when should I buy so I'll call
Fred we get together
and we bought it I already had his fit
for my brother but when he asked him
that
I I want to hug him
but
we come from we don't hike too much we
took over
October 17
1977. we did a 420 dollars gross
for the day and never forget that
when I worked with Ruth is your mom must
say and I worked with her for many years
we used to do the dining room together
because your dad was the best pizza man
I mean he would he could make a p his
specialty was pizza and he could do like
you know the other dishes but when it
came to the white wine the more delicate
dishes it was all your mom and I
remember her going from the dining room
serving the customers getting into the
kitchen and preparing those dishes with
a certain Elegance she did everything
with a certain Elegance
[Music]
Nina was involve around in the business
and she knows she knew exactly she was
doing very smart person we really worked
together I mean we accomplished some
ideas and everything how overrun by him
you know and then if he didn't agree
with all I gotta do is go talk to your
mom and the next step is fine
push him a lot of things
which if it was enough for our
I don't think I was going few things I'm
never going to do even to buy rooties
to work with your mother was like a
it's like a blessing I mean how we get
along so well
you know and I still thinking about
doing the espresso
huge day off she comes over here having
his friends together
you know find a party party I bring
espresso to your mom to the last day
you know
I think we're gonna break
[Music]
um she was
she was one of the nicest people I
haven't met my entire life
I'm sorry
she was a waitress so I was uh worked up
front but I got what is together for her
and uh you know all you had to do was
watch the way she worked and you just
want to be like her you want to you know
do the things she did enough
foreign
I remember the first time I met her so
outside of that
she
she was as much of a fixture in the
restaurant as Charlie or Freddie she was
she was the female counterpart she was
there she was hostessing she was front
of house as funny as Freddie is as
serious as Charlie is Nina was something
in between and she was just amazing I
mean she was the most sophisticated but
not formally educated person I think I
knew get a lot of style and a lot of
spunk and I think over the years she
brought that to the restaurant when I
was probably 11 or 12 one day I asked
Maddie if I could make a pie and we got
a chair from the dining room and as I
was making the dough
my mother grabbed me
from like this
and literally pulled me off the chair
and said you're not learning how to make
pizza
and the point was I'm not on my feet
all these hours all these years so that
you have to do a life of manual labor
like weed
my wife used to help me and Fred
by any time to wash the dishes at the
end of the night we are like 100 dishes
to wash so I've told that they work and
wash the dishes
we didn't have to get our money back as
soon as we get our money back
then we started to get a little help I
started working at Rudy's at 14. so I
came here in 1979. I had a job to do it
was a lot of pies to make at once and uh
especially Good Friday Good Friday but
uh yeah good Fridays were quite a quite
an event busiest night of the year right
nobody can eat meat so Rudy's was like
the record-breaking pizza night right
we'd have the A-Team on let's put it
down
Maddie of course right
I started here I believe it was October
1978 so it's going on 37 years
the owners here they're they're very
fair but they can't be tough at times
which is fine they want done things the
way they want it done which is their
right and you know
they really do know how to run a
restaurant these guys
my name is Gregory Rosario and uh I've
been working at Rudy's for 17 years we
don't have that normal relationship with
the boss and and employee have we don't
have that we we're like we're like
family I have been working here I
believe I started in 1992 so going on uh
23 24 years you know they came to this
country with very little and built this
incredible
machines incredible restaurant
that that's basically supported us all
my name is David Oso my father is uh
Fred I've been uh working at the takeout
counter for about 20 years my name is
John I've been here by eight years at
Rudy's well I'm Andy Fernandez I work
here the first time in 1972.
we had like a 31 minute it's not an 85
in 1985 yeah he started a dishwash it's
very good very good man it's been 11
years it did wash dishes they cut the
chicken it doesn't try to work just like
me all right it's a very good cook very
good Chef very good person
I love him is he here for many years 18
17 17 years the Bonkers are like family
the customers is like family
I am like the family like a big brother
of not big brother he's older than me
anyway
I mean for rudis I think the main thing
is Charlie and Freddy I think when you
it's not Rudy's it's Charlie and Freddie
I mean they're always here together you
come into the place you always see one
of them here they're very demanding
customers as far as quality they they
won't tolerate anything unless it's top
quality and and you know sometimes they
they teach us a few things well Charlie
I would say is more of a
the back of the house
you know he works with the dough with
the water ring making sure everything's
running according to plan very
regimented very regimen very organized
he's
[Music]
you know the hair is combed the same way
the outfits are always you know just so
and he's
he's structure I've never met a 70 year
old man
that works the way he works well I
didn't appreciate it if you could come
over today we didn't need it all right
please thank you call me all right bye
Fred is
Fred is a people person
he's very very big he's because he's got
he's got that personality he's got that
you know you leave you leave after
having a conversation with him and you
have to laugh because he's just he comes
off as so entertaining especially with
the customers he comes in here and he
jokes around with them and he has fun
with them
would be Freddy
the comic you know on the floor Freddy
can roll everything rolls off his
shoulders and just laughs it off they
complement each other very well because
I think they're like Polar Opposites and
that's why they they've been together
for so long
and they just work perfectly together
it's not just my boss and my friend
[Music]
um
Charlie and Freddie took rudis from
Rudy's and they they brought it to a new
level
and what rude in the original movie
maybe was lacking they brought it in and
that's them being here all over the past
all the time you give up your life you
don't have weekends you don't have
holidays I have four kids I don't
remember when they took their first
steps when they got their first teeth
because even if I was there I was
preoccupied with you know the business
becomes a huge part of your life but to
be successful you have to give up a lot
and you have to put that time in 40 60
80 92 50. yeah number 15 come up come up
thank you good night Charlie Boy
I never thought it was cool that my
parents owned a restaurant when I was a
kid I think as a kid I probably resented
the restaurant
because it kept my parents from me you
know I never really got to know my
father as a child until I was 30 until
after my mom passed away really
but I do this on my side I do for my
for Rick
and Tony because
[Music]
after four or five years I think it has
trouble for me to
not retired because even if I retired
I'm still not going to be every day you
know
to take it easy Let's uh aggravation and
responsibilities
[Music]
foreign
was almost done
90 is done
this week we should finish I just think
it's amazing that you spent your whole
life here
in this place you know what I mean like
from when you were in 1970 you were 25
why that's right and you're now how old
are you I'm
so this is the men's room that's the
men's room
can you believe this though you turn
around and look at what's in here
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
boxing one on top of the closed one here
yes because it's so far off it's too
shaded then one in this big one yeah
Rick is good the most of everything is
good it's very polite he knows how to
talk to people
it's got respective of the people who it
deals with and they get along very good
we're not going to complaint it's a is a
very good it's very good or not I'm very
proud
oh I tried to get pop today to say nice
things about you and it was oh he's done
everything
well my father didn't exactly say
anything I know
he started tearing up when he said he
was proud of you he started tearing up
and had to look at his watch and kind of
distract himself it was really sweet but
I was really trying to get him to like
enumerate your qualities
and he did but it was not that easy he
was much he was much more comfortable
saying there's a few things I don't
agree
most restaurants fail when you have
family trans family transition when you
have contention and if your people start
forcing things you know for me because
for me also you know like I'm in a
position in my life that I don't need it
you know I don't have to do it for ego
or for financial gain or whatever I'm
doing it for the right reasons so if you
see what's good for the business what
makes a business successful you know for
me to force or anyone to force any kind
of change is selfish and stupid you know
you let the business run its natural
course and what works works so why
change it you let it go do you yeah do
you really what do you really imagine
like
your best guess for a year from now what
is the layout of
your involvement in his involvement in
Friday's involvement it's gonna it's
gonna be the same thing
in a year it'll be the same thing which
means they're both therefore yep
even with everything pop said
I guarantee you you think let's tape a
year from now saying it's amazing so
today is February 29th 2016.
you think that it's not going to change
no the new place is an Italian Farmhouse
that they grew up in so you come full
circle it's where they started so
they're going to be they're going to be
at home
they're gonna be at home
[Music]
foreign
okay okay
[Music]
right
here
[Music]
finally finish
[Applause]
I'd like to thank everybody for coming
today this is a great day for Closter I
would like to recognize the owners of
These Fine establishments folks that
have been around here for a long time
Charlie and Fred awesome
[Applause]
[Music]
not only do you need to build a
beautiful restaurant being built a
restaurant that's functional that's
practical
um you never want to alienate the
customers that you built up over the
past 50 years and bring in some new
clientele as well serve some more wine
like our some nicer specials but never
lose sight of what got us here never
forget where you started
Rudy's is a landmark in closer yeah it's
a landmark for the entire Northern
Valley as a matter of fact when the talk
was about changing the plaza selling the
plaza the only thing people wanted to
know is Will Rudy's stay there I love it
I think it's so pretty it's like home it
has
we've read online that today was the
opening so we had to come I live in
Brooklyn now and I come back
specifically for Rudy's so it just feels
like home one or two three four five
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm proud of myself I'm proud of myself
what I've done and I'm proud of me and
my brother of accomplished
you know and we now we're getting old
because you know we get an update but we
still enjoy working at least I am
I I don't really want to retire
completely well retirement is none of my
my gender
no I never thought about that really why
you wait another two years then you see
the difference
between 68 and 70. that's what he said
when I was 50. foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
thank you
foreign
all around the world a powerful
transition is taking place
communities are building local movements
to address economic instability and the
worst effects of climate change
energy lies at the heart of our Global
Society
and how we consume it impacts everything
from the air we breathe and the food we
eat to our jobs and the health of our
families
currently the vast majority of this
energy comes from the burning of fossil
fuels
and while these resources help to create
the world we know today they are now
proving to be a threat
they threaten our safety
or economy
and the health of all life on Earth
according to Economist Jeremy Rifkin
when oil prices approached a hundred and
fifty dollars a barrel in June 2008. it
caused prices of basic Goods to
Skyrocket
which led to a massive Global shutdown
that spike in Commodities had a Rippling
effect around the world and contributed
to the crash of the financial markets 60
days later
the burning of fossil fuels is one of
the main contributors to air pollution
which is now officially known to cause
more lung cancer than second-hand smoke
carbon emissions are the primary cause
of climate change which is disrupting
our daily lives and destabilizing the
planet at an increasing rate
foreign
scientists say there's been a 40
decrease in phytoplankton since 1950 as
a direct result of climate change
phytoplankton produces half of the
oxygen that you and I breathe
these life forms are at the very
foundation of the entire ecosystem
if we keep destroying them by dumping
excessive amounts of carbon into the
atmosphere we could be the cause of our
own Extinction
[Music]
when we became aware of how energy is
directly connected to these Global
issues we set out on a mission to find
solutions to the problems we face
we launched an Indiegogo campaign and
raised enough money to begin production
of the film you're watching now
we discovered a vision to move away from
fossil fuels and switch our whole world
to a hundred percent renewable energy
you are about to witness that Vision
unfolding from some of the people and
communities that are leading the way
this plan has the potential to create
millions of green jobs
a healthier environment
and improve economic equality for all
we are at a critical point in history
we can choose to continue consuming
energy the way we have in the past and
that our children face the consequences
or we can choose a transition into a new
system based upon local clean renewable
energy
[Music]
this is our generation's Revolution
this is the future of energy
[Music]
millions of people around the world are
creating 100 renewable energy projects
and targets their whole cities regions
countries businesses that are targeting
100 renewable energy some of them have
achieved it some of them have surpassed
it it's very exciting to see we began
our adventure by attending the very
first 100 renewable energy conference in
the U.S where some of the most Brilliant
Minds and energy came together to share
their Visions about the future of the
planet
these leaders are implementing a bold
new plan to shift the whole world to
renewable energy a lot of people are
still thinking about renewable energy
like it's 1990. we're 5 10 15 20 years
out of date with reality of where
renewable energy is today we believe
that there's technically an economically
feasible to repower the entire world's
energy infrastructure for all purposes
with renewable energy the main
limitations are more social and
political rather than technical or
economic we envisioned that these plans
will result in 100 conversion to wind
water and sunlight for all purposes by
2050. by 2030 we expect about 80 percent
conversion and really what that entails
that by 2020 is that all new sources of
energy will be wind water and Solar
Vision Without action is merely a dream
merely a dream and if you just have
action without a vision you're just
passing time
so if we take action with true Vision we
can change the world
but if you are an alternative energy
and want to save this planet
I will move whatever I have to move for
you
I will do whatever I have to do to make
your project successful the moment you
convince us it makes sense
because we need a place that is
literally going to save the world
nobody else is volunteering I'm
volunteering
all around the world people are
implementing renewable energy at an
amazing rate
some cities have already achieved a
hundred percent renewable electricity
and many more on their way
some have set goals to be green cities
and carbon neutral within the coming
decades
While others are enacting policies to
ensure that every building consumes only
as much energy as it produces
there are even plans to build brand new
100 renewable energy cities across the
globe
we travel to the heartland of America to
visit a city powered by 100 wind energy
Greensburg Kansas
[Music]
[Applause]
the very wind that destroyed Greensburg
in a
2007 tornado is the same wind that we
utilized in our rebuilding process to
generate electricity that powers the
whole city of Greensburg in 2007
Greensburg was hit by an ef-5 tornado
that destroyed 95 percent of all
buildings and left nearly everyone
homeless afterwards hundreds of
courageous citizens came together and
decided to rebuild using 100 renewable
energy well you know the first thing
when I heard we were going green I I
cringed a little because we go back for
decades and
of talking about Green and we Associated
that with
environmentalists where Jimmy Carter and
solar panels in the White House exactly
tree huggers
so as we framed it in our own thinking
we realize that our ancestors were the
original Green people being good
stewards of the resources and educating
people of what really sustainability
resiliency and being green really is
Mayor Dixon took us around town to see
some of the green buildings and to meet
a few of the local residents wasn't
about a political agenda it's about
common sense their sense of spirituality
and and stewardship as it related to God
family clean air clean water generating
their own power so for us it was really
helping people reconnect to that and
that was I think part of what
sparked people's imagination and sense
of passion for what they really wanted
and
so here you see today this living model
of sustainability
[Music]
[Applause]
but there'd never been a John Deere
dealer anywhere that had done anything
like this so we had to go to John Deere
Corporation and basically let them know
what we were doing we wanted to build a
lead Platinum building essentially super
green and they said well what's that so
then we had to kind of embark on
educating deer a little bit and that's a
massive Corporation you're talking about
as to what these standards are and why
it's important to build to this level
which is relief it deals with your
Energy Efficiency your materials and the
construction the what you use in your
construction so right now with that big
turbine and all those small ones we're
probably sitting at about a
it's generating about 80 to 90 percent
of all the power needs I have
[Music]
we're all very important but we can't do
it alone we're not on an island
and so when we get together
cross-generational and pull this
together
it's just
totally rewarding if our community
can teach the rest of the United States
or the world some of the facts in front
of them to just make their footprint a
little bit smaller it makes a big
difference in the whole world
[Music]
we do this one activity called power
source where they are challenged to look
at an outlet on the wall and draw a map
of the source of that power
foreign
[Music]
fossils dead things that are in the
ground that we're bringing out we're
waking up these like Elders our
ancestors yeah they go that deep and
we're utilizing them instead of
utilizing this living breathing Force
that's the sun
fossil fuels are scarce they're governed
by a different rule of Economics whereas
we've got the technology curve and we
come down in price with mass production
they go up in price with mass production
because they're finite and the more you
use them the more expensive they become
whereas solar electricity has always
tracked down and now it's crossing over
that line and becoming less expensive
than conventional electricity and at the
socket where you and I pay for it as
retail consumers of electricity it is
less for most Americans to have solo
over the next 20 years than it is to
take conventional electricity there are
new numerous experts that agree that
it's technologically possible to go to
100 renewable energy the question is
political will the question is not if we
are going to go to 100 renewable energy
it is how and when Lancaster California
became the first city in the U.S to
mandate solar panels on all new
buildings
they're almost at Net Zero and their
goal is to be one of the solar capitals
of the world
foreign
and I would understand the the lack of
motivation of people to do something if
there was nothing we could do
or if there was little we could do
the you know the the engineers and
scientists of this country have done
remarkable things in regards to
Alternative Energy
we can now do it cost effectively we now
have the ability to to save the planet
increase the standard of living and the
well-being of everyone
that we were able to put solar panels on
every every facility in the city and
also provide shaded parking in the
process you know every school in the
city shaded parking in the process and
we fixed our energy costs we have five
City facilities that have one and a half
megawatts of solar on them it's
offsetting about 97 of our usage and in
our first year we've saved a real fifty
thousand dollars
from there we learned that the school
districts were interested in pursuing
solar as well they've seen a real 225
thousand dollars in savings wow over the
first year we installed solar on 25 of
their sites and it's a seven and a half
megawatt project we're going to be Net
Zero within four years so and then it's
going to be how far below men's cereal
can we get I mean I put solar panels on
my house
cheaper you know it's the only business
decision my wife said I've ever made
that was
a good one
and you first start with new
construction if you have Sun you got to
go to Silver now here you want to put
solar panels on your house it's over the
counter you know you come up the counter
20 minutes later you got your permit
it's easy you know all new construction
so many kilowatts is going to be
required this way I do know sense that
we've become engaged in this alternative
energy and being a part of the solution
the well-being of everybody that lives
here has improved
and nobody intended it nobody planned
for it
but we feel it
[Applause]
[Music]
during our time with the mayor we had a
realization
what if it's the solar energy itself
that's transforming the community
oh
hundreds of years we've been powering
our societies on the dead energy of
fossil fuels
maybe it's been impacting our psyche in
ways we aren't even aware of
communities like Lancaster are now
tapping into living energy directly from
the Sun
[Music]
by harnessing that power they're
engaging with the same life-giving
forces that created our planet in the
first place
[Music]
we are fortunate we are right now on the
cusp of a new convergence of
communication energy a powerful third
Industrial Revolution that could
potentially Maybe
get us over the divide into a new
sustainable post-carbon Society in time
to address and mitigate climate change
and we heal the Earth this the third
Industrial Revolution is not rocket
science these five pillars to create a
new post carbon era is just plain common
sense you have to go to renewable
energies because we've got to get off
fossil fuels that are killing the planet
we know we have to collect them so you
collect them wherever you have human
infrastructure to collect them because
those energies are everywhere so use
your buildings to collect them and your
infrastructure Builder two pillar three
we know we have to store the energies
because they're intermittent the sun
doesn't always shine when you want it
the wind blows at the wrong time so we
have to store the energies killer four
we have to share them because sometimes
you may have less green electricity
available and someone else in another
part of the continent may have more so
we put in an energy internet so everyone
can share their energies with each other
in pillar five we have to then plug in
the whole system with our transportation
our electric and Fuel Cell Vehicles if
there's a plan B to these five pillars
for a new economic Paradigm I have no
idea what they could be
thank you
according to Jeremy Rifkin the great
economic revolutions occur when new
Energy Systems converge with new
communication Technologies let's see how
that works in the first Industrial
Revolution coal and the steam engine
powered our boats and trains and the
steam-powered print press made possible
the mass production of printed material
like newspapers and books
Industrial Revolution cheap oil and a
combustion engine came to power our cars
and airplanes and the telephone radio
and television became our main forms of
mass communication the third Industrial
Revolution is the convergence of
renewable energy Technologies such as
wind and solar with advanced
communication Technologies powered by
microchips in the internet
the first two revolutions helped to
create the world we know today
but as we look forward it's now clear
that renewable energy and advanced
digital technology are the only
solutions capable of moving us into the
future
some leaders say that natural gas and
nuclear power the solutions but that's
not the case first of all natural gas
produces more than just carbon dioxide
it also produces methane which is a far
more potent greenhouse gas than CO2
secondly natural gas production is
exempt from the Safe Drinking Water Act
Clean Water Act and the Clean Air Act
because it's not regulated the ways in
which natural gas pollutes groundwater
drinking water and the air causes
unknown risks to human health in the
environment and nuclear seems like an
impressive technology but managing
nuclear material can often be dangerous
and difficult to control
the nuclear accident at Fukushima in
2011 was a terrible disaster and it is
another example of how hazardous nuclear
energy can be natural gas and nuclear
are not wise Energy Solutions when we
have safe clean renewable technology in
the new paradigm we will be creating our
own energy and sharing it as we choose
just like we do with the information on
the internet that is the future of
energy and that is where we're headed so
soon we'll have solar cells on the
surface of every building on the surface
of the streets themselves
everything will be able to produce its
own electricity
and we will be the plurality of power in
our society we'll produce most of the
electric power that we use and will
displace The Infernal combustion engine
which is what I call cars and
Automobiles and other ways we use
transport with electrification because
electricity will be so cheap that we'll
put it everywhere the way to keep
distributed generation and
decentralization truly on the path
towards um towards a clean energy
economy that's sustainable and socially
just requires democratization of the
energy system that means people in the
communities have control and ownership
over the energy assistance and
infrastructure it's actually a total
transformation of our Energy System and
thereby of our society we actually have
the power to take energy back into our
own hands we have the power to
democratize energy and become the owners
again of the local power that we're able
to create in our communities when we
converge the inner internet the
democratization of communication with
distributed energy
we've empowered the human race
millions and then billions of people to
produce and generate their own green
electricity at near zero marginal cost
so they can then share it with neighbors
across entire regions and continents
just like we create information and
share it online so we've democratized
communication with the internet and now
as we begin to expand out to the
internet of things as we call it the
internet of things which is the
communication internet the energy
internet and the logistics internet
we're democratizing energy
that's a game changer that's going to
change everything
[Music]
so we're in Oroville right now in Butte
County in Northern California and we're
with great Alternatives there's going to
be an install today this family's
getting solar panels installed on their
house so this is really cool there's
student volunteers coming out
it's really exciting you get to kind of
see the whole process unfold right in
front of us so it's gonna be a fun day
[Music]
to date we have eight offices seven of
them in California and one in Denver
Colorado and we're expanding nationally
we've installed almost 4 000 systems for
you know people who think in megawatts
that's over 11 megawatts which is really
a power plant but all installed one to
two kilowatts at a time on the homes of
low-income families we've trained over
14 000 people
and really what that translates into is
like over a hundred million dollars all
put back into the hands of low-income
families
[Music]
you know we're engaging first generation
um
college students that are economically
disadvantaged and we're working on an
internship program with them to give
them Hands-On skills and give them a
Competitive Edge in the technology
industry I want to do this solar
involvement or volunteer work in order
to like kind of get back to the
Community as well as nature because it's
given so much to us I feel that we owe
it to the Earth that we give back to it
I think it's really important that our
generation really learns about
alternative energies because
it's going to be really important in our
future things are changing
[Music]
Sierra we're expanding to the east coast
we just installed seven systems in New
Jersey and in New York and are opening
are in New York New Jersey office next
year every new home is gonna be required
to have solar and Commercial properties
and it's like you know this is this is
how we should behave we should be making
a structure that is self-sufficient all
it takes is one neighbor getting solar
and then the whole neighborhood's like
oh man I should have done that yeah next
thing you know the whole neighborhood
got panels it's amazing this is the most
fun day I've had in a long long time
we're decking this house out with solar
and I mean look at this Tech it's like I
feel like I'm in the future right now
this is the future of energy
foreign
Community Choice aggregation where
municipalities all over are taking back
the decisions about where they get and
how they get their energy and applying
the and and from the investor and
utilities
um and actually asserting their
Democratic right to decide what kind of
energy where it comes from who who does
that work Community Choice energy is a
local program that buys and generates
electrical power for residents and
businesses and here in Sonoma County our
Sonoma clean power program is going to
be providing 33 percent renewable energy
with no coal and no nuclear power in the
mix that is a valued choice of the
people of Sonoma County that we want to
go with renewable energy and that's
critically important for reducing
greenhouse gas emissions and addressing
the climate crisis where do carbon
emissions come from
according to the EPA 33 of carbon
emissions come from our use of
electricity
and how do we generate that electricity
two-thirds of it still comes from the
burning of fossil fuels
[Music]
ccas allow us to cut our carbon
emissions by choosing renewable energies
to power Our Lives
call your state and local officials and
tell them you want Community Choice
aggregation today
a lot of solar
was is described as this will solve our
energy needs
not we need to review how much energy
we're consuming so if we don't
completely start with how much we're
consuming from the get-go
and do those kind of energy Audits and
not just an audit but an actual plan of
action so there's really three main
components for San Francisco to get to
100 renewable energy the first one is
what we call shrinking the pie so that's
really focusing on reducing our energy
consumption and reducing energy demand
so that's the first thing that we want
to do is shave off the excess energy use
throughout the City and County of San
Francisco Vermont has been a historic
leader on many energy initiatives
particularly uh efficiency we we began
down the Efficiency Vermont path in the
year 2000 in a comprehensive way and
they're now getting over 12 percent of
our annual electricity from efficiency
alone we expect that will be 15 and then
20 percent within the next few years
and we know where we gotta go we got to
go to zero net energy we gotta stop
wasting stop wasting we need more
elegant design more efficient ways of
using things our journey led us to the
grand opening of the zne center in San
Leandro California
it's the first retrofitted zero net
commercial building in the country
zero net energy is an example of how we
can dramatically lower our carbon
emissions and create millions of green
jobs across the U.S you got purpose you
got collaboration you got business you
got labor you got a Union contract and
you got apprenticeship
what role is retrofitting going to be
playing in this shift over to the whole
new energy Paradigm okay so retrofitting
is an important spectrum because 99 of
buildings right now are existing right
what we're doing which is kind of
revolutionary it's the first building
like it is we retrofitted a building to
be Net Zero which gives us a model on
how to make every other commercial
property Net Zero if we can do it you
can do it there's no gas input to this
building whatsoever they capped it off
because we don't use gas we're all
electric based the important thing about
being electric based is that we can
produce our own power so why would we
use gas when we can produce with solar
panels and wind turbines in our Solar
tree out front
free Power
[Music]
the purpose of this building is to train
the future Workforce of electricians
that's what ibw Nika does the union the
contractor Association they put you know
individuals through a five-year program
college credit classes you know like I
said Hands-On 8 000 hours of Hands-On
for the purpose of training this next
Workforce that's going to go out and do
all of this either retrofit or new
construction of buildings in this
country that will be more energy
efficient if we're going to retrofit all
of our buildings why not make them
living buildings
by using Nature's Own design principles
we can create buildings that are
healthier more beautiful and more
sustainable
I think Greening our buildings is
amazing and inspiring but I'm excited to
see us go even further and looking at
things like the living building
challenge where buildings are not seen
as separate to their surroundings
people the buildings the surroundings
are all seen as a continuous almost
living being they're really fantastic
and they're popping up all over the
world the ultimate goal of a living
building is really to find a way to to
approach that net zero energy usage but
also create buildings which are in
harmony with the flow Ebbs and flows and
cyclical diurnal seasonal
variations in in nature and it's not
just a standalone building which
consumes energy but it's something that
really is is working in tandem with the
natural resources and forces
[Music]
foreign
idea house a Net Zero Energy Zero carbon
showcase for sustainability welcome
[Music]
and we have built a Net Zero Energy Zero
carbon home and we produce more energy
than we use on an annual basis and uh
we're actually making money on our our
energy production
[Music]
so what you're looking at is uh the
solar array very simple Solar Ray it's
all PV photovoltaic panels so they just
make electricity because our house uses
almost no energy during the day and so
most of the the energy that it's using
is actually being pushed into the grid
and it's powering the rest of the houses
on the street
[Music]
the sun rides high in the sky in the
summertime and it runs low in the sky in
the winter time that means with just a
five foot overhang we can shade the
building dramatically in the summertime
and then in the winter time that heat
will penetrate the windows and actually
heat the house so that's accounting for
50 to 60 percent of the heating and the
cooling of the house
so we have an induction cooktop can boil
a full pot of water in two minutes and
it uses electromagnetic Technologies we
kept off the gas line none of our
appliances are gas so we're not burning
anything and that's why our house is
considered zero carbon because we even
have an electric grill outside so
there's nothing combustible in our house
[Music]
the car is now charging it's that simple
it's as simple as charging your cell
phone
there's absolutely no maintenance on
this cars as well no oil changes no
timing belts the brakes on the vehicle
are meant to last the life of the
vehicle I don't know about you but I
have no interest of going back to the
pump I have no interest in getting oil
changes it it really doesn't serve me to
do those things and it doesn't serve the
environment to do those things
so it's nice to know is that there are a
range of electric vehicles available now
there are smaller cars they're mid-sized
cars I have a a Toyota RAV4 which is a
Tesla powertrain it's an SUV perfectly
capable of carrying lots of things
you've got the Tesla which is a high-end
car we've got a plug-in Toyota we've got
the Fiat we've got a leaf which is a car
I had for a couple years fabulous car
really enjoyed it looks like we have a
Ford looks like we've got a smart car
even a couple of other interesting cars
like photos and Fiskars are here so a
nice range it's just nice to see that
electric vehicles are now no longer One
Market they really span the spectrum of
what consumers might want
if a third of carbon emissions comes
from electricity where else is it coming
from
28 comes from Transportation alone
and currently 93 of the energy we use to
power our vehicles comes from petroleum
average Americans single greatest source
of carbon footprint is going to be their
car ten thousand pounds is what the
average car pumps into the atmosphere 10
000 pounds carbon dioxide when you go
with an electric vehicle one of two
things is going to happen first off
electrics are inherently more efficient
and therefore even if you get your power
from the utility it's still going to
dramatically reduce the amount of carbon
that you pump into the atmosphere coming
from the utility instead of coming from
your car I have on my home uh solar as
do many electric vehicle owners
that solar cost me twelve thousand
dollars
it's replacing my fuel costs for my
vehicle as well as my electric cost for
my home
given the displacement of the cost of
fuel and the cost I otherwise would have
been paying the utility for my
electricity I'm going to pay back the
entirety of my solar system in four
years thereafter driving for free now
that system is going to last on my house
for at least 25 years guaranteed
probably will last dramatically longer
if you take the cost that I'm saving and
you look at the cost of electricity and
how that goes up annually the cost of
gasoline and how that goes up annually
you do the numbers crank them through
you'll find that it's literally hundreds
of thousands of dollars I will be saving
over time in having home solar to fuel
my home and more importantly to fuel my
car
[Music]
thank you
I've been an activist on climate and
energy issues for a long time about 20
years or so working with a bunch of
non-profits on energy policy and climate
protection
when I was working at Greenpeace in the
last decade mostly in Australia and the
Pacific I realized that the time had
sort of come to not just demand that we
stopped digging up carbon and polluting
the atmosphere but also we start driving
the solutions at scale
[Music]
foreign
if you're a business owner wanting to be
part of the solution B Corps are the way
to go
social benefit corporations are an
emerging business model founded on the
triple bottom line of people planet and
profit
sungevity the company I help start just
won an award from the Oakland Indie
Awards for job creation in Oakland
because in a recessed city in America
company that's grown to 270 employees is
a good news story right and that's the
story of Seoul over the last five years
again a hundred and twenty thousand as
of the end of 2012 employed in the Solar
industry at the end of 2011 we're a
hundred thousand so we added 20 000 jobs
in 2012 this flat year which is a
remarkable number like a double-digit
growth rate in employment
name another industry doing that in
America Danny Kennedy and I got together
and thought what would it look like if
we could transform Oakland starting
right here in Jack London Square into
this place that's known around the world
for solar Innovation and Ingenuity so
anyone around the country of the world
who has an idea for a solar startup
particularly in software or finance that
they would know we better go to the spun
Cube because that's where it's happening
it's the founding partner singevity is
doing an incredible job helping
residents Go Solar so people who
otherwise couldn't afford you know the
20 to 40 000 to put up a system with
singevity they can get a solar lease so
zero money down you get the panels up
you know almost immediately and then
you're paying less from day one on your
energy bill for the next 20 years of the
lease whereas the prices of fossil fuel
dirty energy coal are just going to
continue to rise and continue to destroy
the planet and we have you know eight
great companies already in this space
and a couple of non-profits that support
these sorts of uh openings in the the
economy so you know one great example is
Mosaic which is a crowdfunding platform
and Mosaic is connecting everyday
investors people like you and me to
solar projects that otherwise wouldn't
be funded by big Banks so one of the
challenges in the Solar industry is that
there are a lot of medium-sized schools
churches hospitals that can't go solar
Banks won't Finance them Banks won't
loan them the money and so Mosaic is
stepping in and saying you know what we
don't need big Banks to finance these
solar systems we can do it ourselves
because there's enough people around the
country and around the world who want to
see these institutions Go Solar and are
willing to put in their money and
because they're going to make their
money back and then some so it's pretty
much like a solar savings account or a
solar retirement account that's paying
you back and then some we were started
with a mission of democratizing
investing in clean energy and
accelerating the transition to a world
powered by 100 clean energy and you know
that is of benefit to the world most of
our projects return between four and
seven percent annually we have zero
defaults today 100 on-time payments to
our investors so if you structure these
Investments right
they're very solid yeah I'm here to talk
to you about money you know I'm the evil
Banker in the room and uh it's an honor
to be in your presence but it has to
make business sense right so
um I want to talk to you a little bit
about the economics behind Finance
renewable energy for us and why it makes
business sense for us some of it's
coming from the finance end of town you
know like big Banks U.S bank robber Bank
City Goldman they're all getting into
the game Warren Buffett didn't spend
seven billion dollars on solar in the
last couple of years because he thinks
it's a passing fad
you have people like
um Tom steyer and Kat Taylor and Oakland
who are saying you know what we're
billionaires and you know what we also
are not okay with being alone
billionaires with our little private
club we're funding clean technology
we're opening a Community Bank we're
doing these things to start
redistributing our funds the thing that
will catalyze a massive shift is the
recognition that people want to spend
money with people who care so we need
young leaders in America to be stepping
up and saying I will create that
business that puts solar in every school
I will create the window that is also
providing electricity I will create the
car that self-powers I will sell these
solutions that already exist in an easy
online store I will create the app for
that there's software there's Finance
engineering there's all these
opportunities that need the Ingenuity
and Genius of young Millennials to be
applied to that will make this solar
opportunity happen this rooftop
Revolution take place but that really
requires entrepreneurs to grasp the
nettle and do the work it's inspiring
because I think there's a lot of models
right now and I think big CEOs realize
that if their business is not having
some massive give back as part of their
business model they will become dinosaur
and die
we plan to chain ourselves to these oil
barracks right here and hopefully try to
engage dialogue in a non-violent direct
way and then we'll be testifying later
on in the meeting
this fossil fuel divestment movement has
already spread to over 300 universities
and college campuses across the country
and more than 100 cities and states and
dozens of religious institutions and now
it's even going globally they are
demanding that their institutions take
action to divest from the top 200
companies that own the vast majority of
the world's carbon reserves and begin to
think about how to reinvest that money
we're at a point where
we don't have a lot of time to just get
comfortable with Recycling and changing
our light bulbs so we have to take a lot
bigger steps and we have to demonstrate
to the status quo the business as usual
industries that we we're not going to
take it anymore so we modeled this
fossil fuel development movement on the
movement to divest from apartheid South
Africa that was in the 1980s and that
movement convinced over 150 colleges and
universities and dozens of cities and
states to ultimately take some form of
action to divest and it had a real
impact it both convinced the U.S to take
a stronger position on South Africa and
showed a lot of support for the
anti-apartheid activists there so much
so that when Nelson Mandela was freed
from prison and did his first
international trip the first place he
went wasn't to the US Congress it wasn't
to the White House it was to the
University of California in Berkeley to
thank students there for their role in
the divestment movement our hope is that
this fossil fuel divestment movement can
have a similar impact we have to be off
carbon-based fuels off
within 30 years all over the world if we
have any hope of addressing the enormity
of the crisis facing our species and our
fellow creatures on this Earth I mean at
this point there's not even much mystery
about I mean we've raised the
temperature one degree
that melted the Arctic okay I mean we've
lost 80 percent of the sea ice in the
summer Arctic that should um be a little
warning we're going to go to two degrees
and even if we do everything right
probably that's some
it's going to be a lot worse we're
already losing major physical features
of the planet but if we go
where the scientists tell us we will
unless we get off coal and gas and oil
right away up to four or five degrees
well we can't have a civilizations like
the ones we're used to having so our job
is just to keep it from getting
completely out of control the latest
report from the intergovernmental panel
on climate change concluded that in
order to stop global warming and avoid
catastrophic impacts we only have a
limited amount of carbon that we can
Emit and it's called the carbon budget
we've already emitted uh you know
hundreds of gigatons of carbon dioxide
into the atmosphere and now we only have
a couple hundred gigatons left we're
going to burn through that budget in as
close to the next 14 years if we don't
take action what that means is that
these fossil fuel companies are going to
need to leave in the ground 60 to 80
percent of their known reserves of coal
oil and gas that doesn't even include
the all the new reserves that they're
spending hundreds of millions of dollars
a day to go find if these companies are
forced by governments to leave those
reserves underground it will have a
major impact on their share price think
about it a company like Peabody Coal
it's only worth what it is because it
has committed to the market that it can
dig up this coal and burn it once we
start regulating these companies that
share price will drop quickly and that's
what's known as the carbon bubble these
companies are massively overvalued and
continuing to invest in them poses a
real risk to Big institutional investors
like the city of San Francisco or like a
big university so what all this means
and what all these new reports are
showing is that divesting from fossil
fuels isn't just the right thing to do
is to financially prudent thing to do
and I keep waiting for 25 years for the
fact that the scientists the economists
and the engineers and everybody else
were
telling our leaders that we were facing
the biggest problem in the world I kept
waiting for some action no action came
and the reason is that the fossil fuel
industry has a hammerlock on Washington
and a lot of other capitals too
and unless we can weaken their power
then we're never going to get done the
things we need to get done and the time
we need to get them done if you think
about what the fossil fuel model of
electricity has caused it's this
concentration of wealth and power the
the control of a very important service
in society in the hands of a few the
influence of fossil fuel lobbies and
their money in politics and we're going
to break that hold over our democracy
and we're going to take the power back
in a literal and a figurative sense so
yes it has that potential to be
revolutionary whether or not it is is up
to the people
[Music]
foreign
and witnessing 350s divestment Movement
we realized how critical Our Moment in
history really is
how do we convince the most powerful
companies in the world to stop burning
fossil fuels and to help save the planet
[Music]
we were overwhelmed by the magnitude of
the situation
A change this large almost seems
impossible
so we went to our teacher Joanna Macy to
get her perspective on the psychological
and philosophical implications of our
moment and how we should move forward
despite the difficulties we're facing
of course you're confronted when you see
this with both we can do it
and then about will we do it
are we capable of waking up and seeing
where we are
I think that every one of the
leaders and
Heroes that I admire doing so much of
the planet they have these doubts too I
have these doubts too how could we not
there has never been a time
where so much Destruction has been
Unleashed on our planet as a whole
[Music]
whole species whole ecosystems whole
cultures are winking out
how could we not with all our uh
Goodwill and everything with all our
Visions not also be assailed with
heartbreaking doubts so
they'll get used to it yeah
they're gonna be there the whole time
I've had to get used to it because the
Miracle is this
that you care so deeply
you're giving your heart and your mind
and your life to addressing it
so you just keep on going
remember the poem from rilca that I
quoted in class
where he says uh
let everything happen to you
Beauty and Terror
just keep going no feeling is final
so that's the real Beauty you feel the
doubts you feel the grief and you just
keep going you know Paul Hawkins and
blessed unrest reminds us
that never has there been at the
Grassroots level in all countries
more initiatives
sprouting up
more organizations more campaigns more
people linking arms to uh
look for renewable ways and to resist
oppression
and that this isn't to hear the ancient
teachings of the indigenous people and
to harness the latest science
and we're calling that the great turning
and how can I agree with him when he
says this is the largest social movement
in human history
I am convinced that the great turning
is the Great Adventure of our time
scientific cultural technical all of it
can participate where Humanity takes a
Quantum Leap into a Cooperative
unfolding of our vision
[Music]
foreign
Joanna was right we are part of the
largest social movement in history
we are witnessing the emergence of a
participatory Universe where everyone
has a chance to co-create our world
in the old Paradigm energy and
information were centralized and
controlled from the top down
in the new paradigm energy is created
locally and shared laterally from within
each community
energy is not the only part of this
transition
perhaps the greatest example of lateral
power is the internet which allows us to
connect and mobilize in amazing ways
other examples include crowdfunding
platforms like Indiegogo
local food movements like farmers
markets and food co-ops
and new collaborative education models
that are emerging around the world
leading this shift towards lateral power
is green for all one of the most
Innovative Community organizations in
the country
green for all is a National Organization
we were founded to develop an inclusive
green economy strong enough to live
people out of poverty and so we really
work with communities all over the
country to focus on solutions from the
Grassroots up and to really redesign how
our economy functions so that it not
only protects and respects the
environment but that it serves people we
have to do the work to ensure that as we
build it it's not built in the same old
way where the same people that got the
jobs get the jobs and the same people
that were locked out the poor people the
communities of color that were locked
out of that economy are locked out of
this one we have to make sure that it's
done in a way that it's really can be
transformative for everybody but also
the communities who haven't had any
economic benefit from this industry they
need to be made whole too they need to
be able to make their communities
healthy with jobs with affordable
housing with health care with education
that's accessible to their kids so all
that is possible with a transition to
renewable energy
that is local that is locally and
democratically controlled and that
allows resources to be produced in
communities and stay in communities and
be controlled by those communities
[Music]
star school stands for service to Hall
relations service to all relations comes
from the Navajo culture this is the
first school in the United States to be
totally Off the Grid so for 13 years
we've been powering this school on solar
and wind energy that energy is stored in
batteries and 90 to 95 percent of our
energy comes from solar and wind power
we teach our children about solar energy
and wind energy through our Science
Education here at the school and they
learned that along with other
sustainable practices such as gardening
and Horticulture which is indigenous to
the area
you want to talk about energy let's talk
about food
I moved into this house and it was a
garden full of dead grass in the middle
of urbanized Oakland but what we did was
we had some Garden parties and we ripped
up all the grass and helped amend the
soil and now we Harvest for two years
we've harvested a lot of food from the
garden it's given us organic produce and
saved us money and helped offset carbon
in the environment and create homes for
the birds and the bees and it might seem
like just a garden but it's actually a
really powerful piece of land to help
the world heal itself so yeah I would
say it's worth it the part of growing
food at home and composting is the
Energy savings because if I go down to
Vons and buy some food that came from
another hemisphere like it was grown
there and then it had to get shipped
here and then and then distributed to
the stores and then I buy it and it's
just really it's really energy intensity
intensive and it sacrifices the quality
of the foods whereas here I can come out
and just like find a lemon that's really
ripe right now and pick that and it's
going to be a really good lemon and it
didn't have to get trucked anywhere
think about the last meal you had and do
you know where the ingredients came from
and I realized that I had I couldn't
name where a single one came from the
let alone the farm the state the country
even when you're considering buying
something that grew 1500 miles or came
from your own garden that's offsetting
carpet footprint so much right there you
got the bike power you know saying
making sure people know they are the
juice they are the power and then we're
actually providing just like fresh
nutrients you know phytonutrients juice
smoothies elixirs tonics and hiring
people from the community as well and
eventually we bring it in as a re-entry
program folks are previously
incarcerated too so then the compost
goes to local organizations they'll be
working with too so we're just one of
those stations we're a product of
looking at the social entrepreneurship
movement we're a product of the green
jobs movement we're a product of the
Black Panthers we're a product of like
indigenous Shamanism all of that when we
fuel ourselves differently and give
ourselves a different feel we actually
see different possibilities we can dream
further we can dream deeper we can
imagine things that we couldn't imagine
because what we're talking about here is
Shifting your vibration right you're
actually raising a vibration then you're
able to actually remember exactly who
you are and that's exactly what you're
talking about the future energy is
actually remembering exactly who we are
as human beings and actually being
stories of this Earth and stewards of
future communities
we can't hear the chunks of ice because
that's when you know you got a smooth
smooth so that's some juice right here
in the building One Stop Shop to
transform the whole entire planet with
just four elements a solar panel
you use a charge controller a battery
and if you use an inverter you can have
electricity off the grid without having
being involved you then have control of
your own power and if you've got control
of your own power you've got control of
your life the student movement here and
throughout the world is really showing
the way and it makes sense because
they're the inheritors of this Earth and
they're the ones who are going to Bear
the brunt of climate change if we don't
get our act together and they're also
the ones who are going to get who are
going to get to tell their children that
you know what we took action when we
needed to we saw the writing on the wall
we banded together and we did the work
that needed to be done and they'll be
the ones who really lead us towards you
know a sustainable World a resilient
world a world where Justice comes first
people in the planet comes first and
profit comes after that because I think
there's a younger generation around the
world that is
basically upending the old Gestalt and I
think more and more organizations around
the country especially environmental
organizations are recognizing that we
need a trans-local approach an approach
that is grounded in community where
where the the issues and solutions that
are coming from Community groups from
from Neighbors from young people is
informing what we do at the national
level this is an environmental issue
it's a human issue it's also about
learning about Civic engagement
leadership the kids when they go home
and start to take action with their
parents they're leading the family
across the country organizations like
powershift cool the earth and the
alliance for climate education are
getting students actively involved in
the larger climate discussion
we met with a group of young leaders to
share with them what we had learned
about the climate crisis here's what
they had to say
I never really thought I thought of it
as
like this big
now I realized that you know we're doing
this to our own world and if we keep it
up then we're really going to destroy
ourselves Some Humans just don't believe
in global warming they don't believe in
that our planet is getting hotter they
don't believe that the ice caps are
melting and I think something really
needs to show them they need to be more
aware of it and I think that's one of
the biggest problems is that people need
to believe in this this thing that's
happening right now that is the first
step realizing that we as a Humanity
have done wrong and that we need to
change our ways is the first step to go
and that now if we all realize that and
work together we can change it I was
just thinking that if a huge meteor was
gonna come and smash into Earth all the
humans would be trying really really
hard and be doing everything they could
to make it stop
I don't understand why we're all not
trying to make it stop if everybody was
aware of this issue and wanted to stop
it with tons of passion then I think
that would be very good for the
environment and that would help but
everybody doesn't know about it and
everybody's not trying their hardest to
make it better so we have to get people
to try their hardest to make it better
but I feel that everyone who lived in
the past never knew about climate change
or all the babies that throw their toys
on the floor and break their plastic
toys which is a waste now because that
goes with the trash they did something
bad but did they know that they were
hurting the environment no but if you
learn it and learn that you're doing
something bad and then do it again that
is when it becomes wrong the young
people across this planet are beginning
to think of themselves as an extended
Human family
and beginning to see our fellow
creatures as part of that family I am
hopeful that a younger generation is
going to be able to move this journey
to a empathic civilization embedded in a
great biosphere community so we can let
life flourish again on this little Earth
that we live in climate change and the
energy crisis puts it into perspective
the way that we as human beings have
been evolving over time and how this
moment is our opportunity to to like
take that next evolutionary thrust and I
can't think of a better way to live my
life than being in partnership with
young people to create this incredible
future that that is is unknown and
exciting and and the next Frontier of
our human imagination we are witnessing
the emergence of a new planetary
Consciousness a new vision for Humanity
itself
it's a vision that reconnects us to the
living systems that brought us here in
the first place
and reminds us that we are stewards of
this planet active members of this Earth
community
we find ourselves at a critical point in
history
where the future of the planet rests
upon the choices we make today
we now have a plan to move away from
fossil fuels and rebuild our society to
use a hundred percent renewable energy
by implementing this plan we have the
opportunity to create millions of jobs
in an inclusive green economy
improve our health and well-being
and create a more secure future for our
families and communities
this is our time to be fully engaged
this is our time to cultivate the
greatest gifts we have to offer
and use them for the benefit of all
beings
the future of the world is in our hands
the question is what type of future will
we create
[Music]
never
happens to me show me a Saturday is
it crazy
yo yo show me a sign that the world
could be better than people on the
streets sleeping on the newspapers I'll
filled with celebrity news why
bankruptcy's gotta sing in the Blues
Blues yeah
I just wanna know why teams everywhere I
go that nobody knows how it answers
started standing in the lines of the
Brokenhearted it's just so hard to make
it on your own but you
[Music]
I wanna know I wanna know when you're
coming home send me a picture on your
telephone and say hey
[Music]
oh the crazy
all dictators
everywhere taking it to the streets
throw your hands in the air if you know
what I mean Wall Street criminals some
of them politicals stealing money off of
people in the strawberries everywhere on
this planet I see people fighting back
from Humanity yeah I hold my camera's so
far away so I
picture of the world today I wanna know
I wanna know when you're coming home
[Music]
access the financial World On Demand
foreign hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
scientists predict the small nation of
kiribat will be one of the world's first
countries to disappear as a result of
climate change
well our Villages is covered with water
there is no dry ground here
so that there is a great
disaster here
our future is actually being it's
written
it's written on the wall that the sea
level will rise and it will affect our
islands and so the International
Community cannot ignore that
[Music]
in the middle of the Central Pacific and
spread over 33 Coral atolls kiribas is
home to 105 000 people living an average
two meters above sea level
how long will they survive the rising
tide
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
so I want to I want to introduce our
next speaker
team on I first found out about kiribats
through Maria Simon
Maria has been living in Sydney for two
years but karabasas where her family
lives and the place she calls home
the flying Islands please make a very
welcome
to visit my mom who was not well
life is very difficult
my own father said
Maria I know that I'm getting old
and I will not be here when this
happened but my heart goes to the Young
Generation and my grandchildren
how long would they survive
where would they be in the future
there are many people who don't even
know where kittypus is
it's very frustrating when you want to
tell the world what is really happening
to your people
we are talking about the lives of people
the lives of human beings and this is
what I'm I'm passionate about Maria
worked for a non-government organization
the Edmund rice Center and was part of a
team preparing for the Copenhagen
climate conference
the outcome of the conference will be
critical for the fate of low-lying
Ireland States like Kiribati I'm very
eager to to to be out there and to tell
the the world leaders about my people
related to Copenhagen we want to be
communicating with as many Community
groups as we possibly can with schools
with ngos who said the most Australians
wears kiribus some may know Kiribati but
they want no curabester and they won't
know where it is so that's part of the
reason why we've got to get the word out
you know they're lots of ways Maria I
mean you can tell a story that no one
else can
foreign
exchange but they don't know what causes
it
especially our older people even my dad
they kept asking like why this is all
happening and why the heat is getting
hotter and harder while life is getting
um difficult it seemed a big step from
this one Sydney school to get the story
out to the world
get you involved in these three clubs
like one two three but I had the feeling
that Maria was up to the challenge okay
can we do it now
now
thank you
[Music]
I come from a very big family
and we are very close to each other
I miss my parents very much
my dad has not been well
my mom is very ill and that is my worry
that
being here in Australia I might not be
able
to say goodbye to her
times I feel very lonely to be
here on my own while the rest of my
family are back in Canibus
[Music]
soon Maria's climate change work was to
take her back to Kiribati
but just days before leaving she
suddenly received a message that her
mother had passed away
[Music]
I was they decided to find out the news
my brother said Oh daddy wants all of
his children
beside him and
he wants you to come back right now
my family is my priority yeah my heart
is always there
[Music]
we're arriving on Maria's home island of
Peru
home to 2 000 people
Maria's been the only one of her 13
siblings to leave the island to continue
her education and make her life overseas
[Music]
thank you
very much
foreign
[Music]
we still haven't have a dad
my dad is a very tough father
he just worked as a fisherman and he
really worked hard for all of his kids
um unfortunately one of his food had
been amputated
my dad really encouraged all of us to go
to school and complete our studies
I guess I was the only one listening to
my dad
as we drive around the island it's easy
to see the impact of the year-long
drought on the breadfruit trees a staple
food source
and then Maria takes us to one of the
many villages where people have had to
move because of the rising tide
the woman died in 11.
good morning
foreign
for Maria it was very important to
explain the concept of climate change to
the younger generation
they'll be the ones affected for years
to come
[Applause]
dynamic
yeah yeah
remember
[Music]
um our trip to beru has coincided with
celebrations marking the anniversary of
dementier the center of social life of
the whole village
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
Linda is organizing the Kiribati
government Side Event at Copenhagen
the conference is now less than five
weeks away
it is
foreign
yeah
come today
Linda and her partner John Anderson are
making an official DVD for the
conference
it's one of scores of sponsored videos
they've made educating local people and
taking the images of kiribus to the
world
good is one of our key National icons
the national bird of kiribas
the storytelles of a bird flying the
ocean in search of food for its young
on her return she finds that her
Homeland has disappeared beneath the
waves
this Prophecy from the past reminds us
of the uncertain future we face as a
country and as a people
foreign
[Music]
the worst high tide we ever had was
three years ago
we were standing here and waves were
just coming
over from the Lagoon onto our land our
sea wall was being eaten away
it went right through our house we
worked overnight during when that tide
was starting to go out we quickly had to
mix cement so that we can at least
strengthen some of the um the worst hit
areas of the sea wall it was really
really scary
some parts of the island never properly
recovered from the storm
sea walls protecting many communities
were destroyed
though they were repaired they ended up
being wrecked again and again but a
combined impact of tide and storm
Linda takes us to one of the communities
that have been severely affected
people from the outer Islands settled
here 30 years ago
it was one of the last places left on
overcrowded Tarawa
though
let's see warm smashed up
and that's when the water starts coming
in but we need the wall
to raise up a little bit all the way
across and
very urgent because the people are very
affected with these damage that we have
now
we once have a well by one of the house
back then
and the well was covered with water
and so that there is a grading
disaster here
it's very quick now it's coming up here
this is my house now my house was there
where the water is now between those
plants here to here
and now it's a
I see
they say that today it will be much
higher than yesterday so that we are
expecting the
we are expecting this classroom to be
flooded some of the houses to be flooded
to an advantage of having these flood is
place is very clean of the Woods
the waves takes away the rubbish
as a government Wicked a lot of requests
for
protection against the sea water
we try as best as we can but we don't
have the resources to deal with this
you just got a feel for these people
because
they they are being affected
and to feel that there is nothing we can
do
about it it's it's extremely it's
frustrating
our future is actually being it's
written
it's written on the wall that the sea
level will rise and it will affect our
violence and so the International
Community cannot ignore that
[Music]
back in Sydney and it's only a week
before Maria leaves for Copenhagen
[Music]
um just spending a little bit but I'm
all right yeah
what's your biggest worry
I don't know
I'm just stressed right now with yay
Murray is a member of one of many
non-government delegations trying to
influence the outcome of the official
talks so if we have four or five things
you need to get we want to say in each
interview or each person you speak to
you get those across and the question is
really oh perhaps but let me say this
right and then you go we launch into
what Julia the stuff that Julia was just
saying accompanying the Pacific calling
partnership delegation is Maria's boss
Phil glendenning in terms of the
Copenhagen my hopes would be this is
another beginning of a long-term process
the group is pressing for a legally
binding treaty to cut emissions to keep
global warming below 1.5 degrees
Centigrade
even the rise of two degrees would spell
disaster to caribass and it's even
smaller neighbor to the lou so the
question now is as we leave um with with
great hope and expectation
uh the only question is to you know will
the politicians actually be up to it
will they be able to follow through on
the promises that have been made
[Music]
Copenhagen but also see for
constructiveness c for a corporation and
hopefully in the end C for commitment
and consensus
We Gather for a colonic office and
they've already they've already lost
we've already lost curabest in tibulu I
haven't made it to the map
curability on the equator
it's not big
we hope this isn't a globe as it would
look in 70 years time and just just a
mistake this is our chance if we miss
this one it could take years before we
get a new and better one let's get it
done and let it get done now
the tiny caribus government budget means
that John and Linda have had to stay two
hours out of town
on top of that to cut costs dances for
the official presentation have had to be
canceled
at the last minute Linda has asked Maria
to help out
[Music]
okay
foreign
must now prepare Maria for something
she's never done before at such a major
event
[Music]
s
foreign
I think she's doing it because
she's needed it's not easy to actually
um
decline
yeah
[Music]
thank you very much
foreign
[Music]
conference
will directly affect the future
my country
in our people
and we call
on the global community
to take action now
for the sake of the most vulnerable
countries
[Music]
thank you
our end goal is to maintain the one
point or well below 1.5 degrees Celsius
so any Target that will contribute to
that is what we're asking for anything
beyond that will mean the two degrees
Celsius increase and that's that is
traffic for us
thank you
tuvalu has asked for the flow
I don't want to cause embarrassment to
you or the government
but I want to have this issue considered
properly
I clearly want to have the leaders put
before them an option for considering a
legally binding agreement for them to
sign on at this meeting
I make this as a strong and impassioned
plea
we've had our proposal on the table for
six months
six months it's not the last two days of
this meeting
tuvalu supported by Kiribati and 41
other low-lying Ireland States has
proposed a framework for a new legally
binding treaty
not only developed but developing
countries would be forced to make the
permission cuts to keep global
temperatures from rising above 1.5
degrees the island sticks as a sentinel
of the world we are the first to go
the problem is that fast industrializing
Nations like India and China are
strongly at odds with what Tupelo is
proposing
the island states are coming under
enormous pressure to withdraw their bid
this morning according to the negotiator
Canberra apparently called up somebody
in fortnite the powers that be and said
please tell your boys in Copenhagen to
ease off
back down and not push for illegal
funding legally binding documents
can you imagine they have actually gone
from Canberra Canberra has actually
called up probably the prime minister's
office or Foreign Affairs and said can
you talk to Ian not to do this
some other specific Island allegations
are shocked to think that Australia has
taken that position but when it comes to
the pursuit it goes to our backyard
and um
you know to be to be heavy in Google at
this stage
no sorry 132 Nations have supported the
position until all of you 132 Nations
um and what they're calling for is a
plea for them to survive a two meter
will rise in sea level
they're out of business they're gone
[Music]
what's happening at cop15 is the death
of democracy
it's an attempt to undo 20 years of work
on a legally binding agreement
shots the Earth will write the rules
[Music]
[Applause]
it's not about what degree or but it's
all about human rights it's all about
Justice
and it's all about giving us a place on
this side
the question is what will become of us
our children and our children students
because 50 percent
of our population is under 15 years old
we love our country and we just want
the Civil Society and world leaders to
see us as human beings and give us a
fair deal
how do you save the world
sorry how do you save the world
I think we've done enough
I think we've done enough for today
yeah this is how the world's going to
solve its problems
I think we're in trouble
[Music]
the conference fails to agree on a
legally binding treaty but in the dying
minutes adopt a non-binding Accord
asking Nations to pledge carbon emission
reductions
meanwhile Kiribati and other least
developed Nations have been promised a
30 billion dollar fund to help them
adapt to the impact of climate change
but how fast will the money flow
it doesn't matter whether we show them
the effects and impact on video or say
it through our songs or say through our
slides and presentations
the people that we are talking to are
deaf and they're dumb and they're also
blind they don't understand a syllable
of what we have been saying
I return to a very different Tower
a severe storm combined with the feared
Westerly wind has caused a lot of damage
and in a week the annual spring king
tide is due
foreign
[Music]
the cement
yeah this is our boys our boys uh this
is what they did mixing cement
and then put it in sex
and then go put it on the sewer
thank God that there wasn't any waves
last night because of no wind once we
have the wind coming from the the North
and the West that's when we have these
big waves coming and it's just climbing
up the wall and into the houses and
which is a big problem
it is sad
sad to know that people laugh
suffering
because of somebody
enjoying what they're doing
and uh
well
we know the good Lord knows what is
better for us
and he will help us
[Music]
we're going to have another very high
tide this afternoon
but what is that
we'll continue to pray that the Lord
will give us this good hand and protect
our place
protect us our lives and our little ones
I want you people to continue praying
that the Lord will
Save Our Place praise the Lord
looks like it needs
cool
to me to higher than this
we need to make it higher
to add another two layer of sandbags
and
it needs more Center to pack it up from
over this side
we have to ask ourselves the question
if um half a meter
Horizon sea level is projected we're
gonna have a lot of problems
um we've got our unfortunately our
islands are scattered all over the place
so the next question we have to ask do
we build up all of the islands or we
build up just a few and if so which ones
okay so these are the many many complex
issues that we have to deal with
and I can guarantee you
the cost is going to be in the billions
and billions of dollars
well ideally what we want to see happen
is that we we would still be
and we would have a nation of Kirby's
with a culture
people
to carry on being part of this Global
community
even the current projections the the
prospects of that happening are becoming
very much diminished
as much as we would like to deny the
reality I think we as responsible
leaders we have to accept the reality
there may come a day when we have to
look at the option of relocation
prayers on her way back to Kiribati
she's accompanying a delegation of
community leaders led by indigenous
Elder Pat Dodson
it's all part of Phil's strategy to get
the story of Kiribati out to a wider
community
[Music]
foreign
Patrick Dodson uh and and the people
from the Kimberley
who've heard the needs of the indigenous
peoples of the Pacific
and are going
to sort of leadership we don't see in
politics
[Music]
we'll put it all to try and remain on
our country are very warm welcome once
again
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
the
trees used to be way out there and they
just died bit by bit
over there is a swampy um land that used
to be a buffet pit pop-out pit is one of
our main food crops here
um as you can see it's all Barren at the
moment because
um at the the high tide and the water
salt water got into there and ruined the
crops
we're just trying to introduce them to
Mango planting at the moment
it's a peninsula of an overnight side
where they are suffering quite severe
erosion
so what we've done here is designed the
siebel for um
the next 50 years of sea level rise
I've been filming for over a year now
and it's the first time that I've seen
major Coastal Protection work being
carried out here we identified that the
erosions very close to the road so it's
really trying to protect the major
infrastructure of Tarawa but we
identified 15 sites similar sites to
this unfortunately we've only got
funding to do for this time
finally critical adaptation funds have
started to flow
but these funds have come out of
existing Aid budgets
so what about the 11 projects that
couldn't be funded
whatever happened to the 30 billion
dollars pledged by the major emitters
back in Copenhagen
[Music]
thank you
well let me welcome you I I heard you'd
come last week we've really just come to
um
express our solidarity with with you in
in new fight we admired the leadership
uh from afar in Copenhagen we were
disappointed and felt with you very much
when the other nations they took a
different View and particularly our own
country
for quite a long time I didn't sleep
because I didn't know what to say to the
people because I had nothing to say I
mean ended up with the onslaught of this
threat and I said you know what kind of
a leader could have nothing to say on
this issue to the people but I thought
it through for a long long time and
eventually I went back to the cabinet
and
so we mapped up the scenario that we
have to deal with this issue on a on a
Time relevant basis so in the long term
we have to prepare our people
for the eventual possibility of
relocation
but relocation does not begin then it
begins now relocating our people but
with dignity so how do we do that
upskill them train them and prepare them
for that
we have to assume the West
while the delegation returns to
Australia Maria sets out for Peru
she's just found out that her father's
been taken ill
a young policeman she met last time she
was in Tarawa and has been developing a
relationship with on the internet since
[Music]
following tradition Maria needs to
introduce chifa to her father
[Music]
come on
ironic
foreign
[Music]
is like all of Kiribati getting steadily
worse
and Maria is gathering the evidence
important conferences are coming up
[Music]
foreign
I actually had the opportunity to go
back to my home Island where I was born
which is called Peru and I was really
surprised to see a lot of changes there
was a used to be a place that my dad
used to take a family to that very point
where would we would have a family
picnic and enjoy the day but now sadly
it's all gone disappeared and I was
really surprised because I left kidibess
and spent my life 11 to 12 years
overseas but when I went back a lot of
changes had been happening as a result
of climate change
when I had an interview my dad with my
dad I said to him dad now I live in
Australia
would you rather come and live with me
in Australia my dad said
I was born here I grew up here
and I'd rather die here
we are among the most vulnerable of the
vulnerable
the entire nation faces real Danger
it's not just about relocation or
migrating people to a safer place
climate change is about
human rights and justice
again another Triumph
tonight
foreign
[Music]
hahaha
I think I want to like
[Music]
we would love to get married in kiribes
because all of our families and friends
are there
after the wedding we hope that chiffon
will eventually come and live with me in
Australia and start our family
[Music]
at the same time
I have to support my family back at home
[Music]
I committed to this job because I know
that my people are benefiting out of it
I'm more confidential I'm more confident
to speak out and to talk about climate
change and human rights and justice for
our own people
the issue is very complex and it's very
sad that world leaders are an audience
listening to our voices
[Music]
I won't stop to shout on behalf of my
country
[Music]
Roy
foreign
[Music]
they're losing battle no no no
I talk about with quite a lot of
families
and they're
indication is that they want to move out
and that's for the sake of their
children
you know and but the question is now
where would they go
and so all they can go is to the next
Island which is the next island in the
Pacific in kiribus will have the same
problem
[Music]
s
foreign
bigger countries
so
people of the islands can move to their
higher places
and I think those are about the only
options that we're looking at
uh high places like uh New Zealand
Australia
some parts of Europe Asia or the United
States somewhere there now if those
people can have mercy on these people
they
that would be the answer
it is sickening and uh
said
because this is what we will face
it is a hungry time
[Music]
foreign
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
well hello there come on in it's hot out
here come on
welcome to Waldorf Astoria Maldives
Stella Maris Village one of two Villas
that are only reachable by boat I don't
know where to begin it's probably the
nicest hotel Villa I've ever stayed at
foreign
[Music]
made up of over 1200 islands in the
Indian Ocean the Maldives is unlike any
other place on Earth with countless
white sand beaches and world-class scuba
diving this was my fifth trip to the
Maldives and while I was still eager to
book a Points Hotel this time I was
after something a little extra special
the Waldorf Astoria Maldives itafushi
I could have booked a base Villa but
since I was traveling halfway across the
world for a very special occasion I
decided to splurge on the enormous
two-story Stella Maris Ocean Villa
[Music]
so we just touched down in vallana
airport in the Maldives the main
Island's kind of a hustle bustle City
we're going to take a 30 to 45 minute
Yachts ride because this boat ride costs
800 and change per person round trip and
no you cannot rent your own cheaper boat
and go to the island with the Maldives
nothing is cheap so even if you get a
room on points the seaplane or boat
transfer can cost you an arm and a leg
but you'll see why it's worth it when we
get there
[Music]
unfortunately even if you book on points
there's only one way to get to the
Waldorf Astoria Maldives from the
airport
[Music]
come on
oh it's kind of like the residence
you may have to pay 800 for this
50-minute boat ride but I think you
should get a life left
it's factored in the cost of going and
don't go to sleep over it there's no way
to get this cost down
I guess you could try parachuting onto
the island I've read some interesting
threats I mean it is crazy to think a
15-minute ride it's like 900 but
like
got a plan for it
[Music]
it's got a little bit of rain but that's
something you need to get used to in the
Maldives
[Music]
the end is so close I cannot wait to
unwind
many Resort Islands choose to set their
clocks an hour ahead of male to
capitalize on the evening light so even
though our boat ride from the airport
was just under an hour we arrived at the
resort nearly two hours later for 2.2
million points a night the Stella Maris
Ocean Villa is not a valuable points
redemption but if you want to splurge
this is how you do it are you kidding me
I don't even need to see it that's
amazing from a bar
[Music]
wow
this is insane
[Music]
what do you think
uh you know you can go upstairs
we're not leaving
[Music]
oh my gosh
I'm speechless so if you could talk that
would be great
[Music]
what I like about Waldorf Astoria
is the technology so everything
at the resort excursions from diving a
dolphin cruise Sunset fishing which I am
going to do our concierge Camille is
reachable with one touch at all times
and she is here to make our stay amazing
and we've got
this and that
you can't even
oh I have to jump to get it but that's
not it
we also have the
outdoor which
tight
[Music]
come on
out here we've got
our own Grill which they were like you
really can't use you got to get a chef
I'm sure it's not inexpensive
they've got some juice machines Frozen
cocktails once again you have to kind of
hire a bartender to use them
[Music]
while it was tempting to spend all day
at the Stella Maris Villa I knew I had
to get some underwater experiences
we are here in the Maldives George's
second dive after being certified look
how beautiful that is learning about
let's go diving
[Music]
for 165 dollars a person you can book
scuba trips that will let you explore
incredible marine life just minutes away
from the resort
[Music]
while they offer certification classes
make sure to get scuba certified before
your trip you'll save a ton of money and
you won't waste valuable Maldives time
in a classroom
the Waldorf Astoria Maldives itafushi
offers world-class luxury experiences
for guests of all skill sets and does an
incredible job customizing experiences
to their guests wishes we splurged our
last day and chartered a boat to go out
with Emma the Resort's amazing marine
biologist to check out one of my
favorite animals sharks
foreign
[Music]
After experiencing the sweetness of the
maldivian nurse sharks we stumbled
across a heartbreaking scene an olive
Ridley sea turtle that was stuck in a
fishing net turtle is caught and we are
going to save him save the turtle
Emma acted fast and we helped to save
its life with a detour to the Malay sea
turtle Hospital
foreign
T great to give back to the sea that
gave us so much
our underwater workouts also made it
easier to justify going all out with our
meals most resorts in the Maldives only
offer a couple of restaurants but not
the case here the Waldorf has 11 dining
options from the wine Rock to the
Treetops to Peking duck no matter what
you want you'll never get tired of the
food
oh it's so nice and cold
after diving all day we were starving
for our exclusive booking at the rock
this is a cool way to end a trip
dinner was served around a 200 year old
jarrow wood table in a cave-like dining
room built from Jordanian limestone
it's amazing to be in the middle of the
Indian Ocean but feeling transported to
the Middle East
there's no getting around the fact that
the Maldives is an expensive place to
visit but it doesn't have to cost as
much as you might think for a
points-friendly trip to the Waldorf
Astoria Maldives you can book a
beautiful Reef Villa with private pool
for 120 000 points per night compared
with the more than 2 000 you'll pay if
you're booking with cash including tax
and if you're a Hilton Honors elite
member you'll get the fifth award night
for free which increases the value per
point on the Redemption
[Music]
which comes as a perk of the Hilton
Aspire card you could even score a space
available room upgrade to the Grand Reef
Villa and if you want to guarantee that
overwater Villa you can pay in advance
by contacting the hotel
the Waldorf also includes a bunch of
other surprise and Delight benefits as
well including complimentary welcome
champagne and an additional 30 minutes
when you book a 60-minute massage
foreign
Diamond members also get complimentary
breakfast each morning which normally
cost 60 dollars a person on a five night
stay for two people that really adds up
[Music]
after you
you'll definitely want to get Hilton
Honors Elite status before your Waldorf
Astoria Maldives stay it's not goodbye
it's see you later
but fortunately it's pretty easy to earn
if you know how to play your cards
you'll automatically receive Hilton
Diamond status with the Hilton Honors
American Express Aspire card or gold
status with the American Express
Platinum Card if you decide to splurge
and book with cash instead of points I
definitely recommend paying with the
Aspire card
and saving a turtle we saved a turtle on
vacation you'll earn a combined 20
return based on my valuation of Hilton
points with the 20 points per dollar
from your diamond status and 14 points
per dollar spent on Hilton's days with
the Aspire card
whether you go on points or cash you
need to visit the Maldives it's by far
the ultimate in luxury
and by the way that special experience
that I came to the Maldives for
turned out to be a huge success
he said yes
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
World On Demand
foreign hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
On Solid Ground you're not quite Solid
ground but
it's the same place
and here is the JW Marriott which will
be home for the next three nights
[Music]
we are not messing around to begin with
I'm in my Island Ferrari with Ari who
claims he has a license but he's driving
like a lunatic around these uh around
these Island bends
um what an incredible welcome I've just
been told that I've been upgraded to a
beach Villa so let's see what that's
like but so far this has been pretty
special
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is the main bedroom it's a wide
open space loads of room table and
chairs over here and like a cool seating
area here now look at this I've got
snacks for days this is my little
welcome treat look at that it's like
four separate wardrobes here all filled
with different goodies so there's
dressing gown and
umbrella iron ironing board in here I've
got bags you can use in a safe sewing
kit and stuff and in here slippers and
flip-flops and shoe cleaning products
into the bathroom
there is a gorgeous big bath to get into
double sink one over here
and one over here
so there's big sliding doors that go out
onto the uh Terrace
out here there is an outdoor shower
a beautiful swimming pool a chill out
area
some beds over here doors that go out
into the main room and this
my little private section of these
unbelievable
okay I'm gonna do one of the coolest
things now that's a little bit different
and it is a treehouse so we're going to
go up here and in the tree house is a
restaurant there's all little nooks and
crannies where you can eat and this is
called rum bar and it's the
bar in the tree house but there's also
hi it was meant to be an incredible Thai
restaurant the Thai restaurant is called
Kashi how many rums have you got
98 runs in Rumba the treehouse this is
the funnest bit right here
[Applause]
kind of
rope bridge in the tree house love it
and we're gonna eat right at the top
it's hot
this is going to be where I'm gonna have
my lunch
how cool
is that
foreign
[Music]
experience is to dive and Diving is
excellent from the dive shop right here
especially because it's so quiet here
there aren't many divers and actually
today they've told me if I go out I can
have a one-on-one experience with an
instructor and be alone in the water
which is absolutely incredible so I'm at
the dive School I've seen the gear it's
looking brand new and fresh the hotel is
new to everything's new and sparkling
the boat is being loaded up here and
we're gonna go diving
foreign
[Music]
I brought down that was so cool we saw
two nurse sharks that were snuggled up
together inside a rock which was amazing
I saw some amazing nudie branches some
bright yellow white and black ones and
this amazing like green one as well and
it was really nice actually the diamond
instructor said that there wasn't a lot
of fish even though I thought there was
loads for now
I have to have a bit of sleep
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
I feel like the naughty one
thank you
so much
[Music]
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring just to see what's
moving the markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
thank you
so I'm here at the Westin it is hot it
is humid but you can't argue that it's
beautiful
[Music]
I just got to my beautiful Villa at the
Westin Maldives and I literally never
want to leave so I wanted to show you
guys a round of it there's a really
comfy little day bed slash couch
situation I really like the small dining
table they left out some amenities those
chocolate truffles are so good I may
have already had a few you know the
little things that I really appreciate
so I also really like this giant bar
situation there's an espresso machine
which is truly the key to my heart
there's not one but two mini bars so
here's the first one
has some beers some soda
and over here there's even more alcohol
some more snacks so you'll definitely
never go hungry or go thirsty here
pretty solid selection the other mini
bar is for wine which is totally
something I can get behind I feel like I
need one of these in my apartment
so really nice you know they really take
care of their guests and then last but
not least is my favorite part of the
whole villa which is the small private
pool
um so there's two lounge chairs and
again another like small couch slash
daybed situation it has a small private
beach and looks out into the ocean so
it's really pretty the weather is not
great today but that's okay it's still
beautiful
we have the most amazing breakfast
spread
omelette station bread pudding
thank you
need all of that a juice station some
yogurt staying carbohydrated over here
fruits
smoked salmon my fave like this room is
mattered and it's all food this is my
dream
s
I'm about to go parasailing I haven't
been in so long I'm super pumped and
going to uh take this little GoPro thing
with me
[Music]
I'm in the air this is insane I'm
literally flying look you could see all
these hotels
hello down there
look how beautiful this is it's so
pretty
views from up above you know
not too shabby
[Music]
it's time to leave very sad
because there's kind of bad weather
so Journey Begins
so overall I'd love to stay here service
was amazing it's very windy the service
is amazing and the hotel itself is
beautiful definitely a great use of your
Marriott points
um
it's not the most luxurious hotel that
you'll find I think that goes to St
Regis but a great place to come with
family or with significant other whether
on vacation or honeymoon and I know that
you will love you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
I'm here in the Maraca Suite which is
the famous
underwater Suite here at the Conrad
Maldives
so this Suite is 40
000 plus plus per night that is to say
it starts at forty thousand dollars but
with that you get a chef you get a
personal Butler and there's an exercise
room there's all kinds of stuff you get
with it but yeah forty thousand dollars
a night if you wanna sleep under here
the suite is absolutely insane I mean
look at it
so you got a little sitting room here so
you can just chill out
watch the fish
oh my favorite part
is here
so this toilet situation is pretty
insane and my favorite thing is when you
get close to it
it opens automatically look at that
this is your view
while you do your business under the sea
and then
stairway going all the way up
so the structure itself
was designed by an architect named Ahmed
Saleem and moraka means Coral in the
native language of the Maldives which is
divecki so it's named after the coral
reef that it sits upon I mean this is
just absolute Peak luxury it is huge and
spacious
you've got a spare forty thousand
dollars this doesn't seem like a bad way
to spend it
[Music]
[Applause]
so ether is the underwater restaurant of
the Maldives it was the first of its
kind and it's made by the same people
that did the Maraca Suite so it's pretty
cool you get to eat lunch with a bunch
of fish swimming over your head so uh
let's go check it out
[Music]
yeah you have to have a reservation to
get in and it's also a fixed price menu
so you get seven courses and they just
start feeding you
okay so this is the first course here it
is a snow crab and hamachi salad I don't
see any snow crabs around so hopefully
not
sending anybody
[Music]
for one person it came to 252 dollars I
wanted to get a glass of white wine and
the waiter said that it was a hundred
and fifty dollars
I passed on the glass of wine and just
stuck with still water and they still
got me for 45 dollars
for prices in the Maldives whatever you
think it's going to be it's gonna be
more
[Music]
foreign
World On Demand
foreign hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
it seems like overnight much of
humankind went from traveling more than
ever to a complete shutdown
it's clear that the travel industry can
grind to a halt overnight but can it
start back up just as quickly
while we're all stuck at home the
question on everyone's mind is when can
we travel again and what will it be like
when we do
[Music]
no one knows for sure what the future of
travel will be like in the wake of
covid-19 but we do have some Clues as to
what the major airlines are thinking in
the first week of April 2020 Delta
announced it was extending Elite status
for a year
other major airlines followed including
United and American
for example to get gold medallion status
on Delta typically you have to fly 50
000 miles in a calendar year and spend
six thousand dollars on flights with
Delta or its Partners under the new
rules you get to maintain your status
level automatically for an extra year
without needing to meet minimum travel
or purchase requirements that is great
news for frequent flyers but more
notably it signals when Airline
Executives expect air travel to take off
again so why is that important it means
major airlines are betting that most
people will not be traveling enough in
2020 to qualify for elite status a
couple other program extensions add to
the pile of Clues many airlines have
pushed the expiration dates for flight
vouchers and ticket credits by one year
Delta Airlines is waiving change fees
for new bookings until May 31st and
American announced that it will waive
them until September 30th United has
committed to waiving them until the end
of 2020. again these changes aren't just
about making it more convenient for
travelers
it shows when Airlines themselves expect
a man to return
it looks like that's not going to be
until fall 2020 at the earliest
the International Air transport
Association suggested that Airlines
won't see a full recovery until at least
2021.
okay so once we do start traveling again
what will it look like we've already
seen Airlines significantly increase
their sanitation process and work that
into their marketing cleaning crews have
increased the attention they give to
wiping down high-touch areas it's likely
Travelers will have an increased concern
for a sanitized travel experience even
after covid-19 is resolved
the travel experience outside the
aircraft could be different too with
more airports screening passengers for
temperatures other countries have
already implemented health screening
procedures and we may see a version of
this at U.S airports in the near future
we may also see an increase in countries
that demand proof that incoming
Travelers have immunizations like what
we see with the yellow fever vaccine
certifications in some parts of the
world
a major difference that Travelers will
notice immediately will be a sharp
decrease in flight time options and
direct flights
as Airlines slowly begin to ramp up
operations to meet returning demand
schedules will simply be less packed
for a while we'll just have to settle
for connecting flights that leave at
less convenient times
hopefully that change will just be
temporary until demand increases
any way you slice it
you're gonna have to adjust your summer
travel plans
while a European summer getaways will
likely need to be postponed for a year
some regions of the US might open up for
local exploring this summer may be the
time to hit the highway and get out into
nature
the U.S has a ton of incredible open
spaces and breathtaking natural wonders
trips to big cities might decrease but
we expect a summer surge to the fresh
air and Great Outdoors
ultimately we will get back to the skies
again
even if it is a little later than we
hoped for more info on when we can
travel again head over to the
pointsky.com
subscribe here for updates on the
changing travel situation
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
World On Demand
foreign
hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
or from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
Airlines receive the 50 billion dollar
Aid package they asked for but what's
really in it
with Revenue across the industry
dropping to zero in some cases without
help from the government many airlines
were doomed to fail while some costs
have diminished with route reductions
Airlines still have a slew of fixed
expenses on their books including
aircraft leases maintenance costs and
employee pay the bailout funds are not
free money they come with some serious
strings attached including measures that
prevent funds from going into investors
and guarantee that cities both big and
small stay connected
foreign
the major benefit is aimed at workers 25
billion in the relief package is going
to go to make sure about 750 000
employees don't get laid off a central
condition of the grants is Airlines must
not furlough staff and I have to
maintain current pay and benefits
through September 30th the goal is to
not just benefit Airline workers but
also their families and the overall
economy the funds will be divvied up
between carriers based on how much they
paid Staff last year between April 1st
and September 30th of 2019. the next
major provision make sure cities don't
have their service cut to qualify for
the bailout funds Airlines must maintain
a minimum level of service to cities
within the U.S the Department of
Transportation released these guidelines
that Define minimum levels of service
one cities served with five flights a
week would need to maintain at least one
flight per day five days a week
a practical example pre-corona American
Airlines flew hourly flights between New
York and Dallas if it maintains one
round-trip flight per day between the
two cities five days per week that would
meet the requirement for both New York
and Dallas
two cities with flights fewer than five
days a week would need to maintain at
least one flight per week if United's
only flight to Flagstaff were a round
trip between Denver and Flagstaff three
times a week the airline could reduce
that to one day per week three cities
with multiple routes could reduce those
routes as long as the minimums from
guidelines one and two were still met
Delta had multiple daily flights from
Green Bay Wisconsin to other cities
including Detroit Minneapolis and
Atlanta that service could be paired
down to a single flight at least five
times weekly between Green Bay and one
of the other cities such as Detroit
Delta could also choose to operate at
least five flights weekly from grb and
distribute them to among various
destinations so what this means
practically is that cities will never be
completely cut off there's always going
to be one or two flights now the amount
of direct flights and connecting flights
will be reduced sometimes dramatically
depending on the city
the rich won't get richer Airlines
cannot pay investor dividends or engage
in stock BuyBacks until one year after
the loans are repaid executive raises
and compensation are also limited so we
shouldn't see big bonuses like the ones
handed out by Banks bailed out in the
financial crisis of 2008. post Corona
airlines are likely to look a lot
smaller and a lot greener despite the 50
billion Aid package Airlines will no
doubt be forced to shrink while the
package will help Airlines stay in
business it does not cover the billions
of dollars in Lost Revenue the companies
must absorb in the months ahead routes
have been slashed by more than 70
percent in some cases it is unlikely we
will see post Corona route availability
surge back to pre-corona levels for
years Travelers might be stuck with more
connecting flights thousands of planes
have been grounded the older models will
likely be retired permanently American
Airlines for example has accelerated the
retirement date of its 757s and 767s
Delta will probably ground its md-80s
and md-90s for good a democratic version
of the bill would have enforced strict
environmental measures that was stripped
out of the final bill however the
retirement of older aircraft is likely
to mean a leaner and Greener Airline
Fleet going forward the gas guzzling
e190s and md-80s are likely to retire
early there are possible Replacements
the Airbus 220 or the Boeing 737 max if
it ever returns to the sky use 14 to 20
percent less fuel per passenger mile
while the economy will bounce back
travel will not be the same at least for
some time
it's quite likely that Leisure Travel
will eventually return to pre-corona
demand levels but there is uncertainty
around the future of business travel
companies have been forced to adapt with
Innovative remote working strategies
that may convince some of them that
using the now commonplace video calls
may be better than paying for travel to
in-person meetings
the thing we know for sure is that
everyone's doing their best to limit the
damage not only to the airline industry
but also to individuals and other
businesses
please subscribe to stay up to date with
how the coronavirus is changing the
industry
[Music]
foreign
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
the cruise industry has been rocked by
the coronavirus pandemic high profile
outbreaks like the one aboard Diamond
Princess have left many people thinking
twice about cruising again
with a no sale order from the CDC set to
expire on July 24th the industry has to
make some big changes
can the cruise industry adapt to make
cruising safer for both passengers and
crew
there's no sale order cited what it
believes are health risks associated
with being on cruise ships
let's unpack that order and review some
of the ways Cruise operators May address
those concerns
the number and variety of
person-to-person contacts in semi-close
settings are particularly conducive to
SARS cov2 spread resulting in high
transmission rates
cruises include frequent events that
bring passengers and crew close together
including group and Buffet dining
entertainment events and excursions
to address the spread of covid-19 whose
companies are going to need to address
these three areas cleanliness social
distancing and testing
let's look at cleanliness first
cruise lines have a bit of a head start
on taking cleanliness seriously previous
outbreaks of norovirus aboard cruise
ships have led to intense focus on
cleaning in the past
ships are already equipped with a ton of
hand washing stations throughout the
vessel often hand washing is strictly
enforced by crew members in dining rooms
and common areas
they could further modify these cleaning
strategies with a more intense focus on
high-touch areas like handrails
doorknobs and bathroom fixtures
cruise ships there are many high-touch
areas including self-serve buffets game
rooms and casinos
special attention will need to be paid
to playing cards poker chips and touch
screens too cycling out or disinfecting
contaminated objects wherever possible
social distancing on cruise ships
presents a more difficult challenge
by definition being on a cruise ship
means being in an enclosed space with
many people
while modern cruise ships have a ton of
outdoor space with multiple levels of
decks with pools outdoor bars and even
full water parks a lot of cruising takes
place indoors
restaurants casinos Spas theaters and
most importantly cabins are all indoors
that creates conditions that make it
easy for covid-19 to spread
how could Cruise companies begin to
mitigate this risk
[Music]
first you could reduce the total number
of people
cruise ships would likely reduce
capacity and those routes that do sail
could be shorter and closer to home
fewer people sailing on fewer cruise
ships means fewer chances for the virus
to spread on board period
those that do sail will probably find a
cruise experience to be a bit different
there will likely be scheduled
entertainment limited capacity in
restaurants and you may see the
elimination of self-serve buffets
altogether
according to the CDC close quartering is
a particular concern for crew who
typically eat and sleep in small crowded
spaces
crew members interact with passengers in
all kinds of settings from Food Service
to housekeeping
these are all opportunities for a crew
member to get exposed to the virus an
exposed crew member then goes back to
the shared crew quarters creating more
opportunities for the virus to spread
reducing overall passenger capacity
could create the need for fewer crew
members with more space for the crew
itself specific protocols for keeping
crew members healthy will need to be
developed
investing is the final and most
important piece of the puzzle
reliable widely available testing is
crucial to overcoming this pandemic
overall but it will be of particular
importance to the cruise industry
if cruise lines can get fast and
accurate testing for Coronavirus and its
antibodies they could essentially create
safe ships testing before boarding and
disembarking could create a relatively
safe environment on board and cut down
on the Extreme Measures needed for
Social distancing
there have been reports that some Cruise
companies were not forthcoming about
infection rates with passengers and
local authorities resulting in high
profile investigations in Australia and
New Zealand